Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Es ist auf dem Niveau, auf dem wir jetzt Fußball spielen, in meiner Überzeugung ein ganz klares Players-Game und kein Coaches-Game. Und die Rolle von mir, die Rolle des Trainerteams ist eine Dienstleisterrolle. Wir sind die Dienstleister. Wir unterstützen und helfen.
Ein Trainer ist nicht ein Idiot. Ein Trainer sei, seh, was passiert im Platz.
Ich begrüße euch ganz herzlich zum Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch. Ein Trainer, er ist kein Idiot. Er sieht, was passiert auf dem Platz. Aber sind Trainer wirklich nur Dienstleister, die Spielern helfen oder sind Trainer ganz unwichtig? Wir reden heute über das, was Trainer tun und zwar nicht über Konditionen, Motivation, na vielleicht ein bisschen Motivation, sondern wir wollen über Taktik reden. Ein Tribünengespräch zum Thema Fußballtaktik. Das wollen wir jetzt ausführlich durchsprechen. Und dafür könnte ich mir keinen kompetenteren Gesprächspartner wünschen als denjenigen, den ich hier in der Leitung habe. Ich begrüße Tobias Escher. Hallo, Tobias Escher.
Man muss es auf die Zeit bezogen auch jetzt. Das hatte wahrscheinlich denselben Effekt, wie du es vorhin für den Flachpass bezeichnet hast. Und zwar etwas komplett Neues, wo es auch die Zuschauer dann erst mal gedacht haben, oh, was ist da denn jetzt los? Natürlich wurde auch vorher mal schnell gespielt, aber diesen Fokus dann darauf zu legen, acht Sekunden nach Ball gewinnen, treffen zu wollen, dass wir dann den ein oder anderen Gegner, weil es so etwas völlig Neues war, vollkommen auf dem falschen Fuß erwischt haben.
Ja, das muss für die Würstchenbudenbesitzer ganz schön übel gewesen sein. Da konntest du auf einmal nicht mehr schnell mal dich umdrehen und dir noch eine Wurst kaufen. Da konnte dann tatsächlich was passieren. Okay, damit hätten wir Herbert Chapman erwähnt. Wir wissen eben jetzt, es gibt ein WM-System. Warum heißt das WM-System? Weil wir gucken auf unsere Taktiktafel, die vor uns steht, hochkant. Da haben wir die Stürmer ganz oben, die bilden ein W. Drei ganz vorne und zwei etwas darunter. Die Verteidiger und Mittelfeldspieler darunter bilden ein M. Drei Verteidiger und wieder zwei Mittelfeldspieler in der Mitte. Wir merken jetzt schon, dass wir die ganze Zeit – und deswegen sagt man ja auch England Mutterland des Fußballs – reden wir über England, über Schottland. Und du hast es schon angedeutet. Der Einfluss oder die Verbreitung des Fußballs erst mal fand über England statt, über englische Kontonien, über Internate. So kam der Sport überhaupt erst nach Europa. Und dementsprechend waren auch die Engländer dort Vorreiter. Jetzt kann man aber dann rund um diese Zeit, der 1920er, feststellen, da wurde Fußball auch in Kontinentaleuropa so richtig populär. Ich habe zum Beispiel gefunden, die Besucherzahlen vom Meisterschafts-Endspiel in Deutschland von 1914 und von 1920 und die sind deshalb vergleichbar bei beides Mal der 1. FC Nürnberg mit daran teilgenommen hat. 1914 hatten wir 6.000 Zuschauer beim Finale einer kompletten Saison. Und 1920 waren es schon 35.000 Zuschauer. Das zeigt quasi, da hat sich was bewegt. Das Spiel war jetzt auch in Kontinentaleuropa angekommen. Es war nicht mehr nur so eine englische Fußlümmelei, hat ja glaube ich irgend ein Turnvater es kritisiert. Also jetzt ist es auch in Europa angekommen.
Ich habe noch eine sehr viel eindrucksvollere Zahl. Ja, sehr gerne. Und zwar 1913 hatte der DFB 161.000 Mitglieder. 1920 waren es 755.000.
Ja, stimmt, sehr beeindruckend. Und gleichzeitig muss man da noch sagen, warum hatte es zum Teil der Fußball auch in dieser Zeit, also wenn wir jetzt von Deutschland sprechen, vor allem so schwer, weil es gab schon etablierte Sportarten. Ich habe jetzt leider die genaue Zahl nicht da, aber ich glaube, gelesen zu haben, dass Turnvereine damals um die sechs Millionen Mitglieder hatten. Das sind quasi Dimensionen, in denen sich heute der Fußball bewegt. Das heißt, es war nicht so, dass alle gesagt haben, toll, ein neues Spiel, wo wir ein großes Feld brauchen, ein Ball und 22 Spieler, sondern die Leute haben eher gesagt, was soll denn das überhaupt? Der eigentliche Sport ist doch, sich an einem Rack aufzuschwingen oder einen Strecksprung zu machen, nachdem man eine formvollendete Rolle gemacht hat.
Da muss ich kurz unterbrechen, weil Turnen damals ein anderer Sport war als heute. Turnen war damals nicht auf Wettbewerb größtenteils, sondern da wurden vorgegebene Formen gemacht, da war auch sehr viel Gymnastik drin. Da ging es auch sehr viel um Werbehaftigkeit, also darum, sich für den Krieg vorzubereiten. Deswegen war das in der Deutschland, im militarisierten Deutschland, im deutschen Kaiserreich so beliebt.
Fußball als Spielgebiet der Gesellschaft, immer wieder interessant. Wir werden das jetzt immer wieder so am Rande streifen, wollen aber nicht zu tief reingehen, glaube ich. Interessanterweise ist es ja dann gerade auch das Militär, was später den Fußball dann etabliert, allerdings gerade in Deutschland, weil es die perfekte Ablenkung an der Front war. Und unter dem Stichpunkt der Kameradschaft dann auch den Offizieren eigentlich ganz gut gefallen hat, dass die Untergebenen da ein bisschen gekickt haben.
Da jetzt gar nicht zu tief reintauchend, kann ich vielleicht noch hinzufügen, dass es natürlich im Krieg damals war, der Erste Weltkrieg war ein Frontkrieg. Das heißt, die Leute haben sie an der Front beschossen, aber hinter der Front war meistens ziemlich viel los. Da wurde dann Fußball gekickt. Das war, wie Deutschland so Fußball, richtig die Fußballbegeisterung angefangen hat, dass die Soldaten gekickt haben. In anderen kontinentaleuropäischen Ländern war es ein bisschen anders.
Aber dazu vielleicht nochmal ein eigenes Tribünengespräch. Wir wollen ja vor allem über Taktik reden. Also wir halten einfach fest, auch auf Kontinentaleuropa wird Fußball jetzt zu einem Massensport und von immer mehr Betrieben. Und fast konsequenterweise bilden sich damit auch eigene Taktikströmungen. Damals gab es ja auch noch kein Internet, da hätte man ja gar nicht alles kopieren können aus England. Logischerweise haben sich jetzt auch eigene Dinge entwickelt. Und da gucken wir vor allem in die Länder, die an der Donau liegen.
Ja, vielleicht müssen wir da doch tatsächlich nochmal einmal diese Geschichte, wie der Fußball da hingekommen ist, weil ansonsten kann man das schwer verstehen. Deutschland haben wir gesagt sehr stark von Militär geprägt. Österreich und Ungarn, also Österreich-Ungarn war es ja damals sogar noch, war Sport und gerade Fußball sehr viel bürgerlicher geprägt. Da haben sich die Mittelstandskinder, die Fußball gespielt und haben sich nachher in die Kaffeehäuser Wiens oder Budapests gesetzt und haben darüber debattiert, was sie gerade gespielt haben. Das war tatsächlich so der Einfluss. Sieht man auch heutzutage noch, dass da sehr viel England, dass man sehr viel internationaler gedacht hat im Fußball. Wenn man sich die österreichischen Fußballbegriffe anguckt, da spricht man doch heute von einer Korna bei einer Ecke oder einem Penalty als Strafstoß, weil niemand einen Sinn darin gesehen hat, diese Dinge einzudeutschen. Und dann hat man auch aus dieser sehr bürgerlich geprägten, sehr auch geistig geprägten Fußballhistorie, hat man in Österreich und in Ungarn Taktiken entwickelt, die sehr durchdacht waren. Wo man sehr viel über Fußball nachgedacht hat.
Also im Grunde das, was wir ja auch viel tun, über Fußball nachdenken. Nur anders als bei uns kamen da noch revolutionärere Dinge raus. Was sind denn dann so die wichtigen Entwicklungen in dieser Zeit?
Die wichtigen Entwicklungen sind, glaube ich, dass sich ein kontinentaleuropäischer Stil herausgearbeitet hat. Einen, den man auch so als Donausschule bezeichnet, eben weil er in Österreich-Ungarn sich entwickelte. Das war ein Fußballstil geprägt von Jimmy Hogan, einem englischen Trainer, der in Österreich und Ungarn lange Zeit gearbeitet hat nach dem Krieg. Und dann aufgegriffen vom österreichischen Trainer Hugo Meisel, der das alte 2-3-5-System benutzt hat, aber es halt mit neuen taktischen Mitteln interpretiert hat. Da reden wir dann tatsächlich das erste Mal über so eine Art Ballbesitzspiel. Ein Spiel, wo man sehr viele Pässe einstreut, wo es darum geht, den Ball möglichst lange in den eigenen Reihen laufen zu lassen, wo technische Perfektion wichtiger war als Kraft. Wo der Mittelläufer erneut eine sehr wichtige Aufgabe hatte, in dem Sinne, dass er der Ballverteiler der Mannschaft war.
Also der Mann auf dem Anstoßpunkt. Okay, lass uns mal erst über das System reden und dann gehen wir nochmal genauer drauf ein, was er verändert hat. Denn du hast ja schon gesagt, die Veränderung war eigentlich nicht das System. Er hat nicht im WM-System gespielt. Wir bewegen uns jetzt so rund um die 30er Jahre. Das österreichische Wunderteam, wie man es genannt hat. Man sagte, mit der Geburtsstunde sei gewesen 1931 bei einem 5 zu 0 gegen Schottland. Warum war das so toll? Na, weil die Schotten damals noch der heiße Scheiß waren im Fußball. Und es eigentlich kaum zu glauben war, dass ein kontinentale europäisches Team überhaupt auch nur gegen die Land zieht. Also sprich, das ist der Zeitraum.
Entschuldigung, dass ich dir eingreife, aber dieses 5 zu 0, vor allen Dingen auch symbolische Wirkung. Schottland, schottischer Flachpass hatten wir genannt. Die galt als das fußballspielerische Nonplusultra. Dann kamen die Österreicher und haben mit ihrem Passspiel diese Schotten auseinandergenommen. Das galt dann als Wachablösung des Flachpassspiels.
Okay, und jetzt könnte man ja meinen, wir sind in den 30er Jahren und wir haben ja gerade eben erst gehört, Chapman hat oben 1925 rum angefangen, ein W und ein M auf die Taktiktaffe zu malen, dass Hugo Meisel und Jimmy Hogan das die auch in diesem WM-System gespielt haben. Tatsächlich haben wir hier aber dann doch wieder die Pyramide.
Aber auch nicht die klassische Pyramide, wenn du darauf jetzt anspielen möchtest.
Genau, das musst du mir jetzt nämlich erklären.
Jetzt kommen wir gleich wieder, kannst du vielleicht wieder dein Fife-Ding gleich benutzen, weil wir tatsächlich reden werden über die falsche 9. Die falsche 9 bezeichnet einen Stürmer, der nicht klassisch wie ein Stürmer im Strafraum darauf wartet, dass ihm der Ball an den Fuß gespielt wird und er das Tor erzielen kann, sondern der andere Aufgabe übernimmt, der oft zurückfällt und aus dem Mittelfeld kommt.
Und warum 9? Weil wir vorhin gelernt haben, die Spielnummerierung und so wie der Mann, über den wir jetzt die ganze Zeit geredet haben, der zentrale Mittelläufer, der auf dem Anschlusspunkt steht, die 5 ist, so ist die 9 derjenige, der im gegnerischen Strafraum in der Mitte steht. Und da steht er eben jetzt nicht immer und deswegen ist er falsch.
Warum falsche 9? Genau, weil er nicht wie ein klassischer, wie ein echter 9 spielt. Den Begriff gab es damals noch nicht, muss man dazu sagen. Der Begriff kam, glaube ich, erst ein paar Jahre später auf. Aber es gab bei Österreich einen Spieler, der so spielte und das war Matthias Sindela, auch bekannt als der Papierne. Warum Papierne? Weil er so eine schmächtige Statur hatte, dass man denken würde, der wäre aus Papier. So dünn war der, aber der am Ball unglaublich viel konnte und der sehr viele Tribbings gemacht hat, sehr viele Pässe gespielt hat, der aber gar kein Torjäger war, sondern der immer aus der Tiefe kam, der immer aus dem Rückraum mit seinen Mitspielern gespielt hat.
Tiefe und Rückraum. Was ist Tiefe in dem Fall?
In dem Sinne ist Tiefe eigentlich falsch benutzt, fällt mir gerade auf. Weil Tiefe eigentlich, wenn man sich den Platz anguckt, Breite ist das, was man nach links und rechts, wenn man dahin spielt, spielt man in die Breite, wenn man nach vorne spielt, spielt man in die Tiefe. Was ich jetzt mit Rückraum meinte, war, dass er nicht vorne drin steht, sondern dass er im Hintergrund war. Wenn man jetzt den Ball auf dem rechten Flügel hat, schematisch, und man spielt ihn dann nach hinten, dann spielt man ihn in den Rückraum. Diagonal nach hinten, hinter den Strafraum, dann spielt man ihn in den Rückraum.
Ist Rückraum tatsächlich immer der Raum hinter dem Ball?
Kann auch der Raum hinter dem Strafraum sein, beispielsweise. Normalerweise würde ich schon behaupten, dass das Rückraum hinter dem Ball ist.
Das heißt, wir schieben mit dem Ball eine Linie, die definiert den Rückraum, so wie das Absatz über die Verteidiger definiert wird. Das haben wir vorhin hoffentlich halbwegs richtig erklärt. Diese Klippe haben wir schon umschiffen, Tobi. Ich bin sehr stolz. Wir haben tatsächlich die erste falsche Neun. Wir haben einen Spieler, der sehr stark am Ball ist, der sich von der Konstitution sehr deutlich unterscheidet. Von vielen Fußballspielern, wie sie damals aussahen. Er war sehr, sehr dünn und schmächtig. Deshalb hat man ihn den Papierennen genannt. Ich habe noch ein berühmtes Zitat von Friedrich Torberg. Das ist ein Dichter und Schriftsteller dazu gefunden, der sagte über ihn, er spielte stets und kämpfte nie. Das zeigt zwei Sachen. Zum einen zeigt das, dass das damals Fußball tatsächlich eine Sache war, mit der sich Intellektuelle beschäftigt haben. Denn warum sonst lässt sich ein Dichter ein Zitat dazu einfallen? Und zum anderen zeigt es, dass er sich mit diesen Zurückfallen ein bisschen rausgezogen hat. Also das ist eigentlich auch relativ leicht zu erklären. Wenn ich mich jetzt immer in den gegnerischen Strafraum stelle, also immer da, wo ich dem gegnerischen Tor am nächsten bin, dann steht mir immer jemand auf den Füßen. Und damals ging es auch noch ruppig zu. Da werde ich ganz schön oft auf die Haken bekommen. Wenn ich mich jetzt aber zurückfallen lasse in den Rückraum, den du ja gerade beschrieben hast, sprich, ich gehe ein bisschen mehr Richtung Mittelfeld, ich entferne mich eigentlich wieder vom gegnerischen Tor, dann entziehe ich mich ja letztlich den drei oder zwei Verteidiger, je nachdem welches System der Gegner spielt, die eigentlich auf mich aufpassen sollen. Und deswegen, daher kommt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen dieses er spielte stets und kämpfte nie. Das hat nicht nur mit seiner Konstitution zu tun, sondern auch mit der Art und Weise, wie er sich positioniert hat auf dem Spielfeld.
Es ist da auch viel, in diesem Zitat steckt auch so ein bisschen österreichische Eigenliebe, sag ich mal. Das ist ja so das österreichische Selbstbild, dass sie dieses elegante eher haben und nicht dieses teutonisch-kämpferische, was man den Deutschen immer darstellt.
Ja, und weißt du an wen mich dieses Zitat auch immer erinnert? Franz Beckenbauer. Und in Deutschland wäre aber dasselbe Zitat über Franz Beckenbauer als Vorwurf verwendet worden. Das ist genau das, was du gerade gesagt hast.
Da kommen wir später noch zu. Da können wir später darüber reden, wenn wir über Beckenbauer reden. Da gibt es auch dann so interessante Geschichten, was das angeht.
Okay, also wir haben ein österreichisches Wunderteam. Wir halten fest, das Besondere war, der mittlere Stürmer, der vordere Stürmer war nicht nur ein ziemlich krasser Dude, sondern er hat seine Position auch noch anders interpretiert. Und deshalb war dieses Team, das eben auch sehr viel auf Ballbesitz gelegt hat. Das heißt, sie haben mit dem Ball etwas anfangen können, sie haben in sich zu passen können. Und deshalb waren sie, obwohl sie nicht das WM-System verwendet haben, was wir ja gerade als große Innovation eingeführt haben, aber weil sie das alte Pyramidensystem verändert haben, waren sie trotzdem überlegen und haben deswegen unter anderem die Schotten mal eben 5-0 weggemacht und haben ganz viele tolle Siege gehabt und wäre da nicht eine ganz dunkle Zeit in der politischen Geschichte Europas dazwischen gekommen, wäre da vermutlich noch so einiges passiert. Gibt es zum Wunderteam noch was, was du hinzufügen möchtest?
Eigentlich nicht an dieser Stelle, nein. Wobei, jetzt kommen wir ins Politische rein. Natürlich das Wunderteam schon nicht mehr ganz das Wunderteam war, als dann der Anschluss kam. Also der Anschluss Österreichs an Deutschland. Österreichs an Deutschland, Entschuldigung. Was natürlich das Traumalm dieses Teams war, war 1934. Die WM in Italien, stimmt doch, oder? 1934, die WM in Italien, wo dann sie das Halbfinale gespielt haben gegen Italien. Wo da dann, wie man heutzutage weiß, dass Mussolini die Schiedsrichter, ich will nicht sagen gekauft hat, aber dass sie Druck ausgesetzt waren und dass dann in diesen Spielen, gerade in diesem Halbfinale, ein paar Entscheidungen gab, die dann proitalienisch ausgefallen sind.
Das ist das eigentlich furchtbare. Wahrscheinlich musste er dafür nicht mal bezahlen. Damals hat die Drohkulisse Mussolinis wahrscheinlich schon gereicht. Wir bewegen uns in faschistischen Zeiten.
Der Bewerber muss auch mal aufhaufen, wenn wir bewegen, ist auch mal rechtlich im schwierigen Gebiet, weil da gibt es dann Italiener, die dann das nicht gerne hören. Aber dieser Titel gilt allgemein als nicht ganz sauberer Titel. 1934 italienischer WM-Titel.
Und generell äußern wir hier eh immer nur Meinungen. So, das ist nämlich ein ganz interessanter Punkt, denn wir haben ja schon so am Rande gestreift, dass der Fußball am Anfang logischerweise noch nicht so organisiert war wie jetzt. Erstmal musste ein Liegen gegründet werden, oder erst mal musste ein Regelwerk festgehalten werden, dann musste ein Liegen gegründet werden, dann haben sich diese Liegen auch in Europa gebildet. Dann gab es das Konzept der Nationalmannschaft und dann gab es die ersten Weltmeisterschaften. Und da hast du mir jetzt die Goldene Brücke gebaut. Uruguay und Italien haben die ersten Weltmeisterschaften gewonnen. Und während ich zu der Uruguayanischen Weltmeisterschaft, ehrlich gesagt, nicht so arg viel gefunden habe, was in taktischer Sicht interessant ist, hat Italien tatsächlich, jetzt mal unabhängig davon, wie der Sieg zustande kam. Aber die haben auch taktisch etwas verändert. Was war denn das?
Da müsstest du mir jetzt kurz auf die Sprünge helfen. Meinst du, dass dieses Mischsystem, das sie hatten, aus WM-System und 235?
Genau, ich hab's mir immer gemerkt als WW-System.
Ja, ich bin da jetzt nicht ganz so fit, deswegen muss ich danach haken. Der Begriff dazu ist, dass der Italienisch-Stil das Metodo, dass sie eine Mixtur geschaffen haben aus 235. Da haben sie dieses 2-3 hinten so ein bisschen übernommen. Wobei sie die äußeren Spieler im Mittelfeld haben, eine etwas andere Rolle übernommen und haben das, was man heutzutage als Außenverteidiger bezeichnen würde. Als als Verteidiger, die außen auf den Seiten spielen. Solche Rollen haben sie dann eingenommen. Wobei es halt noch so eine 2-3 Architektur war wie vom 235. Vorne hatten sie aber schon dieses W aus dem WM-System übernommen. Also die beiden Stürmer sind etwas zurückgehangen, haben etwas weiter hinten gespielt. Italien hat das dann mit sehr viel Kraft dann interpretiert. Die waren eine sehr kräftige Mannschaft mit sehr großgewachsenen Spielern, die aber auch sehr schnell spielen konnten. Also auch sehr schnell das Konterspiel aufziehen konnten.
Also im Grunde kann man sich das ein bisschen so vorstellen. Wir haben auf der einen Taktik-Tafel unsere Pyramide schön aufgefächert von vom Keeper bis vor den Sturm. Und auf der anderen Taktik-Tafel haben wir unser WM-System. Und jetzt schneiden wir die einmal auf Höhe der Mittellinie auseinander und pappen die auseinander. Wir nehmen den unteren Teil, nehmen wir von der Pyramide, aber schieben die ein bisschen breiter. Also die drei in der Mitte, die werden ein bisschen Richtung Außenlinie verschoben. Und vom WM-System nehmen wir uns das W der Stürmer, das heißt drei ganz vorne in Richtung gegnerisches Tor und zwei etwas dahinter im Mittelfeld. Und das pappen wir oben drüber und dann haben wir den Metodo. Gut, Vitorio Pozzo war da ein wichtiger Mann. Allerdings hatte es jetzt nicht die riesigen Auswirkungen, deswegen glaube ich, können wir an der Stelle darüber dann eigentlich hinweggehen. Das war so eine Fußnote. Letztlich, habe es ja schon angedeutet, jetzt hat dann eh erstmal die Politik da so wild rein gefunkt, dass dann auch Fußball taktisch sich dann erstmal nicht so viel getan hat. Was jetzt glaube ich bestimmt noch interessant ist, und das beschreibst du ja auch wunderbar in deinem Buch, ist die Entwicklung in Deutschland. Wir haben jetzt über Österreich-Ungarn gesprochen, wir haben über Italien gesprochen. Wie war es dann mit dem Fußball in Deutschland?
Das werden wir ganz kurz zusammengefasst an so ein paar Stichpunkten. Wir haben darüber geredet, dass in Deutschland das Militär sehr stark als Stützpfeiler gedient hat für den Fußball. Dementsprechend war auch in den Anfangstagen Taktik gerade eine sehr defensive und auch eine sehr kampfbetonte Ansicht. Fußball galt immer so als Kampfmann gegen Mann. In dem Sinne gab es auch sehr früh in Deutschland schon die Mandeckung, die ja international erst mit dem WM-System so richtig kam. In Deutschland war immer Mandeckung. Es gibt dann so kleinere Entwicklungsschritte, die den Fußball modernisiert haben in Deutschland. Der erste Entwicklungsschritt ist der sogenannte süddeutsche Flachpass, mit dem der 1. FC Nürnberg mehrmals Meister geworden ist. Es ist so ein System, das auf dem 2-3-5 baut, das aber auch viele spielerische Elemente beinhält. Das ist sehr stark geprägt auch vom österreichisch-ungarischen Donaufußball. Damit haben sie Anfang der 20er Jahre sehr viel gewonnen. Auch mit zurückhängendem Stürmer und allem dem Pipapo.
Sehr schön, wieder einfach so die größte Zeit des 1. Zurückgehender Stürmer, whatever. Und noch ganz kurz, Flachpass bedeutet einfach ein über den Rasen rollender Ball. Ein weiter Pass oder ein hoher Pass wäre eben quasi, ich knüppel drauf und dann säge dabei durch die Luft. Flachpass bedeutet einfach, ich versuche den Ball im Bodennähe zu halten. Und dadurch hat man halt auch mehr Kontrolle, denn es ist leichter den Ball zu verarbeiten. Das heißt, wenn ich einen Ball flach zugespielt bekomme, dann muss ich nur meinen Fuß ungefähr so hinhalten, dass der den Ball aufhält. Wenn der Ball aber durch die Luft auf mich zusäge, dann muss ich irgendwie erst mit dem Kopf, mit der Brust oder mit was auch immer versuchen, den Ball irgendwie wieder so hinzubekommen, dass ich ihn mit dem Fuß weiter spielen kann. Deswegen ist der flache Pass dem hohen Pass von der Ballverarbeitung her einfach, also wie ich mit dem Ball umgehen kann, überlegen.
Deswegen, wenn ich auf Ballbesitz spielen möchte, spiele ich mit flachen Pässen, weil ich dann mehr Genauigkeit und mehr Ballverarbeitung reinbringen kann.
Genau. Und Ballbesitz bedeutet eben nicht, ich bin derjenige, der nur deswegen zum Kicken eingeladen wird, weil ich der Einzige bin, der einen schönen Fußball hat im Dorf, sondern Ballbesitz bedeutet eben, meine Mannschaft hat das Spielgerät an ihren Füßen und damit versuche ich ein Tor zu schießen. Und die Gegensituation ist einfach, ich bin in der Abwehr, ich versuche das Tor zu verhindern und habe aber gerade selber nicht den Ball, ich muss ihn irgendwie dem Gegner abnehmen. Dankeschön. So, Süddeutscher Flachpass, falsche Neun, whatever, 1. FC Nürnberg, alles klar. Jetzt wissen wir ja heute auch, dass das Ruhegebiet gerade in Sachen Fußball eine große Bedeutung in Deutschland hat und das fing damals schon an.
Das fing damals an, tatsächlich. Die 20er Jahre waren noch sehr in der Hand des süddeutschen Spiels, halt wegen diesem süddeutschen Flachpass, der nicht nur in Nürnberg gespielt wurde, sondern auch in Fürth. Bayern München hat diesen Flachpass dann relativ früh übernommen und dann, ich glaube, 1933 oder 1932 die erste Meisterschaft gewonnen. Im Ruhegebiet hat man dann tatsächlich auch so einen Fußballstil übernommen, was tatsächlich etwas überraschend anmutet. Wenn man heutzutage an das Ruhegebiet denkt, dann denkt man an Malocha, dann denkt man an Kämpfen, dann denkt man an Fußball, der sich vor allen Dingen auf dieses defensive Element beschränkt. Tatsächlich aber der erste große Verein des Ruhegebiets der FC Schalke 04, der den Schalker Kreisel erfunden hat. Schalker Kreisel hat sich einen Journalist ausgedacht, und zwar mit der Begründung, die haben den Ball so lange kreiseln lassen, also so lange von A nach B gespielt, bis sie irgendwann zum Toraufwahl kam. In dem Sinne Schalker Kreisel. Es war ein sehr ballbesitzelastiges Spiel, das mit sehr vielen direkten Pässen ankam. Also das, was man heutzutage als One-Touch-Fußball bezeichnet, als Fußballspiel mit einem Kontakt, also dass man den Ball nicht annimmt, sondern dass man den Ball bekommt und sofort weiterpasst. Das hat Schalke damals schon in Ansätzen gespielt.
Machen viele Leute mich eingeschlossen unfreiwillig, weil sie den Ball so schlecht annehmen, dass es so aussieht, als wollten sie ihn gleich weiterpassen. Aber es ist tatsächlich die hohe Kunst des Fußballs.
Schalke hat es tatsächlich mit Absicht gemacht. Das ist eine interessante Sache, weil sie damit auch einen Ruhrpolstil erst mal geschaffen haben, der bis in die 60er-Jahre hinein eigentlich so war. Da kann ich das Buch, wenn wir vom Fußballträumen von Christoph Biermann empfehlen, der diese Entwicklung im Ruhrgebiet beschreibt.
Und wurde auch getragen von einzigartigen Spieler-Persönlichkeiten. Das haben wir immer wieder. Da muss man auch ein bisschen aufpassen, wo man da die Balance setzt. Es gibt immer einzigartige Spieler und es gibt taktische Veränderungen. Und ganz oft hängen beide Dinge miteinander zusammen. Vermutlich auch deshalb, weil es ein großes fußballerisches Talent braucht, um auch neue taktische Innovationen umzusetzen. Das ist so ein bisschen meine Theorie dazu. Aber das haben wir eben hier bei Schalke auch. Da haben wir auch wirklich mit die besten Spieler Deutschlands gespielt, zu der damaligen Zeit. Und dann auch noch in einem Stil, der den anderen überlegen war, einfach weil er etwas Neues eingeführt hat, auf das man damals erstmal reagieren musste. Es ist ja nicht so wie heute, dass man im Grunde fünf verschiedene Arten hat, wie man verteidigen kann und man auch schneller mal auf etwas reagieren kann. Damals war ja alles noch neu und überraschend.
Fritz Schepern und Ernst Cotorra sind da die Namen auf Schalke. Das ist dann auch eine ganz interessante Frage, die ich auch in meinem Buch versuche zu beantworten, aber auch nicht abschließend beantworten kann. Wieso Schalke damals so gespielt hat? Wie kam dieser Flachbass-Spiel von Süddeutschland nach ins Ruhrgebiet rein? Da ist dann halt auch eine These, dass einfach die Spieler selbst so gut waren, dass sie das halt spielen konnten und dann halt auch getan haben.
Wo wir eben genau diesen Punkt haben, da treffen sich besondere Talente und dadurch kommt es dann auch zu taktischer Innovation. So, wir bewegen uns jetzt in der Zeit der Nazizeit in Deutschland. Also wir kommen jetzt in die 30er Jahre des 20. Jahrhunderts rein. Hier kommt es dann auch irgendwann der Zweite Weltkrieg als die Zäsur in den Leben von so vielen Leuten. Und logischerweise auch in der Fußballtaktik. Das ist ja generell eine sehr komplexe Zeit, in der alles ineinander greift, aber auch in der Fußballtaktik sieht man das. Ich finde, man sieht das so ein bisschen an zwei Namen im Fußballdeutschland und die wären für mich Otto Nerz und Sepp Herberger.
Otto Nerz, er ist der deutsche Nationaltrainer. Ab 1926 hat er die Nationalmannschaft aufbauen dürfen, die bis dahin in Deutschland keine Rolle gespielt hat praktisch. Und der dann zur prägenen Figur für den deutschen Fußball wurde. Einfach, weil er als erster Trainer so eine Organisation aufgebaut hat. Mit Trainer-Ausbildung, mit Taktikkursen für die Spieler, mit Lehrgängen auch für die Spieler, dass sie zur Nationalmannschaft nicht erst zum Spiel kamen, sondern dass man vorher Sachen durchgesprochen hat. Er war ein großer Verfechter, ein großer Freund des englischen Fußballs und ist auch sehr oft gereist nach England und hat dann relativ schnell dieses WM-System für sich entdeckt, das im Jahr bei Arsenal aufgekommen ist. Und hat dann auch dieses WM-System auf Biegen und Brechen der Nationalmannschaft umsetzen wollen. Auch wenn die Spieler es nicht kannten, größtenteils, und auch wenn manche Spieler bei ihm anderen Fußball spielen wollten und sollten, dann ist das das eigentlich. Wir hatten ja vorhin den Schalker Kreisel, der sehr auf Flachpassspiel war, sehr auf Ballbesitzspiel war, aber nur nähert es sich eher an einen Mann, der kontern wollte, der Kraftfußball wollte, der flanken wollte in den Strafraum rein, den dann ein großgewachsener Mittelstürmer am besten reinköpft, der den sehr, sehr schönen Satz gesagt hat. Ich muss es kurz nachschlagen, einen Moment, Sekunde. Aber der ist halt so großartig, weil der die deutsche Entwicklung in den ersten Jahren sehr gut zusammenfasst.
Alles gut. Ist auch deswegen bemerkenswert, dass Nerz so auf Flanken gesetzt hat, weil er ja einerseits großer Fan von Chapman und seinem WN-System war, aber andererseits Chapman Flanken furchtbar ineffizient war. Bei Chapman war es eher so, wie man es auch heute von manchen Mannschaften kennt, dass er gesagt hat, die Stürmer, die ganz an den Außenlinien stehen, die sollen bloß nicht in die Mitte flanken. Das würde viel zu selten zu Toren führen, sondern der hat lieber gesagt, geht ein bisschen mehr Richtung Strafraum, da ist es viel gefährlicher. Und obwohl Nerz ja anerkanter WM-System und auch Chapman Fan war, hat er es aber deutsch interpretiert.
Ja, und das Zitat, das ich meinte, habe ich jetzt gefunden, es lautet, meine Beobachtung im Spitzenfußball der ganzen Welt haben mir klar gemacht, dass Kraft und Härte unumgänglich notwendige Eigenschaften guten Fußballs sind, ohne sie Dekadenz. Ein Zitat, ein großartiges Zitat, das diesen deutschen Fußballstil dieser Jahre zusammenfasst und das auch zeigt, worauf Nerz einen Wert gelegt hat. Und das dann auch so ein bisschen, ich will jetzt hier gar nicht chemisch sein, aber ein bisschen erklären, wieso bei ihm, wie auch beim ganzen deutschen Fußball dieser Übergang von Weimarer Republik zu Nazi-Zeit sehr fließend war. Das ist ja jetzt nichts unbedingt, was sich beißt mit der Nazi-Ideologie und Nerz war auch kein Mann, der sich mit der Nazi-Ideologie biss, sondern ein Mann, der sich damit schnell anfreundete, schnell in die Partei eintrat und auch schnell das Konditionstraining der Nationalmannschaft überlassen hat.
Was ja auch schon krass ist, das muss man sich wirklich auf der Zunge zu gehen lassen, nicht, weil es ist ein sehr fader Beigeschmack, aber du lässt die SA deine Mannschaft trainieren.
Gut.
Wie hat denn die Nationalelf damals gespielt, also jetzt nicht ergebnistechnisch, sondern war das so, wie sich das Zitat liest?
Tatsächlich war es so, wie sich das Zitat liest. Nertz war einer, der sehr viel Kondition hat trainieren lassen, der sehr viel Wert auf die taktische Disziplin gerade in der Defensive gelegt hat. Es gab dann immer so kleinere Ausnahmen, die aber nicht groß der Rede wert waren. Was halt ein richtig spannender Aspekt daran ist, wenn man die WM 1934 anschaut, das war der erste große deutsche Erfolg. Nertz hat es geschafft, die Mannschaft bis ins Halbfinale zu führen. Und dann hat man nachher das Halbfinale verloren. Aber das Spiel um Platz drei gegen den Erzrivalen Österreich hat man mit 3 zu 2 gewonnen. Das war ein riesiger Erfolg damals für Deutschland. Aber er hat halt auch mit diesem sehr kampfbetonten WM-System gespielt. Und hat vor allem Fritz Czepan, die wir ihn vorher schon genannt hatten, beim Ruhrgebietsfußball. Den hat er nicht etwa als Stürmer oder als Mittelfeldspieler. Nein, er hat ihn als zentralen Abwehrspieler eingesetzt. Und hat ihm verboten, über die Mittelfeldlinie zu gehen. Was praktisch bedeutet hat, dass er nicht am Offensivspiel teilnahm. Weil in jener Zeit spielte sich das Offensivspiel meistens am Strafraum ab. Das muss man sich insofern auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, als dass Czepan einer der größten Techniker ist, den der deutsche Fußball je hervorgebracht hat. Aber er wollte, Netz wollte unbedingt verhindern, dass er anfängt vorne mit seinem Kabinettsstückchen, mit seinem Passspiel.
Also als würde ich Plisod Özil einfach hinten in die Abwehr stellen, würde er aber auch sagen, hier mein Lieber, über die Mittellinie gehst du aber auch nicht drüber, sondern du bleibst jetzt schön mal hier hinten.
Ja, so kann man sich das vorstellen. Aber es war sehr erfolgreich, muss man sagen. Man hat damit dann die Gegner überrascht und ist dann ins Halbfinale völlig überraschend vorgestoßen.
Gut, und den zweiten Namen, den ich schon genannt habe, der natürlich auch viel, viel geläufiger ist aufgrund dessen, was er dann erreicht hat, ist Czep Herberger. Und bevor wir jetzt, ich will noch nicht über die WM 54 reden, denn davor würde ich gern noch erklären, warum eigentlich die Ungarn damals so gut waren. Aber Herberger hat ja den deutschen Fußball maßgeblich geprägt in dieser Zeit. Und der hatte irgendwie eine kuriose Beziehung zu Otto Nerz.
Herberger ist für mich, ich überlege gerade, ob ich den superlativ gebrauchen möchte, aber ich möchte ihn gebrauchen. Er ist eigentlich die interessanteste Figur an der deutschen Fußballgeschichte. Man müsste eigentlich einen eigenen Podcast machen, nur über Sepp Herberger. Oh, don't challenge me. Man müsste eigentlich auch nochmal eine Biografie über Sepp Herberger schreiben, auch wenn es schon eine sehr gute gibt von Leinemann. Aber Sepp Herberger kam aus ganz einfachen Verhältnissen. Er kam aus der Mannheimer Spiegelstadt. Das ist ein Arbeiterviertel, das gerade damals sehr erblich geprägt war. Er hat sich dann nach oben gearbeitet durch harte Arbeit, durch Fußballspielen. Er ist der Erste, der sich von ganz unten nach ganz oben gearbeitet hat. Das hat dann aber letztlich auch zu Verwerfungen geführt mit Otto Nerz. Weil Herberger einfach einen ganz anderen Herkunft war als der Professor Nerz, der später dann auch als Medizinprofessor gearbeitet hat. Der sehr viel bürgerlicher war, der auch diese Härte sehr viel stärker propagiert hat. Wohingegen natürlich Herberger als Arbeitersohn auch, ich sag mal, eine gewisse Lockerheit hatte. Der hatte das Fußballspielen auf der Straße gelernt. Der konnte halt mit so Straßentypen, wie in Japan, sehr gut umgehen. Weil er selber letztendlich einer so einer war. Und das hat dann letztendlich auch zu taktischen Verwerfungen geführt. Weil Herr Herberger bis 1936 Co-Trainer von Nerz war, aber auch nicht mit allem einverstanden war, was Nerz wollte. Er wollte eigentlich einen spielstärkeren Stil auch haben. Er wollte auch, dass man diese Manndeckung, diesen Kampffußball dann auch mal mit so einem leicht österreichisch-schottischen Flair mischt. Und das hat letztendlich zu Stress geführt.
Okay, das heißt, hier trafen unterschiedliche Arten, wie man Fußball spielen lassen möchte aufeinander. Und der eine stellt eben Mesut Özil in die Abwehr und sagt ihm, Mittellinie ist Schluss, mein Freund, und hör bloß auf mit deinen flachen Pessen. Und der andere sagt, ne, ich möchte dich eigentlich gerne vorne drin haben. Lohnt es sich, darüber zu reden, was dann passiert ist in der Zeit ab 36, wo Sepp Herberger dann übernommen hat? Und vorher war er ja auch, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, quasi auch schon im Jahr davor quasi schon Trainer und Nahtz war nur noch ausführende Person seiner Anweisungen. Ist das fußballtaktisch interessant, was Herberger damals aufgebaut hat, oder ist das vor allem geschichtlich interessant, was eine wahnsinnige Zeit damals war?
Es ist für das, was wir hier versuchen, eine Geschichte der Fußballtaktik jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig spannend, das stimmt. In dem Sinne, dass er nichts gemacht hat, was irgendwie revolutionär war, oder was dann den Fußball weiter beeinflusst hat. Es ist natürlich geschichtlich schlausspannend, wenn man sich die Geschichte der WM 1938 alleine anschaut. Der Anschluss Österreichs an Deutschland kurz vor der WM 1938 geschehen, der einfach völlige Planung durcheinander geworfen hat, weil der DFB ganz klar gesagt hat, es gibt für uns nur eine Lösung und das heißt 6 plus 5. Heißt, sechs deutsche Spieler und fünf österreichische müssen auflaufen. Klar. Muss mit einer Mannschaft aus zusammengewürfelten Spieler. Und auch gar nicht, wie Herberger das möchte, sondern ganz klar 6 zu 5.
Das ist typisch deutsch, oder?
Dann hat Herr Herberger auch gesagt, das funktioniert nicht. Die Deutschen sind jahrelang von Netz diesen Kraftfußball gewohnt gewesen. Und die Österreicher spielen ihr Flachballspiel und wollen am liebsten nie ins Tor schießen. Wie soll ich das unter einen Hut bringen? Hat dann natürlich auch nicht funktioniert. Deutschland ist bei der WM 1938 gegen die Schweiz ausgeschieden, ohne dass sie wirklich einen Stich gesehen haben. Das ist in dem Sinne natürlich eine sehr interessante Zeit, weil man da diese sieht, wie die Taktik auch politisch wirken kann.
Ja, vor allem auch verbandspolitisch. Das hat den Fußball als Sportverband wahnsinnig zurückgeworfen. Das waren ja die berühmt-berüchtigten Olympischen Spiele von Berlin. Da musste Adolf Hitler noch überredet werden, sich Fußball anzugucken. Er war kein Fußballfan, weil er eben auch gesagt hat, ja, Individualsport ist besser und was soll dieses Rumgekicke. Dann haben sie ihn überredet, dass er ins Stadion kommt. Und dann verlieren sie gegen Norwegen, glaube ich, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Das muss ich jetzt ein bisschen verbessern. Sorry, weil du wirbst da gerade zwei Sachen durcheinander. Der Anschluss und dieses Anschlussspiel bei 1938, also diese WM. Und 1936, da war noch Nerz tatsächlich Bundespräsident.
Ach, das war dann, ja, okay.
Das war das, wo Nerz nämlich seinen Job mit verloren hat.
Stimmt.
Es ist bis heute nicht umstritten, ob Hitler da war. Ich habe auch keinen eindeutigen Beweis gefunden, dass Hitler tatsächlich bei diesem Spiel war. Aber tatsächlich haben sie 2-0 gegen Norwegen verloren. Und tatsächlich war Goebbels auf jeden Fall da.
Ich dachte mir nämlich auch schon, wie 38 eigentlich Olympische Spiele sein konnten, wenn das nicht durch… Sorry.
Das ist dann der zweite Punkt. Aber das ist jetzt auch gar nicht wieder taktisch rein. Deswegen ist es eine interessante Phase im deutschen Fußball. Auf jeden Fall. Da kann man fünf eigene Podcasts mitfüllen. Aber taktisch ging es dann erst nach dem Krieg wieder mit neuen Entwicklungen weiter.
Übrigens, es ist auch spannend geschrieben in deinem Buch. Ich habe zu der Zeit schon viel gelesen. Es gibt auch von Nils Havelang, glaube ich, heißt er, Fußball unterm Hakenkreuz. Sehr interessant, ziemlich wissenschaftlich. Aber es gibt tolle Bücher über die Zeit damals. Aber das habe ich auch wirklich in deinem Buch nochmal sehr gerne gelesen, diese Kapitel, wie sich das alles in Deutschland entwickelt hat. Und ja, einfach eine krasse Zeit.
Um jetzt hier nochmal schön den Werbebalken zu schwingen und auch nochmal schön die Leute heißen, es gibt auch eine ganz spannende Episode in dem Buch aus der Zeit, wo dann die Politik, die Nazis nochmal versucht haben, taktisch Einfluss zu nehmen auf den Fußball. Ich werde es jetzt nicht spoilern.
Ich habe es extra auch nicht gespoilert. Aber wirklich, kauft euch das Buch. Es ist wirklich, wirklich sehr lohnenswert. Aber wenn ihr bis hierhin gehört habt, dann wisst ihr das eh schon. So, Sepp Herberger wird nochmal auftauchen, denn wir alle wissen, da kann ich jetzt – also Achtung, Spoiler-Alarm – Deutschland hat die WM 1954 gewonnen. Krass. Man nennt es das Wunder von Bern. Spoiler-Alarm, Ende. Jetzt könnt ihr wieder weiterhören, wenn ihr euch die Spannung nicht nehmen lassen wollt. Aber warum das so krass war, um das zu verstehen, muss man wissen, wie Ungarn gespielt hat, die ja der Finalgegner waren. Denn das war eigentlich so der nächste Meilenstein in der fußballtaktischen Entwicklung, der ungarische Stil.
Ja, wir hatten Ungarn jetzt schon ein bisschen erwähnt bei diesem Donaufußball. Beim Donaufußball in den 20er und 30ern wird oft nur Österreich genannt, aber Ungarn war auch angefixt von diesem Flachpassspiel, von diesem Spiel mit den vielen Pässen, mit dem auf Ballbesitz auslegend und mit der technisch hochwertigen Klasse. Das hat man dann weiterentwickelt, während und nach dem Krieg auch vor allen Dingen, und hat dann dieses Flachpassspiel zu einem neuen System ausgebaut, kann man sagen. Man hat das WM-System als Basis genutzt, also nicht wie beim österreichischen Stil das 2-3-5, sondern jetzt das WM-System. Und hat aber dieses WM-System nicht starr interpretiert, sondern hat die Position bis zu einem gewissen Teil aufgelöst. Das heißt, das bedeutet, dass gerade vorne diese 2-3-Formationen, also hatten wir dieses W, zwei etwas zurückhängende Stürmer, drei weiter vorne, dass dies nicht mehr in dieser Dogmatik betrieben wurde, sondern dass da sehr flexibel getauscht wurde. Die Spieler tauschen die Positionen untereinander, die Spieler gegen nach vorne rein, die fehlen zurück.
Was damals krass war. Heute kennt man das.
Ja, damals war das sehr, sehr krass.
Genau, da wussten die, da kommen wir letztlich auch wieder zum Thema Mannendeckung, was ist Raumdeckung. Wenn ich jetzt, ich bin der Kaufhausdetektiv, ich und meine beiden anderen Detektive, wir laufen immer drei Kunden hinterher, und jetzt wechseln die ständig. Da läuft ständig einer von der Wurstheke zur Käsetecke und der andere Kreuz. Da muss ich ja überlegen, bleibe ich jetzt an meinem Kunden dran? Oder soll ich lieber der Kaufhausdetektiv den Kunden übernehmen, der die ganze Zeit schon in Richtung der Käsetecke war? Mit dieser Problematik spielt ja letztlich dieses Positionstauschen.
Genau. Was auch sehr wichtig ist, wenn man das größte Spiel anguckt, das diese Mannschaft abgeliefert hat. Das war ein legendäres 6 zu 3 gegen England im Jahr 1953. Man muss es sich so vorstellen, England, Mutterland des Fußballs, heutzutage englische Nationalmannschaften nicht mehr so viel wert. Muss man leider sagen, da ist der Mythos ein bisschen verflogen, aber damals war das wirklich noch das Nonplusultran. Die englische Nationalmannschaft hat ihre Heimspiele alle in Wembley ausgetragen. Die waren in Wembley gegen Mannschaften vom Kontinent ungeschlagen. Da hat noch nie jemand gewinnen können bis 1953. Dann kommt da diese ungerische Mannschaft hin und dominiert das Spiel und gewinnt 6 zu 3. Wobei 6 zu 3 noch immer viel zu niedrig war. Das Ding hätte 20-3 ausgehen können, zu viele Chancen hatten die. Jetzt gibt es diese eine sehr berühmte Geschichte aus dem Spiel. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon gesagt, dem Fußball wurden die Rückennummern immer sehr rangezogen damals. Die Abwehrspieler hatten die 2-3, im Mittelfeld 4-5-6 und so weiter in diesem 2-3-5-System. Da war sehr klar festgegangen, wer mit welcher Nummer spielt. Die Ungarn haben aber deutlich, dass sie so viele Positionswechsel hatten. Sie hatten gespielt, wo sie wollten. Gerade der Stürmer, Nando Hidekuti, der hat das gemacht, was wir vorhin bei der falschen 9 beschrieben hatten. Der ist immer wieder zurückgefallen.
Er war Stürmer und hätte eigentlich im Gegner schon Strafe um oder da stehen sollen. Er ist aber immer weiter weg vom Gegner schon vorgegangen.
Und das hat den Action-Kommentator sehr verwirrt, der dann gesagt hat, sie werden vielleicht verwirrt sein, wo sich denn die Spieler hinbewegen. Die Ungarn nehmen es nicht so genau mit den Rückennummern. Was schon sehr viel auch über dieses Mindset sagt. Das dann auch erklärt, wieso die Engländer so überfordert waren. Weil auch der Verteidiger von Hidekuti, der Mandekar, der wusste nicht, soll ich ihm jetzt folgen oder soll ich jetzt warten? Er hat sich dann meist fürs Warten entschieden, wodurch Hidekuti aus dem Hintergrund zig Tore einleiten konnte. Und im Endeffekt hieß es dann 6 zu 3 für Ungarn.
Und man muss sich wirklich nochmal überlegen. Wir haben vorhin darüber geredet, erstes dokumentiertes Länderspiel 1872. Wir sind jetzt im Jahr 1953. Das heißt, da liegen 80, 81 geschmeidige Jahre dazwischen. So lange hat England nicht verloren auf eigenem Boden.
Das ist außer gegen Schottland. Gegen Schottland haben sie zwischendurch immer verloren.
Genau, richtig. Aber gegen keine kontinentale europäische Mannschaft. Und dann kommt da eine Mannschaft und spielt die so dermaßen lang, wie F-Jugend gegen A-Jugend. Und auch noch nicht nur mit großartigen Spielern, sondern eben auch mit diesem neuen System. Was heißt neu? Wir haben es ja schon mal gesehen, ein falscher Neuen, aber damit konnte man nicht umgehen.
Der Mythos blieb auch danach noch bestehen. Also, England hat auch die 20 Jahre danach, glaube ich, nur viermal verloren auf heimischen Grund. Also, es war schon was wert, in England zu gewinnen. Das kann man nicht hoch genug einschätzen. Und das war auch damals so tatsächlich, dass der Kicker des Jahres 1953 eine Sonderausgabe zu diesem Spiel gebracht hat. Also zehn Seiten nur über dieses Spiel, weil das halt so historisch war. Und weil die drei Reporter da hatten und dann halt zehn Berichte darüber geschrieben hatten. Das war das Ding damals, dieses Spiel. Und das kann man nicht hoch genug einschätzen.
Das war quasi Mayweather gegen Pacquiao, der Kampf des Jahrhunderts.
Nee, nee, um Gottes Willen, nee, nee, nee. Weil das war wirklich was. Nicht, dass da ein Sky-Kommentator kam und uns eingeredet hat, kauft den Kampf des Jahrhunderts. Das war wirklich der Kampf des Jahrhunderts.
Also sechs zu drei. Und jetzt haben wir über Hidikoti schon gesprochen. Das war eben der Mann, der die falsche Neu gemacht hat. Der hat sich zurückfallen lassen. Und wir haben schon über ganz viele Positionswechsel gesprochen. Jetzt brauche ich ja aber auch Spieler, die sowas überhaupt spielen können. Heutzutage hört sich das gar nicht mehr so dramatisch an, aber wir haben ja schon versucht, rauszuarbeiten. Damals war das sehr, sehr ungewöhnlich, dass jemand, der auf seiner Rückennummer eigentlich stehen hatte, du spielst jetzt links in der Verteidigung, dann vielleicht auch einfach mal im Mittelfeld aufgetaucht ist. Das heißt, du musstest auch Spieler haben, die sowas spielen konnten. Das heißt, hier traf wieder unglaubliches Talent auf eine taktische Innovation und beides hat sich gegenseitig befruchtet. Wer waren denn da so die wichtigsten Namen im ungarischen Team?
Der wichtigste Name ist wahrscheinlich Major Pushkas. Major ist sein Spitzname, weil er, wie die meisten anderen Spieler von der ungarischen Nationalmannschaft bei der Armee angestellt war. Der hat als Stürmer gespielt, gilt als einer der größten Stürmer aller Zeiten. Das völlig zu Recht. Der hat einen unglaublichen Drang zum Tor und hat dann dieses Zurückfallen von Hidekoti mit seinem Läufen nach vorne wettgemacht. Wichtiger Spieler auch Boszczyk, der quasi diese Rolle gespielt hat, die wir vorhin als Mittelläufer bezeichnet hat, aus dem Mittelfeld heraus. Die Bälle verteilt hat, aber der halt auch zum ersten Mal tatsächlich so einen Spielmacher aus der Tiefe gegeben hat. Das gab es bis dahin auch nicht.
Wobei wir den klassischen Mittelläufer hier nicht haben. Also in dem WM-System habe ich ja keinen, der auf dem Anstoßkreis steht. Er war eine der Spitzen vom M.
Kann man so sagen, ja. Wenn man es sowieso schematisch darstellen möchte, ist es relativ schwierig bei den Ungarn durch die Positionswechsel. Aber wenn man es darstellen möchte, könnte man vielleicht sogar fast sagen, dass sie vorne mit so einem 1-4 gespielt haben, also dem zurückhängenden Stürmer als 1, und dann vorne die 4. Und hinten haben sie aber auch so eine Art 4-1 gespielt. Einfach weil Boszik so viel weiter vorgespielt hat als sein Nebenmann, dass er quasi dann der sechste Angreifer war. Also man kann es so als 4-1-1-4, wenn man möchte, bezeichnen.
Und dann habe ich gelesen, dass wir hier den ersten Manuel Neuer erlebt haben im Tor. Csula Grosic, der ungarische Torhüter, hat später auch in Interviews gesagt, naja, wir haben halt auch die Abwehrreihe weit vor verschoben. Also man nennt das Hochverteidigen. Ich mache mal die Pfeife selbst, damit wir uns an das Geräusch gewöhnen und uns nicht entwöhnen. Hochverteidigen, das bedeutet quasi, wenn wir uns jetzt die Taktik-Tafel angucken, dann positionieren wir die Verteidiger ja immer so auf Höhe des eigenen Strafraumes, das heißt in Richtung des eigenen Tores. Und wenn ich die jetzt einfach nach oben verschiebe in Richtung gegnerisches Tor, dann verteidige ich höher. Das ist tatsächlich dann buchstäblich so auf der Taktik-Tafel zu sehen. Was im Umkehrschluss bedeutet, es gibt einen größeren Raum hinter der Verteidigung, der ja nicht kontrolliert wird. Und da hat dann der Torhüter eine ganz neue Rolle gefunden.
Ja, wobei es jetzt nicht so extrem, glaube ich, ist, wie du es gerade erklärt hast. Das klingt jetzt schon sehr revolutionär, was du gerade erklärt hast. Letztlich war es noch nicht so, dass wir jetzt hier von der Abseits-Falle zum Beispiel reden können. Also, dass die gesamte Abwehr nach vorne gerückt, kollektiv, um den Gegner ans Abseits zu stellen. Sondern, das ist natürlich für Einzelne so wahr, dass Ungarn aufgrund dieses Ballbesitzspiels sehr hoch stand. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob der als erster Manuel Neuer gilt, oder als ob er sich als solcher selbst stilisiert hat. Da kann ich nicht so viel sagen. Ich bin auch kein Torwartexperte, was das angeht. Normalerweise gilt der Lev Yashin, der sowjetische Torwart, der später kam als erster großer spielerischer Torwart.
Ich habe mehrfach gelesen in mehreren Quellen, dass er damals schon manchmal seine Linie verlassen hat und quasi Pässe, die steil gespielt waren. Steil meint in dem Sinne vertikal, so wie wir es vorhin besprochen haben. Wenn wir auf die Taktiktafel gucken, spiele ich von unten nach oben zum gegnerischen Tor, dass er die öfter mal abgefangen hat. Und damals ist der Torwart einfach in seinem Kasten geblieben. Das war damals schon neu, aber er hat es bestimmt nicht so interpretiert, wie dann später die nach ihm. Okay, was müssen wir über die Ungarn noch wissen? Wir haben jetzt die wichtigsten Spieler, Boszczyk, Puskás, Hidikuti. Und wir wissen, sie haben England mal so dermaßen eine Wartung gegeben, 1953, und haben jetzt tatsächlich 32 Spiele in Folge nicht verloren.
Bei der IWM 54, also sie sind zur WM 54 als klare Favorit gefahren, haben dann die ersten Spiele auch alle gewonnen und sind dann ins Finale gekommen mit 32 Siegen in Folge.
Genau, das heißt Haus, Haus, Haus, hoher Favorit. Und jetzt kommt dieses Finale von Bern, von der WM 1954, mit Sepp Herberger. Und das soll jetzt ein bisschen verdeutlichen, warum das damals ein Wunder von Bern war, dass Deutschland da gewonnen hat. Sepp Herberger war beim Spiel 1953 beim 6 zu 3 gegen England anwesend. Und welche Schlüsse hat er da mitgenommen, die dann im Finale wieder wichtig wurden?
Er war anwesend und vor allen Dingen hat er sich auch eine Videokopie des Spiels geben lassen. Das ist auch nochmal sehr interessant, weil er nämlich auch das Spiel mit der deutschen Mannschaft im Kino nochmal gesehen hat. Er hat ihm das vor der WM im Kino gezeigt. Die gesamte Mannschaft kannte dieses Spiel, dieses 6 zu 3. Und er hat nämlich gesagt, Mensch, 6 Tore, die sind offensiv ja ziemlich gut, aber dahinten haben sie auch 3 gefangen. Also da gibt es ja anscheinend eine Schwachstelle, die man bespielen kann. Was er gemacht hat vor allen Dingen ist, er hat hinten sich was aufgedacht gegen die falschen neuen Hitekutti. Und zwar war das so eine Ansätze einer Raumdeckung. Und zwar haben sich nämlich der zentrale Verteidiger und einer der Mittelfeldspieler, also in dem 3-2, zwei Spieler aus der Mitte, einer hinten bei der 3, die Mitte und einer davor, haben sich immer abgewechselt damit, wer Hitekutti abdeckt. Mal war das Horst Eckell, der Mann im Mittelfeld, mal war das, ich glaube, Liebrich war das dann hinten als zentraler Verteidiger. Und die haben sich dann abgewechselt dahin. Und damit ist natürlich dieses Loch nicht entstanden und auch nicht diese Freiräume für den Hitekutti, die es beim Spiel gegen England gab. Vorne wiederum hat Deutschland halt ebenfalls mit vielen Positionswechseln gearbeitet. Das kann man, glaube ich, am besten versinnenbildlichen, weil dieses Tor, den jeder kennt, das 3 zu 2. Dieses, aus dem Hintergrund müsste Rahen schießen. Rahen war aber eigentlich Außenstürmer. Rahen hätte eigentlich, wenn man das jetzt ganz klasse spielt, hätte der gar nicht aus dem Hintergrund schießen können, weil er im Zentrum im Hintergrund war. Da kann man sehr gut sehen, wie sie mit diesen Positionswechseln gearbeitet haben. Das waren also diese Zwei-Eck-Pfeiler.
Okay, das heißt, ich fasse jetzt nochmal meine Worte zusammen. Herberger hat zumindest in diesem Spiel das Problem gelöst, vor das Ungarn seine Gegner damals gestellt hat, nämlich dadurch, dass sie mit einem falschen Stürmer gespielt haben. Der hat sich getarnt als Stürmer, dieser fiese Hund, und hat sich aber ständig zurückfallen lassen und hat dann von hinten heraus Angriffe eingeleitet. Für die Mannschaften, die verteidigen mussten, war das Problem, welcher der Verteidiger übernimmt jetzt wann den Stürmer, der sich zurückfallen lässt, und wie deckt man die anderen, die ja vorne dann anspielbar sind. Das hat er gelöst, indem er da eine klare Rollenverteilung gegeben hat und vorne drin hat er letztlich Copy und Paste ein bisschen gemacht, also mit anderem Spielermaterial. Aber vorne hat er den sogenannten Wirbel gespielt, das heißt, er hat auch die Position wechseln lassen und er hat auch den Spielern, die an den Außenlinien stehen, gesagt, ihr dürft nach innen ziehen. Das habe ich vorhin bei Chapman schonmal angesprochen. Du ziehst sie quasi letztlich in einen Bereich näher zum gegnerischen Tor und dann kannst du halt auch als Helmut Rahn einfach mal aus dem Hintergrund schießen. Normalerweise hätte er außen auf der Außenlinie stehen müssen.
Wobei Herrberger diesen Wirbel, wie er es getauft hat, schon viel länger hat spielen lassen. Also der war jetzt nicht so, dass der von den Ungarn kam. Das war auch etwas, was er schon in seinen ersten Jahren gemacht hat. Was seine Reminiszenz an den Donaufußball quasi war. Die Entwicklung bei beiden war parallel in Ungarn und in Deutschland. Das hat sich beides aus diesem Passspielen des Donaufußballs entwickelt. Dass man gesagt hat, wenn wir jetzt vorne die Position flexibel tauschen, dann können wir den Gegner verwirren und unser Passspiel noch besser aufziehen.
Letztlich hat das ja auch anleihen beim Schalke Kreisel. Es war kein neues System, aber er hat es spielen lassen. Das waren quasi die taktischen Dinge. Es gibt noch eine schöne Anekdote, was der Perberger nach Spielschluss gemacht hat, was auch eine taktische Dimension anspricht. Die kannte ich noch nicht. Die habe ich in deinem Buch gelernt.
Die ist auch verloren gegangen. Die habe ich bei Uli Hesse entdeckt. Der Journalistenkollege hat bei sich eine riesige Sammlung an Büchern und an alten Kickerausgaben, die ich für mein Buch immer wieder ausgeliehen und mir angeschaut habe. Der hat bei sich zu Hause ein kleines Büchlein an Anekdoten über Sepp Herberger aus dem Jahr 1963. Da ist diese schöne Anekdote drin. Er hat nach dem Spielschluss von der WM54 mit seiner Mannschaft gefeiert. Er ist dann zu den Ungarn in die Kabine gelaufen und hat sich mit den Ungarn unterhalten. Er hat dann das Schöne gesagt, er habe Boszczyk als freien Mann vor der Abwehr spielen lassen. Das kannte ich noch nicht, das werde ich jetzt auch mal versuchen. Deutschland hat gerade überraschend die WM54 gewonnen. Er überlegt sich, was kann ich von dem Gegner übernehmen, dass ich im nächsten Spiel besser bin. Das fasst diesen Charakter Herberger einfach so unfassbar gut zusammen.
Und ich musste tatsächlich daran denken – naja, ist ja so.
Entschuldigung, krasser Nerd, bist du pressend, aber wie trocken du das schon gerade gesagt hast.
Mir fiel da wiederum auf, ich habe diese Sonderrolle von Boszczyk, die kannte ich vorher nicht. Die habe ich in deinem Buch gelernt und im Nachhinein ist mir dann wieder aufgefallen, wie oft ja Herbert Zimmermann ist das sein Vorname, also Zimmermann, der Kommentator des Wunder von Bernds. Da gibt es ja die berühmte Passage, wo er sagt Boszczyk, Boszczyk, immer wieder Boszczyk. Man hat das auch aus der Radioreportage, die kenne ich eben, schon damals rausgehört, wie prägend Boszczyk war. Wir lassen jetzt mal noch ein paar Aspekte hier hier außen vor. Also wir haben jetzt gerade viel über Taktik geredet. Es gibt allein zu diesem Spiel ganz, ganz viele andere Themen, die auch noch wichtig sind, von schönen Themen, wie es hat geregnet und angeblich hatten die Deutschen einen technischen Vorteil durch Stollenschuhe bis hin zu mentalen Dingen. Auch hier haben wir natürlich Leidenschaft, Kampf, Kameradschaft und tolle One-Liner vom Sepp, die er schon vorher rausgehauen hat, um die Journalisten zu beruhigen, bis hin zu einem verrückten Turnierverlauf, bis hin zu auch Glück zu einer Torwartleistung, die einfach – Wie hat Zimmermann gesagt? Du bist ein Goldjunge, glaube ich. Ach ja klar, Toni, du bist ein Fußballgott. Dafür musste sich doch dann Zimmermann später noch entschuldigen. Das heißt, was ich damit antworten möchte und erwähnt sei auch noch, dass es im Doping-Gerüchte rund um die Weltmeistermannschaft von damals gibt. Was ich damit andäufe. Ich möchte sagen, es spielt immer viel rein zur Taktik. Es ist nicht immer nur einfach, wir verschieben jetzt hier ein paar Figuren und dann machen wir noch einen falschen Neuner und hinten teilen wir uns die Verteidigung des anderen falschen Neuners auf, sondern es kommen halt einfach immer noch andere Aspekte mit rein. Das ist so eine Gemengelage und dann ist es manchmal halt auch schwierig zu unterscheiden, woher kommt jetzt der Sieg? Ist der jetzt taktisch begründet oder nicht?
Das ist gut, dass du das jetzt hier erwähnst, weil das natürlich so ein berühmtes Spiel ist, an dem man das sehr gut aufzeigen kann, weil es da einfach so viele Wege und so viele Geschichten drum herum gibt, die einfach alle irgendwie reinspielen in das Ergebnis letztlich. In dem Sinne halt auch natürlich Taktik immer nur ein Erklärungsansatz von vielen und wir haben es ja auch schon gesagt, es geht auch immer um die Menschen, um die Fußballspieler darin. Wenn du natürlich die richtigen Spieler hast, kannst du eine bestimmte Taktik spielen und wenn du die nicht hast, dann musst du dir irgendwas ausdenken, wie du den Gegner trotzdem ärgern kannst.
Taktik als Mittel der unterliegenden Mannschaft, da haben wir später noch ein schönes Thomas Tuchel-Zitat dazu. Jetzt hast du aber ja gesagt, Sepp Herberger ist vielleicht die wichtigste deutsche Figur für deutsche Fußballtaktik. Das heißt, auch wenn wir jetzt gerade hier so relativieren, hat er ja schon viel bewegt. Willst du noch kurz uns allgemein ein bisschen aufklären, jetzt mal unabhängig nur von diesem einen Finale, auf das man ihn ja auch nicht reduzieren sollte, eben auch wegen der ganzen Nebengeschichten, die es dazu gibt. Was hat denn Sepp Herberger anders gemacht und wie war auch sein Prinzip der Gestaltung der Nationalmannschaft?
Da müsste ich jetzt wieder auf mein Buch verweisen, wenn man das genau wissen will. Ich kann jetzt mal so ein paar Stichpunkte in den Raum werfen. Was natürlich der Sepp Herberger geschaffen hat, ist, dass es einen deutschen Fußballstil gab, der sich bis heute eigentlich durchzieht, den man auch heute noch, wenn man möchte, kann man den noch heute im deutschen Fußball sehen. Das ist zwar, dass er einerseits diesen Kampfaspekt sehr hervorgestellt hat, dieses man muss immer um jeden Ball kämpfen, muss immer hinterher rennen, man muss mehr laufen als der Gegner. Wer mehr läuft, gewinnt ein Spiel, ist einer seiner berühmten Werksätze. Aber auch, dass er dieses ein bisschen versöhnt hat mit so einem spielerischen Aspekt. Wir haben ja schon den Wirbel genannt, den er vorne gemacht hat. Wir haben ja schon diese Anleihen gehabt, die er auch aus dem Donaufußball gezogen hat. Also Kampf mit Spielerechtsverbinden, das hat er quasi geschaffen. Dann mit bestimmten taktischen Mitteln, aber das wird jetzt hier wahrscheinlich zu weit führen und auch ein bisschen wieder von unserem Thema ab, wenn wir die jetzt alle im Detail durchgehen.
Ne, das wollen wir nicht tun. Ich wollte nur noch kurz einordnen, wenn ich vorher relativiere das Finale. Da kamen auch noch andere Aspekte dazu, warum Herberger trotzdem viel geändert hat. Ok, Wunder von Bern. Wir machen einen Haken dran und ihr alle da draußen wisst jetzt, Deutschland hat dieses Spiel gewonnen. 3 zu 2 und eine grandiose ungarische Mannschaft. Die beste, ich glaube, der Fußballgeschichte Ungarns blieb titellos. Es gibt immer wieder solche Geschichten. Durch eine verpasste Krönung, durch einen Titel werden das dann irgendwie so verlorene, goldene Generationen. Bevor wir in die in die Finsternis des taktischen Fußballs einsteigen, die jetzt dann anbricht, zumindest wurde es von vielen so stilisiert, das stelle ich auch mal zur Diskussion hier gegenüber, würde ich mal sagen, wenn wir uns jetzt die ganze Zeit schon darüber unterhalten, wie wichtig auch Spieler für ein System und für einen Trainer sind, da hat Pep Guardiola auch was zuzusagen.
Es ist unmöglich, einen Trainer zu gewinnen, ohne Qualität des Spielers. Mit Qualität des Spielers kann man gewinnen mit einem scheißen Trainer.
Dazu ist eigentlich alles, damit ist alles gesagt. Ja, da stimmst du mir offenbar zu. Ja, nee, hast du natürlich recht. Da habe ich eine Sackkasse anmoderiert. Ich wollte damit die Stimmung aufheitern, denn jetzt wird es düster. Ich habe viele Zitate gelesen. Der Untergang des Fußballs wird heraufbeschworen. Ab jetzt bricht eine dunkle Zeit an. Was ist damit gemeint? Es beginnt alles, wie eigentlich recht selten, in der Schweiz.
Wie eigentlich recht selten, sehr schön. Schuld war nicht der Bossa Nova, sondern der Catenaccio. Catenaccio bezeichnet Riegel, und der Riegel wurde erfunden, wenn man so sagen möchte, in der Schweiz von Karl Rappan. Wir hatten schon vorhin erwähnt, 1938 schändliches Ausscheiden der deutschen Nationalmannschaft, bzw. der deutsch-österreichischen Nationalmannschaft, und zwar gegen jene Schweiz. Was nämlich der Herr Rappan gemacht hat, ist, er hat sich gedacht, Mensch, wir haben eh keine Chance gegen die Deutschen. Da müssen wir doch mit einer Defensivtaktik gegenfahren. Er hat es so gemacht, dass er noch einen weiteren Spieler aus dem WM-System in die Abwehr gezogen hat, der dann hinter der Abwehr gespielt hat. In dem Sinne wurde dann aus der 3 hinten eine 1-3, also mit einem Ausputzer hinter der Abwehr. Der Gedanke dieses Ausputzers war, dass der Ausputzer nicht einen Gegenspieler deckt, der keine Manndeckung hat, sondern der, was durchrutscht an Bällen, was durchrutscht an Pässen, das fängt er ab. Er putzt quasi für seine Leute davor aus. Er war quasi ein Raumdecker inmitten einer Manndeckung. Diese Idee hatte er gehabt und aus diesem WM-System wurde dann, durch noch ein paar Umformungen, die jetzt auch alle nicht so wichtig sind, wurde dann letztlich so ein 1-3-3-3. Was halt wichtig ist, dieser Ausputzer hinter der Abwehr, der halt da erfunden wurde.
Genau, also das ist quasi das. Vorher konnte man immer schön maximal vier Stangen durch die Spieler durchschießen und dann hatte man einen 1-A-Tischkicker. Und jetzt auf einmal bräuchten wir nochmal eine Extra-Stange, weil vor dem Torhüter, der ja auch schon eins sind auf einer Stange, hängt noch so ein zweiter Typ dran. Und eigentlich wird an dem Bereich auch dann schon wieder die Grenze meiner Analogie sichtbar, denn der war nicht statisch immer fix hinter der Abwehr, sondern der hat halt quasi, wie du es gesagt hast, nur auf Fehler seiner eigenen Mannschaft gewartet, versucht die vorherzusehen, zu antizipieren und auszubügeln dadurch. Deswegen auch Ausputzer.
Genau. In diesem Schweizer Beispiel war es halt hauptsächlich eine Stärkung der Defensive. Dabei dieser Ausputzer hat noch nicht so die Entscheidung, sondern einfach, dass sie mehr Verteidiger hatten. Und dass Deutschland sich da halt wundgespielt hat, um das schöne Wort von… Wund gelegen hat, um das schöne Wort von Man mit Scholl zu benutzen. Wurde dann halt erst wichtig, als dann diese Schweizer Taktik über die Alpen gewandert ist.
Ja, dann lass doch damit darüber gleich reden. Die Schweizer haben eine Überzahlung in der Defensive geschaffen und den Ausputzer erfunden. Und was passierte jetzt, als das mit Hannibal und ein paar Elefanten über die Alpen nach Italien kam?
Die Italiener haben diesen Ausputzer als Erster aufgegriffen und haben diese Idee dann tatsächlich weiterentwickelt. Und haben erstmals in den 50er Jahren flächendeckend mit einem Ausputzer hinter der Abwehr spielen lassen. Dann gab es dann so 1-3-2-4-Systeme, 1-3-3-3-Systeme. Die Nummerierung ist jetzt gar nicht wichtig. Wichtig ist, dass hier die Abwehr ganz klar gestärkt wurde. Also, dass man gesagt hat, wir nehmen diesen Ausputzer, um hinten sicherer zu stehen und opfern dafür eine offensive Kraft. Da kommt natürlich diese italienische Philosophie dazu, die ein Fußballspiel immer 0-0 als natürliches Ergebnis sieht.
War denn das immer schon so oder wurde das nicht erst in dieser Zeit geprägt?
Das ist die Frage, ja. Das ist die spannende Frage. Ich kann es auch selber nicht beantworten, weil dazu bin ich kein Experte des italienischen Fußballs. Es wurde auf jeden Fall dann in diesen Jahren geprägt, gerade auch weil der Cattanaggio, also dieser Riegel mit dem Ausputzer, vor allen Dingen zunächst von schwächeren Teams gespielt wurde. Das waren nicht die Top-Teams, sondern das waren die Teams der italienischen Liga, die abstiegsgefährdet waren, die dann vor allen Dingen in Norditalien, nahe an der Schweiz, gespielt haben, die dann diesen Ausputzer zunächst genutzt haben.
Sie haben quasi den Riegel vorgeschoben und damit wäre vielleicht noch ganz kurz erklärt, warum man es eigentlich den Riegel nennt, obwohl ja der Ausputzer, der wesentliche Bestandteil dieses Systems ist, aber ja.
Kann man vielleicht noch in Deutschland zu sagen. Da heißt es nämlich nicht Riegel, sondern da hieß es dann Doppelstoppersystem. Warum Doppelstopper? Ich hatte ganz vorher mal gesagt, dass der dritte Verteidiger im Zentrum hieß Stopper, deutschen Fußball. Und dann hatte man in dem Sinne mit dem Ausputzer einen zweiten Verteidiger ins Zentrum. Also hatte man doppeltes Zentrum besetzt, Doppelstopper.
Auch schön. So, du hast jetzt schon angesprochen, das hat sich in Italien flächendeckend durchgesetzt, was ja durchaus bemerkenswert ist. Das heißt, eine ganze Liga, sagen wir jetzt einfach mal so, hat so gespielt. Und vor allem die unterlegenen Teams, die sich dadurch einen Vorteil erhofft haben, so wie die Schweiz als unterlegene Mannschaft auf dem Papier sich gegen Deutschland unter Rappan 38 ein Vorteil erspielt hat, indem sie einfach eine Überzahl in der Verteidigung geschafft haben, so haben das die unterlegenden Mannschaften auch gemacht. Und jetzt ist da dann der entscheidende Umschwung, dass plötzlich das auch ein Trainer mit einer Mannschaft macht, die auf dem Papier eigentlich nicht unterlegen wäre.
Ja, Heleno Herrera ist der Mann, der Anfang der 60er auf jeden Fall, ich habe das ein Jahr nicht genau drauf, zu Inter Mailand kam. Inter Mailand, damals schon eine große Adresse des italienischen Fußballs, hatte aber lange nichts mehr gewonnen bzw. hatte noch nie was Großes gewonnen. Und Herrera hat dann diesen Ausputzer genommen, hat darum noch ein noch defensiveres System gebastelt. Also bei ihm war es dann kein 1-3-3-3, sondern ein 1-4-2-3. Also fünf Verteidiger quasi, also Ausputzer hinter einer Vierer Abwehr und dann 2-3 davor. War natürlich ein enorm defensives System in einer Zeit, in der viele, gerade viele bekannte große Teams noch mit einem WM-System gespielt haben. Ein WM-System, das ja drei Verteidiger hat, ist ein ganz krasser Weg dann von diesem System zu einem System, das fünf Verteidiger hat. Und dementsprechend war es natürlich auch zunächst einmal ein sehr defensiver Gedanke hinter diesem neuen System, das dann eine Spitzenmannschaft gespielt hat.
Und er hat das krass durchgezogen, also auch überspitz gesagt, DFB-Pokal, erste Runde gegen Regionallegisten, hat er trotzdem gesagt, Leute, hier ist unser Strafraum, auch die Offensivspieler, also die Stürmer mussten bei ihm Aufgaben fürs Verteidigen verwenden. Wir stellen uns jetzt hinten rein. Aber trotzdem, also so kommt quasi die Null zustande, so fängst du kein Tor. Aber um Erfolg zu haben, musst du ja auch Tore schießen. Wie hat er denn das dann gemacht?
Da kommen wir jetzt zu dem, was eigentlich meiner Meinung nach revolutionär war und weswegen auch diese Hintermannschaft mir manchmal zu negativ gesehen wird. Wir hatten das Thema Konter schon so bei Chapman leicht angesprochen, aber da war das ein ganz anderes Niveau, auch athletisch. Ich würde sagen, dass diese Hintermannschaft die erste Mannschaft war, die wirklich Konterfußball, was wir heute unter Konterfußball verstehen, die wirklich Konterfußball gespielt haben, mit schnellem Spiel, mit langen Bällen nach vorne, mit langen Bällen auf die Außen, um den Gegner möglichst schnell zu treffen, mit richtig schnellem, rasantem Spiel, mit schnellen Stürmern, die hinter die Abwehr starten. Die haben dieses Spiel durchgezogen mit dem Konterspiel. Und wenn sie im DFB-Pokal erste Runde 1-0 vorne lagen, haben sie Konterfußball gespielt. Und das war einfach eine ganz neue Geschwindigkeit, die sie in den Fußball gebracht haben, die ihnen letztlich, meiner Meinung nach, in Europa auch den Vorsprung gebracht hat. Deswegen werden sie da manchmal mehr zu sehr auf diese Fünferabwehr reduziert und gar nicht so sehr auf das, was sie gemacht haben, nämlich den Fußball ein Tick schneller gemacht und diesen Umschaltmoment wirklich eingeführt, dass man den ausnutzt.
Genau, also sie haben den Europapokal gewonnen, 65 und 64. Herr Rehrer war von 1960 bis 1968 bei Inter. Das ist quasi jetzt die Zeitspanne, in der wir uns bewegen. Das ist insofern vielleicht ganz wichtig zu sehen. Das ist jetzt quasi – 1954 hatten wir das Ende der ungarischen Dominanz. Dann hatten wir die Etablierung eines Systems, das eigentlich schon früher begonnen hat, 38. Also das überlagert sich jetzt alles so ein bisschen. Aber es hat sich quasi in den 50ern in Italien so flächendeckend durchgesetzt. Und dann kam Herrera und hat ab 1960 dieses Konterspiel hinzugefügt. Lass uns da noch ein bisschen drüber reden, was das ausprägt. Wir haben vorhin drüber gesprochen. In dem Moment, wo ich den Ball vom Gegner erobere, ist der Gegner meistens in einer Formation, die nicht darauf ausgelegt ist, das eigene Tor zu verteidigen, was ja auch logisch ist. Du hast jetzt schon angesprochen, sie haben schnell gespielt. Das heißt, sie haben schnell nach vorne gepasst. Das könnte ja aber auch ein Kick-and-Rush sein.
Es hat auch so, wenn man es philosophisch betracht, Fußball philosophisch betrachten möchte, Anleihen an das Kick-and-Rush. Das waren auch tatsächlich dann die Engländer, die sehr schnell dieses Spiel übernommen haben als Erste. Die ja dann auch damit 1966, nicht ganz mit so, aber auch mit Konteranleihen, den WM-Titel gewonnen haben. In dem Sinne schon, würde ich sagen, dass da eine gewisse Nähe war. Aber es war natürlich schon was anderes, weil die nicht einfach blind den Ball nach vorne gebolzt haben, sondern sie hatten mit Suárez im Mittelfeld einen Spieler, der sehr spielintelligent war, der genau wusste, wie und wann er die Bälle zu verteilen hat. Und der dann auch genau das gemacht hat, nämlich Bälle in alle Richtungen gespielt. Und zwar so, dass die Mitspieler sie erlaufen konnten. Das war halt dann dieser Unterschied, dass man auch sehr bewusst sich positionierte, nach Beil gewinnt, um halt diesen Umstandmoment aufzunutzen und nicht einfach den Beil nach vorne gebeulst hat.
Und das wäre jetzt für mich die entscheidende Frage, wer ist denn dann nach vorne gegangen? Denn wenn jetzt alle nach vorne gerannt werden wie will, dann hätte er wiederum Herrera die eigene Abwehr entblößt. Und ich glaube, es ist schon zwischen den Zeiten durchgeklungen, er war jetzt nicht so der Typ, der Bock hat, Gegentore zu fangen. Das heißt, wer ist da da vorne gegangen? Waren das die zwei und die drei, die wir schon angesprochen haben? Das heißt, zwei Mittelfeldspieler und drei Stürmer?
Das waren vor allen Dingen die Außenverteidiger. Also wir hatten ja gerade gesprochen von einem 1-4 hinten. Dann kann man natürlich jetzt tatsächlich von Außenverteidigern im modernen Sinne reden, also dass die an den Außenlinien waren, aber auch mit nach vorne gegangen sind. Also nicht nur defensive Aufgaben hatten, sondern auch nach vorne gestoßen sind. Das war Jair auf der rechten Seite sehr stark, der auch teilweise sogar fast schon einen Außenstürmer gespielt hat. Aber das war vor allen Dingen auf der linken Seite Fashetti. Ich hoffe, ich habe ihn richtig ausgesprochen. Faketti, Fashetti. Ich habe es immer nicht so mit italienischen Doppel Cs. Der auf links Verteidiger eine Rolle gespielt hat, die sehr vorstoßend war. Also der halt auch in diesem Kontermoment sofort gestartet ist und sich halt dann auch anspielbar gemacht hat. Und das war tatsächlich was komplett neu ist, dass man diese Außenverteidiger überhaupt, dass man eine Verteidiger nutzt, um nach vorne zu stoßen. Aber gleichzeitig dadurch, dass man ja 1-4 hat, ist dann immer noch ein 1-2 hinten übrig geblieben. Also es war nie so, dass man sich entblößt hat.
Okay, also kann man quasi sagen, wir haben ja vorhin schon bei den Ungern gelernt, die haben die Position so ein bisschen als Erster aufgelöst und damit heillose Verwirrung in England und bei deutschen Kommentatoren gestiftet. Und was Herr Rehrer hier gemacht hat, ist, er hat das Element übernommen, die Abwehr zu stärken, einfach indem er eine Überzahl schafft. Und er hat es sogar noch verstärkt, indem er 1-4 hinten – also da standen fünf Spieler hinten drin, vier Verteidiger und ein Ausputzer. Und wenn es jetzt aber zu diesen Kontern kam, dann wurde das zu einem – ja, wieder fast zu einer Pyramide. Wir haben den Ausputzer, wir haben zwei Verteidiger, wir haben zwei Mittelfeldspieler. Und dadurch, dass die Außenverteidiger sehr weit Richtung gegnerisches Tor gelaufen sind, haben wir wieder fast, je nach Spielsituation, dann wahrscheinlich fünf Stürmer wieder vorne drin gehabt.
Ja, dem kann ich auch nicht viel hinzufügen. Das hast du sehr gut beschrieben. In dem Sinne war es halt nicht nur ein defensives System, was halt oft genannt wird, dieses defensive Moment. Aber durch dieses Vorrücken der Außenverteidiger hatte man was ganz Neues kreiert. Vielleicht noch der Unterschied zu Ungarn. Zehn Jahre zuvor, da waren halt Positionswechsel auch in der Horizontalen. Wir hatten ja vorher gesagt, Horizontale links nach rechts. Da haben die Spieler halt die nebeneinander Positionen getauscht. Jetzt war es tatsächlich so, dass man auch im Vertikalen sehr viel mehr Bewegung hatte, halt durch das Vorstoß der Außenverteidiger zum Beispiel.
Und ich habe das ja jetzt schon mehrmals so anmoderiert. Eine düstere Zeit des Fußballs, Untergang des Fußballs, tatsächlich habe ich da ja auch, wenn man es meinen mag, nicht übertrieben. Also die Reaktionen der Presse damals waren so, dass man tatsächlich gedacht hat, jetzt wird dieses Spiel für Zuschauer vollkommen unattraktiv.
Ja, ich meine, ich kann es immer noch im deutschen Beispiel sehen, weil ich da natürlich drin bin im Thema. Damals kam halt dieses, wie ich genannt habe, Doppelstoppersystem, also auch das Spiel mit Ausputzer. Und das war halt fürchterlich unbeliebt. Also das mochte keiner, weil Deutschland haben viele noch das WM-System, wollten das WM-System sehen. Manche haben sogar noch das Pyramidensystem hinterhergetrauert. Dem guten alten Flachpassspiel Schalker Prägung. Da hat man tatsächlich geglaubt, wenn man diese Bundesliga jetzt 1973 einführt, dann kommt das wieder, dieses Offensivspiel. Dann wird man es schaffen, dass die großen Teams gegeneinander spielen und dann halt versuchen werden, offensive Tracking zu nehmen. War nix da, Pustekuchen. Es kam dann Herrera mit seinem Catenaccio, der dann auch relativ schnell in Deutschland übernommen wurde. Und das wurde dann im Mehrwert auf die Defensive gelegt. Was in dem Sinne natürlich einfach nur eine Weiterentwicklung des Spiels war und natürlich auch eine Professionalisierung des Spiels. Weil natürlich jetzt, da können wir jetzt wieder so einen kleinen Haken schlagen, jetzt mal ein bisschen in den wirtschaftlichen Bereich. Wenn ich natürlich weiß, okay, ich kriege, ich fange kein Tor und ich schieße aber vielleicht noch eins, dann ist das, schafft man das mehr wirtschaftliche Planung, Planensicherheit, als wenn ich dauernd 5-4s habe und dann oder 4-5 verliere oder so was und hinten offenstehe. Das war einfach nur, dieser Katanacu fällt halt genau in diese Phase, wo es halt eine ganz klare Professionalisierung des Fußballspieles kam. Und deswegen wird er auch so negativ gesehen, glaube ich, manchmal. Weil manche Leute halt derzeit dann sich zurückgesehen haben zu diesem Urtümlichen des Fußballs, das aber dann in der Zeit verloren ging.
Ja, da kommt gerade in Deutschland noch das Thema Amateur versus Profi dazu. Ganz heikle Kiste, aber da will ich jetzt gar nicht zu tief mit dir einsteigen. Dann geht das Ganze ja nur am Rande. Jetzt machen wir mal einen kurzen Cut und gucken mal, was wir bis hierhin gesehen haben. Also jetzt mal von den wilden Anfängen abgesehen. Die Schotten haben Pässe erfunden. Okay, cool. Dann hatten wir die Pyramide, die logischerweise allerdings hinten wackelig stand. Sie stand auf einer Spitzen Spitze. Die hat uns Chapman verbreitert, indem er gesagt hat, wir machen hier ein WM-System. Das heißt, wir ziehen da noch einen Verteidiger hinter. Das war quasi jetzt eine defensive Variante. Dann haben wir eine Gegenbewegung, quasi eine Reaktion auf diese Verstärkung der Defensive. Das sind quasi neue Offensiv- also Angreifskonzepte. Wir haben Kreisel, wir haben Positionswechsel und wir haben falsche Stürmer, die sich tarnen als Stürmer, aber eigentlich ins Mittelfeld fallen lassen und andere einsetzen. Das heißt, das war quasi dann die Gegenbewegung zu der Stärkung der Defensive. Da haben sich neue Offensive-Konzepte etabliert. Und jetzt haben wir genau wieder das Rückläufige. Jetzt wurde wieder die Defensive verstärkt. Jetzt kommst du mit dem Kreise nicht mehr weit. Wenn da ein Riegel davor geschoben wird, dann läufst du da einfach auf. Und vor allem mit dem Ausputzer, das finde ich ist sehr, sehr plastisch. Das kann man sich sehr gut vorstellen. Du schickst einen Spieler auf dem Feld, der nur die Aufgabe hat, rechne mit Fehlern deiner Verteidiger und sei quasi dann da. Das ist ja eine vollkommen neue Berufsbezeichnung quasi. Und dass das dann die Defensive stärkt, ist ja auch relativ klar. Das sind jetzt so im Großen die Linien, die wir bisher besprochen haben. Gut, dann habe ich das nämlich alles richtig verstanden und hoffentlich du höre auch. Und jetzt kommen wir zu einem kurzen Exkurs, den wir bisher noch gar nicht so auf dem Schirm hatten, nämlich Fußball wurde ja auch in Südamerika gespielt. Ich habe es ganz kurz erwähnt. Uruguay hat die erste Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen, die jemals veranstaltet wurde. Und noch bedeutender war und auch mit Auswirkung auf den europäischen Fußball, die WM 1958 in Schweden. Denn dort hat Brasilien den Europäern so ein bisschen gezeigt, das ist jetzt meine These, wie es eigentlich geht. Wie kriegt man defensive Stabilität und maximale Unterstützung im Angriff unter einen Hut? Was hat denn da Brasilien gemacht?
Ja, da muss man vielleicht auch nochmal zu Ungarn kurz zurückgreifen, die offensiv sehr stark waren, aber wie wir auch gesagt haben, schon in der Defensiv ihre Schwächen hatten. Und genau diese Schwächen haben die Brasilianer vier Jahre später nicht gehabt. Sie haben ein ähnliches System gespielt. Sie haben aus diesem 4114, wie wir es vorher bei Ungarn genannt haben, haben sie so ein 424 oder man könnte vielleicht sogar sagen 433 oder 442 gemacht. Sie haben im Raum verteidigt, was ihnen erstmal sehr stark geholfen hat, sich gegenseitig abzusichern und auch nach Ballverlusten so relativ schnell in eine defensive Ordnung zurückzukehren, die gut funktioniert hat.
Also eben weil, wenn ich einen Zweikampf verliere und ich im Raum verteidige, dann weiß ich, dass ja hinter mir oder neben mir ein anderer Verteidiger aus meiner Mannschaft steht. Während bei einer Mann-Deckung es sein kann, dass ich verliere und die anderen sind halt bei ihren Gegenspielern, die sie decken müssen und mein Gegenspieler, der gegen mich den Zweikampf gewonnen hat, hat halt erstmal viel mehr Platz.
Genau, richtig gesagt. Haben dann auch sehr stark mit das, was man Asymmetrien heutzutage nennt, bezeichnet. Klingt jetzt wieder nach einem furchtbar fancy Football-Word.
Kommt aber aus der Mathematik.
Bedeutet einfach nur, dass ein Außenspieler auf der einen Seite weiter vorne agiert, als auf der anderen Seite. Wenn wir jetzt wieder an die Taktik-Tafel denken und der rechtsaußen steht ganz weit vorne am gegnerischen Strafraum und der linksaußen steht an der Mittellinie noch, dann ist da ganz klar die eine Seite höher als die andere. Man spricht von einer Asymmetrie. Und die Brasilianer haben sehr stark mit solchen Asymmetrien gearbeitet. Also, dass sie auf der einen Seite einen Spieler nach vorne geschickt haben, aber auf der anderen Seite ist ein Spieler zur Absicherung weiter hinten geblieben. Da haben sie halt dieses doch sehr offensives Spiel der Ungarn, das sie auch genutzt haben. Sie haben auch sehr viel kombiniert, sehr viel gezaubert, typisch brasilianisch eben. Aber haben halt dann immer noch die defensive Absicherung gewahrt.
Ok, also sie haben quasi beide Dinge unter einen Hut bekommen und das in einer beeindruckenden Art und Weise. Auch hier trafen wieder besondere Spiele auf ein neues taktisches Konzept. Da muss man nur den Namen Pele fallen lassen oder Garinca, eine der interessantesten Personen der Fußballweltgeschichte. Und das war quasi so ein bisschen eine Folie, wie auch europäische Teams hätten spielen können. Und wohlgemerkt, wir greifen jetzt wieder ein bisschen zurück. Wir sind jetzt auf einmal wieder im Jahr 1958. Der ganze Catanacho-Kram, der kommt jetzt erst noch, mit Helena Herrera, was wir gerade besprochen haben.
Ist, glaube ich, wieder interessant, wenn man den Unterschied auch zwischen Südamerika und vor allen Dingen zwischen Brasilien und Europa aufzeigen möchte. Weil sich in Brasilien gerade quasi diese Vermischung aus Offensive und Defensive durchgesetzt hat. Aber in Europa dann ein sehr viel stärker defensives Spiel aufkam ab den 60er Jahren.
Ja, hier kommen wahrscheinlich auch wieder Mentalitäten mit ins Spiel. Wenn wir an der Stelle so einen kleinen Cut machen wollen, dann kann man so ein bisschen Fußball, also auf einer Metaebene, kann man da so ein kleines Fazit ziehen. Es gibt ein Buch – Der Ball ist rund – damit das Spiel die Richtung wechseln kann von Christoph Biermann und Fuchs. Der Vorname ist nämlich Ulrich Fuchs. Entschuldigung. Eines der Bücher, das ich denke wir beide empfehlen können für Leute, die sich für dieses Thema interessieren, die schreiben, die Ungarn haben sich von den Positionen gelöst, das haben wir schon besprochen. Und die Brasilianer haben ein defensives Gegenstück dazu geliefert, nämlich die Raumdeckung. Das ist eben ganz wichtig, nur im Raum wird verteidigt. Und damit hat man Absicherungen, die andere über einen Ausputzer lösen mussten. Das haben wir gerade schon besprochen. Sie schreiben, damit sind die Systeme aufgelöst und das Stil wird wichtig. Was letztlich bedeutet, eigentlich müssten wir jetzt in den kommenden Stunden weniger über 433 reden und über solche Telefonnummern, wie Pep Guardiola sagt, sondern mehr darüber, wie es interpretiert wird.
Das werden wir auch tun, wobei wir auch bislang viel darüber gesprochen haben. Ich finde, das Buch ist sehr gut. Das kann ich jedem weiterempfehlen. Ich finde dieses Zitat immer so ein bisschen extrem. Gerade weil mir bei Geschichte immer wichtig ist, dass es selten so einen Abschluss- und Anfangspunkt gibt. Das sind ja immer überlappende Entwicklungen. Natürlich war auch der Stil schon bei Ungarn sehr wichtig. Die hätten ja auch auf Konter spielen können, wie z.B. Das haben sie aber nicht gemacht. Also schon da gab es stilistische Unterschiede. Aber natürlich klar, mit steigender athletischen Möglichkeit, mit steigender Trainingszeit usw. werden natürlich auch kleinere Details immer wichtiger. Nicht mehr das große Ganze, nicht mehr die Frage 424, sondern die Frage, wie bewegt sich der Außenstürmer oder der Verteidiger?
Ja, bei beeindruckendem, wie ich es dann geschafft habe, aus 190 Seiten genau das Zitat rauszusuchen, an dem du dich etwas stößt.
Es ist ja auch ein gutes Zitat trotzdem.
Punkt ist angekommen. Wird dir auch keiner üben nehmen, selbst wenn es die Autoren hören, diese Folge. Du hast das ja gut begründet. Jetzt habe ich ja mit dir hier den Experten für Fußballtaktik in Deutschland sitzen. Du hast vorhin schon angedeutet, wenn wir uns auf diesen Zeitraum beschränken nach dem Wunder von Bern, dann wurde 1963 erst – das ist neun Jahre später – die Deutsche Bundesliga gegründet. Du hast schon kurz angesprochen, man hatte sich damals erhofft, manche haben sogar geträumt, es kommt die Pyramide wieder und es wird alles ganz offensiv. Tatsächlich hat es sich aber anders entwickelt. Magst du vielleicht ganz kurz nur abreißen, was ist so in den 60er-Jahren wichtig gewesen im deutschen Fußball und mit welcher Figur eigentlich, mit welcher Spielefigur hat sich dann da wieder was getan, fußballtaktisch?
Ja, auch in Deutschland hat sich der Catenaccio durchgesetzt. Hierzulande hieß es Doppelstoppersystem, wie bereits angemerkt. Gab es auch Mannschaften wie zum Beispiel Duisburg unter – ne, gar nicht Duisburg, Entschuldigung – der MSV unter Gutendorf hieß ja damals noch Meiderreicher SV. War noch nicht aus Duisburg. Die in der Bundesliga im ersten Jahr den zweiten Platz belegt haben, auch als totale Außenseiter, eben mit einer katenaccio Strategie. Und die wurden dann immer und immer mehr am deutschen Fußball übernommen. Die ersten Meister hatten eigentlich alle defensive Elemente. Zum Beispiel Werder Bremen, die auch mit Ausputze gespielt haben, Eintracht Braunschweig, die eine sehr defensive Mannschaft waren. Dann kam aber so Licht am Ende des Tunnels, wenn man so sagen möchte. Der Licht am Ende des Tunnels, das waren eigentlich hauptsächlich zwei Spielerfiguren.
Eine Lichtgestalt darunter.
Eine Lichtgestalt und ja, wie kann man denn den anderen bezeichnen?
Der Scheitel.
Der Scheitel, ein Lichtgestalt und ein Scheitel waren darunter.
Oder einen sehr, sehr tollen Twitternicknamen, kann man auch dazu sagen. Also lass mal auflösen. Wer ist die Lichtgestalt?
Die Lichtgestalt, ja, die kennt ja jeder, das ist der Franz. Ja gut, der den FC Bayern zu dem gemacht hat, was er heute ist. Man muss es ganz klar sagen. Hieß damals tatsächlich der FC Bayern, hieß bis in die 70er-Jahre ein FC Beckenbauer bei vielen. Im Wald Beckenbauer, die die zentrale Figur war. Der tatsächlich mal im deutschen Fußball was Neues erfunden hat. Ich glaube, da müssen wir jetzt mal kurz drauf eingehen. Was man mit Franz Beckenbauer natürlich verbindet, neben seiner großartigen Leistung als Trainer und seiner nicht ganz so großartigen Expertentätigkeit bei Sky, ist die Erfindung des Liberos. Der Libero, muss man jetzt mal erklären. Was ist der Libero? Im Endeffekt ist der Libero nichts anderes als ein Ausputzer, der auch mal nach vorne geht. Libero bedeutet übersetzt freier Mann. Das ist das, was wir vorhin in dem Ausputzer erklärt haben. Er war der freie Mann hinter der Abwehr. Aber Beckenbauer hat diesen freien Mann wirklich befreit. Er hat ihn von taktischen Zwängen befreit. Er ist immer wieder nach vorne gegangen, hat immer wieder aus der Tiefe nach vorne gestoßen, hat Doppelpässe gespielt, hat lange Bälle gespielt, kurze Bälle. Und hat halt diesen Überraschungsmoment natürlich gehabt, dadurch, dass er aus der Tiefe kam. Das war, ja.
Aber das musste mir jetzt nochmal erklären. Also wie kann es denn einen überraschenden Effekt haben, wenn jemand am eigenen 16er den Ball nimmt und damit nach vorne läuft?
Der überraschenden Effekt natürlich in den ersten Momenten vor allen Dingen. Also in den ersten, wo natürlich Beckenbauer hat angefangen in seiner Karriere als Außenstürmer, ist dann irgendwann zum Mittelfeldspieler geworden und ist dann irgendwann auf eigenen Wunsch halt in die Abwehr gegangen, weil er eben genau diese Rolle spielen wollte. Weil er halt meinte, wenn ich im Mittelfeld in einem Sturm spiele, dann steht mir die ganze Zeit ein Manndecker auf dem Fuß. Wenn ich aber aus der Tiefe komme, dann kann ich erstmal den Ball nehmen, dann kann ich mich umschauen, dann kann ich Geschwindigkeit aufnehmen, dann kann ich Gegenspieler dann auch mal mit Geschwindigkeit aussteigen lassen. Das war genau das Kalkül dahinter am Anfang. Später wurde Beckenbauer natürlich auch überall auf dem Platz Mann gedeckt. Da hat man natürlich gerne irgendwann einen Ball allen klar, okay Beckenbauer müssen wir auch Mann decken, wenn der im eigenen Tor den Ball hat. Aber am Anfang war das natürlich was ganz Neues, was gerade Gegner, wenn sie aus dem Ausland zum Beispiel nach Deutschland kamen, die kannten das ja gar nicht.
Um vielleicht zu verdeutlichen, wie bemerkenswert das war, im Sommer 1968 war Beckenbauer in der Kickerrangliste des deutschen Fußballs gleich zweimal unter Weltklasse eingestuft, nämlich als Verteidiger und als Mittelfeldspieler. Das zeigt ja schon ganz gut diese Hybridfunktion. Das heißt quasi, was ist passiert? Wir hatten eine defensive Stabilität und die wurde durch eine Überzahl generiert vom Ausputzer und dadurch, dass Beckenbauer jetzt einfach gesagt hat, ja klar, aber wenn wir den Ball haben, dann brauchen wir mich hier hinten als Ausputzer nicht, da kann ich ja mit meinen Fähigkeiten auch vorgehen und jemand anderes macht für mich hinten die Lücke zu, das war dann Bulle Rot in dem Fall. Dadurch haben wir ja dann wieder eine Überzahl im Mittelfeld und vielleicht auch sogar im vorderen, im Angriffsbereich. Also es war quasi so eine Pendelbewegung dann fast.
Ja, ich möchte da noch mal einen eigenen, allgemeineren Punkt hinzufügen, der an Beckenbauer sich sehr gut darstellen lässt, weil es natürlich damals andere Zeiten waren. Damals war es, wenn Beckenbauer das gemacht hat, dann hat das erst mal ein Jahr oder zwei gedauert, bis jeder das kannte, weil man eben nicht einfach Franz Beckenbauer bei YouTube eingegeben hat. Und dann gab es ein Highlight-Video, Franz Beckenbauer Highlights mit krasniger Technomusik unterlegt. Nee, da musste halt tatsächlich jemand hinfahren und sich das angucken. Und dann musste das auch beim richtigen Trainer ankommen. Und dann musste der Trainer dann erst mal überlegen, okay, lohnt es sich da jetzt meine über Jahre hinweg angewachsene Taktik anzupassen. Und so war das natürlich dann eine Überraschung zunächst mal. Natürlich nicht unendlich lange, aber es war zunächst mal ein, für viele Teams, was vollkommen wahnsinnig ist.
Und interessant, die Bayern sind der Beleg dafür, dass die Offensive zwar Spiele gewinnt, aber die Defensive Meisterschaft, die waren ja nicht bei der Gründung der Bundesliga mit dabei, weil aus München nur ein Verein laut DFB mitspielen sollte. Und das waren die Sechziger, sie sind dann aufgestiegen, haben dann wahnsinnig viele Tore geschossen, über 100, aber auch sehr viele kassiert und sind nicht Meister geworden. Und dann, als sich auch Beckenbauer eben diese Rolle übernommen hat und den Ausputzer gespielt hat, dann hagelten auch die Meisterschaften. Was ich mich immer gefragt habe, ist, wenn wir jetzt darüber reden, für Deutschland war Beckenbauer unglaublich wichtig. Jetzt nicht nur wegen dem ganzen Kram, der danach kam, sondern auch damals als Spieler. Das ist der Grundstein, glaube ich, für den Mythos. Also der hat schon auf dem Platz etwas gemacht, was vor ihm so und der von niemand gemacht hat.
Darf ich da einmal kurz eingreifen? Weil das muss ich nämlich noch mal fünfmal betonen. Und ich habe Beckenbauer, bis ich ihn habe spielen sehen, nie verstanden. Also ich habe seine Funktionen nie verstanden. Also bei Beckenbauer ist ja die Lichtgestalt. Und Beckenbauer, der saß jahrelang bei Sky und was der da vom Stapel gelassen hat, das waren keine Analysen so. Das hättest du jedem anderen Experten um die Ohren gehauen. Und auch alles, das mit ihm so viel verzeiht, was er auch gemacht hat. Aber wenn du das spielen siehst, und Beckenbauer war der beste deutsche Fußballer, Punkt. Und wenn du gesehen hast, wie er gespielt hat, mit welcher Eleganz er da von hinten nach vorne gelaufen ist und wie er den Ball geführt hat, dann hast du erst wirklich ein Verständnis dafür, was diesen Beckenbauer eigentlich ausmacht. So, Entschuldigung, das war jetzt wieder was ganz Untaktisches.
Aber das ist ja schon wichtig, weil wir legen hier ja auch Schwerpunkte, die man ja auch anzweifeln kann. Und das ist eigentlich letztlich spielt das auch auf diesen Punkt, an den ich jetzt dann bringen wollte. Also Deutschland unbenommen wahnsinnig wichtig, ja auch dann in der Nationalmannschaft. Aber wie taktisch einflussreich war eigentlich der FC Bayern international in dieser Zeit, wo sie ja dann auch den Cup der Landesmeister dreimal in Folge gewonnen haben, Anfang der 70er? Gab es da Auswirkungen?
Jein, dann sind wir schon wieder in einem Bereich, wo das, was die Bayern auch stark gemacht haben, dass eigentlich schon niemand anders wieder groß gemacht hat. Dazu kommen wir dann später. Deutschland war aber halt, das hatten wir glaube ich auch jetzt schon, kann man glaube ich merken. Ich glaube wir reden immer so, Deutschland reden immer so nebenbei und dann wir reden immer über die großen Entwicklungen der Taktik und dann reden wir über Deutschland. Weil die großen Entwicklungen der Taktik, die waren immer irgendwo anders am stattgefunden. Deshalb auch dieser Beckenbauer-Rolle so wichtig, weil das halt die einzige taktische Entwicklung ist, die originär aus Deutschland stammt. Also dieser Libero, der dann auch jahrelang so gespielt wurde, wie Beckenbauer ihn gespielt hat. Also das haben dann alle übernommen, dass dann der Libero nicht nur hinten klebt, sondern nach vorne geht. Das ist eine originär deutsche Erfindung, das hat Beckenbauer groß gemacht.
Und wurde dann wahrscheinlich Deutschland später zum Verhängnis gehabt, dass das damals gerade so neu war, weil, wie wir später sehen werden, haben sie lange, sehr, sehr lange am Libero festgehalten, als andere Mannschaften schon wieder komplett anders gespielt haben. So, du hast angedeutet, wir haben eine Lichtgestalt und wir haben, ich habe gesagt, den Scheitel als zweite wichtige Figur. Wen habe ich denn damit gemeint?
Der Scheitel ist ein gewisser Genetzer und zwar nicht der auf Twitter, sondern der echte. Günter Nett.
Zwischenfühle ich mich als echter Genetzer. Mir wird immer mal wieder zum Geburtstag gratuliert, wenn Günter Netzer Geburtstag hat. Aber ja, so ein Tweet pro Jahr.
Günter Netzer, kurz zu sagen, der Borussia München-Gladbach, für Borussia München-Gladbach das war, was Franz Beckenbauer für Bayern München war. Die prägende Figur, der etwas anders gespielt hat als Beckenbauer, wo Beckenbauer nämlich von hinten nach vorne gestoßen ist, ist Netzer von vorne nach hinten zurückgefallen. Netzer war immer einer, der sehr tief gegangen ist und dann sehr lange Pässe gespielt hat. Es gibt ja dieses berühmte Zitat, er kam aus der Tiefe des Raumes, was letztlich nichts anderes bedeutet, als dass er sich tief hat zurückfallen lassen, wobei jetzt auch wieder tief anders benutzt wird, als wir es sonst benutzen, das hatten wir ja schon mal. Aber er kam aus dem Rückraum quasi und hat dann die langen Bälle nach vorne gejagt. Das war halt entscheidend für das Gladbacher Spiel, die halt diesen Kontertrend aufgenommen haben, der in Europa aufkam, aber den sehr, sehr viel offensiver umgesetzt haben. Also die sind dann immer mit fünf, sechs Mann nach vorne gejagt und dann Netze einen langen Ball gespielt und dann haben sie sich drum gekloppt, wer diesen langen Ball bekommt. Das war das Gladbacher Spiel, das dann zum zweiten wichtigen Fleckpfeiler wurde in Deutschland. Gladbach und Bayern waren ja dann in den 60er und 70er auch die beiden großen Mannschaften, die alles unter sich ausgemacht haben.
Und wurden immer so ein bisschen als Gegenbeispiele zelebriert. Einmal die Ballbesitz Bayern versus die Konter Gladbacher hatten aber ja eigentlich, jetzt auch wenn wir so drüber sprechen, wenn wir sagen, Netze und Beckenbauer haben etwas Ähnliches gemacht. Nur der eine hat sich fallen lassen und der andere ist nach vorne gegangen, hatten ja auch viele Gemeinsamkeiten.
Ja, das wird dann natürlich immer gerne so als Grundsatzfrage ausgefochten, weil da spielt dann wieder ganz viel Nicht-Fußball-Technisches rein, was dann in diese Bayern-Gladbach-Diskussionen kommt. Aber fußballerisch war es natürlich ein großer Unterschied. Die Bayern in Anleihen noch an die gute alte Donausschule haben sehr viel mit Pässen gemacht, sehr viel flach gespielt, Gladbach etwas schneller, etwas weiter nach vorne. Aber so grundsätzlich haben beide zuerst ein 4-2-4-System gespielt und dann ein 4-3-3-System. Beide haben einen Mann, der aus der Tiefe gekommen ist, als wichtigsten Faktor gehabt und haben beide sehr dominant immer auftreten wollen. Das sind dann halt Gemeinsamkeiten, die dann eigentlich größer sind, als man das so manchmal hört und manchmal denkt.
Und das war vielleicht die Phase, wir haben vorhin darüber gesprochen, bei Österreich-Ungarn, dass damals die Intellektuellen den Fußball besetzt haben. So eine Phase haben wir jetzt auch hier in Deutschland. Das ist jetzt mal nur so am Rande. Aber es gibt dieses berühmte Zitat über Günter Netzer, seine Pässe atmet in den Geist der Utopie. Hat jemand ganz bekanntes gesagt, das Name, das ich gerade vergessen habe? Wir wollen jetzt hier keine Sprachanalyse mit dir machen und keine soziologischen Studien. Dazu mal ein eigenes Tribünengespräch. Vielleicht, wenn ich mal wieder Lust habe, diese ganzen alten Texte zu lesen, die ich mal für meine Magisterarbeit lesen musste. Aber sehr interessant. Und auch daher kommt, glaube ich, auch das, dass man diese beiden Mannschaften als Antiboden zueinander stilisiert hat, weil eben Gladbach eher so die Mannschaft der Intellektuellen sein sollte oder sein wollte. Und der 68er, ich meine, da hat halt auch jemand gespielt. Der hatte eine Hippiefrisur, der ist nicht zum Friseur gegangen, der hat eine Disco aufgemacht und ist dann zur Real Madrid gewechselt und so weiter. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du halt den gut, den Arbeitersohn, den Franz, der nie schwitzt, der sagt, was ihm auf der Leber liegt. Also das kommt da glaube ich auch noch mit rein. Deswegen hat man, obwohl die sich spiel-taktisch eigentlich gar nicht so unähnlich waren, wird das immer so ein bisschen anders dargestellt. Das hat glaube ich auch mit diesen ganzen Nebenschauplätzen zu tun. Gut, jetzt waren wir mal wieder kurz in Deutschland. Jetzt kommen wir mal wieder dahin, wo Taktik gemacht wurde. So traurig es ist, aber eigentlich erstaunlich, dass dein Buch trotzdem so total interessant und lesenswert ist, wo doch so wenig aus Deutschland kam. Aber du schreibst das auch immer mal wieder mit spitzer Feder in so Nebensätze rein. Das hat mir immer ganz gut gefallen. Also kommen wir mal wieder zu richtigen taktischen Entwicklungen. Und da müssen wir in ein Nachbarland von Deutschland gucken, in die Niederlande.
Die Niederlande bis in die 60er Jahre hinein auf keiner Fußballlandkarte vermerkt. Die hatten einen einzigen großen Erfolg mal. Die haben mal gegen die deutsche Nationalmannschaft 1955, glaube ich, gewonnen. Also gegen den amtierenden Weltmeister. Und das auch nur, weil der Platz eigentlich unbespielbar war und die Niederlande das Spiel einfach wegen den Zuschauereinnahmen nicht absagen wollten. Ansonsten waren sie halt einfach ein kleines Fußballland, so wie heute, was weiß ich, Norwegen oder Finnland. Und die dann aber plötzlich durch taktische Maßnahmen groß geworden sind.
So, und welche taktischen Maßnahmen waren das?
Wir bezeichnen das heutzutage als Fußball total. Als Football total heißt das, glaube ich, auf Holländisch. Ich kann es nicht aussprechen. Mein Holländisch ist so schlecht wie mein Französisch oder Spanisch. Ich kann es einfach nicht. Die Idee hinter dem Fußball total. Wir haben jetzt schon vorhin immer öfter über Positionswechsel gesprochen. Aber wie wir schon gesagt haben, bei Inter Mailand waren es sehr viel Positionswechsel in der Vertikalen, bei den Ungarn und Deutschland 54 horizontal. Und die Niederländer waren die ersten, die sich tatsächlich überlegt haben, könnte man diese Positionswechsel nicht überall auf den Platz aufziehen. Also könnte man nicht den Raum so benutzen, dass zu jeder Zeit jede Position besetzt ist, aber es relativ egal ist, von welchem Spieler. In der Praxis ist das wieder durch einen Spieler zum Leben erweckt worden, und zwar durch Johan Cruyff, der jüngst leider verstorben ist, der aber als die große Figur des holländischen Fußballs gilt. Johan Cruyff hat auch so eine Stürmerrolle gespielt, aber nicht so richtig, sondern er war halt überall auf dem Platz zu finden. Und wenn Johan Cruyff nach rechts gegangen ist, dann wusste die gesamte Mannschaft, okay, irgendjemand muss jetzt das Zentrum besetzen, wo Cruyff war, und dann muss wieder einer das besetzen, was gerade war, und dann muss wieder einer nachrücken, und dann muss wieder so und so gespielt werden. Wenn Cruyff nach hinten gegangen ist, dann genau dasselbe, dann haben wieder ein anderer Spieler besetzt und so weiter und so fort. Es war immer in Bewegung, es war immer irgendwas los, es war immer fließend, es war nie statisch. Deswegen Fußball total, weil es hat nichts mit totalem Krieg oder sowas zu tun, deswegen im Deutschen klingt das leider doof. Aber es ist genau das gemeint, dass Fußball als komplett gedacht wird, nicht als einzelnen, als abgehacktes einzelne Ding, sondern dass man die Position durchgehend denkt, wie muss ich jetzt stehen, damit es einen Sinn ergibt. Aber das war halbwegs verständlich.
Warum hat es die Gegner vor Probleme gestellt? Weil die im Deckungsverhalten noch so waren, dass dadurch, dass jeder Raum besetzt war, allein schon immer einer der Spieler frei war und anspielbar war? Oder das habe ich bis heute nicht so ganz verstanden. Es liegt ja nicht nur an Kreuf und an seinen genialen Pessen, dass es erfolgreich war.
Es liegt daran, dass einerseits natürlich die Mannendeckung damals ganz groß war. Die meisten Teams haben Mannendeckung gespielt. Wenn ich natürlich ständig in Bewegung bin, dann macht es schwerer, Mann zu decken. Nehmen wir jetzt an, der Stürmer fällt zurück und der Mannendecker verfolgt ihn. Dann entsteht ja allein da schon ein freier Raum, den jetzt ein anderer Spieler besetzen kann. Dann geht ein anderer Spieler in diesen Raum hin und guckt, ob er da nicht irgendwie den Pasta hinbekommt. Dann wird aber vielleicht er wieder gedeckt und dann ist wieder irgendwo anders was frei. Es ist halt immer eine Bewegung, ich ziehe immer irgendwo was frei. Was die Niederländer halt konnten, war, dass sie diese Positionswechsel so gespielt haben, dass sie es mit einem sehr flexiblen Stil verbunden haben. Es war eigentlich keine reine Ballbesitz-Nation und eine reine Ballbesitz-Team, sondern sie haben halt immer wieder diese Positionswechsel mit einem schnellen passenden Abwehr kombiniert, mit einer Flanke, mit einem langen Ball auch mal. Also die haben das sehr, sehr flexibel gemacht. Die haben halt alle Stilmittel, die man im Fußball verwenden kann, haben sie mit Hilfe dieser Positionswechsel verwendet. So, das ist halt dieses offensive Moment, das halt so wichtig war vom niederländischen Fußball. Da kommen wir jetzt auch gleich zum zweiten Moment. Das ist der defensive Moment, den sie revolutioniert haben ein bisschen. Der defensive Moment war natürlich, wenn du diese Positionswechsel spielst und dann natürlich keine klare Offensivformation hast und auch relativ natürlich nachdenken musst, wie du wieder in eine defensive Formation kommst. Ist natürlich klar, wenn der rechtsaußen immer rechtsaußen ist, dann weißt du auch, okay, wenn der Ball verloren geht, dann muss ich wieder rechtsaußen defensiv sein, also da, wo ich immer bin. Wenn der rechtsaußen jetzt aber plötzlich linksaußen ist, dann muss natürlich ein Umdenken stattfinden. Und daher war halt die Gedanke, okay, wir müssen es hinbekommen, dass wir den Raum für den Gegner möglichst klein machen und dass wir den Ball so schnell es geht wieder zurückerobern. Und dafür haben sie ein Pressing gespielt. Waren das erste Team das wirklich, wo man sagen kann, die haben Pressing gespielt.
Endlich! Ja, endlich mal wieder. Erklär das. Sag erstmal, was es bedeutet, den Raum klein zu machen. Das hört sich, als würden sich Wände in unserem Supermarkt auf am Anfang zu bewegen und alle Kunden und Kaufhausdetektive zusammenträngen.
Wir hatten vorhin lange über die Absetzregel gesprochen. Und der Raum hinter der Abwehr ist ja letztlich eigentlich nicht nutzbar. Also ich kann zwar im Ball sehr Abwehr spielen, aber der Stürmer darf sich da nicht aufhalten letztlich. Und wenn ich die Abwehr weit, weit, weit nach vorne schiebe, verkleinere ich den Raum, in dem der Gegner spielen kann. Weil natürlich auch die Stürmer nach hinten gehen müssen. Und wenn eine Mannschaft jetzt, der kann mir das zweite Fachwort einnehmen, kompakt spielt. Kompakt bedeutet letztlich nichts anderes, als dass der hinterste und der vorderste Spieler möglichst nah beieinander sind. Je näher die einander sind, desto kompakter stehe ich. Die haben die Abwehr vorgerückt, die Abwehrspieler sind immer nach vorne gelaufen. Und sie haben vorne sofort den Gegner gestört. Das ist jetzt das zweite Wort, das du deswegen gepfiffen hast. Pressing. Pressing bedeutet zunächst einmal nichts anderes, als der Versuch, als Mannschaft gemeinsam den Ball zurück zu erobern. Also nicht Mann-Deckung eins gegen eins, ich gegen einen zwei komme, sondern ich versuche als Mannschaft irgendeinen Weg aus, wie wir gemeinsam den Gegner attackieren können. Und im Falle von Ajax jetzt bedeutet das, dass sie nicht sich an den eigenen Schafraum zurückziehen, sondern dass sie schon am Gegner, schon im 16er oder im Mittelfeld, den Gegner stören, dass sie die aufgerückte Abwehr nutzen, um mit dem Mittelfeld dann zu stören und dadurch gleichzeitig zu verhindern, dass irgendwo vorne Passweg aufbleiben für den Gegner.
Und damit ist eigentlich auch klar geworden, wenn du auf einem engen Raum spielst, wenn du gleich wieder versuchst, den Ball zu erwischen, wenn du gleichzeitig alle Positionen besetzt hast, obwohl es da so Magneten gibt, der durch Eisenstücke, durch Gegenpolige Magneten durchläuft und quasi vor und hinter ihm schließen sich dann immer wieder die Ketten, dann musst du sehr gut ausgebildert sein und du musst technisch sehr, sehr gut sein. Vielleicht kommt es auch deswegen von Ajax Amsterdam, die haben ja damals, ging das in meines Wissens nach ja los, dass die ihren eigenen Stil entwickelt haben und technisch hochklassig ausgebildete Spieler in ihren Reihen hatten.
Du musst technisch perfekt sein, du musst diese Pässe genau spielen. Wenn du sie nicht genau spielst, dann wird halt genau diese Positionswechsel bestraft, indem der Gegner halt dann umschaltet. Du musst nicht nur technisch genial sein, du musst auch mitdenken. Du kannst nicht hoffen, dass dein Mitspieler das macht, sondern du musst halt jederzeit selber in den richtigen Raum laufen. Und du musst dich vor allen Dingen sehr gut kennen. Der Fußball total der Niederländer ist nicht innerhalb eines Tages gewachsen. Die haben nicht von Dienstag auf Mittwoch gesagt, so jetzt spielen wir mal Football total, sondern das hat sich in den 60ern langsam entwickelt. Und das war dann Ende der 60er Jahre, war das dann bei Ajax Amsterdam so weit, dass man damit tatsächlich Titel gewinnen konnte. Und die haben dann damit auch den europäischen Landesmeisterpokal gewonnen. Auch weil sie als Team jahrelang zusammengeblieben sind und zusammengewachsen sind. Und dann, um dann die Analogie zu beenden, dann in dem Moment, wo dann Cruyff gegangen ist, Anfang der 70er Jahre nach Barcelona, hat dann auch sich dieses System so ein bisschen aufgelöst, weil dann immer neue Spieler reinkamen und dann man nicht mehr diese Kohärenz hatte, weil man sich einfach sehr gut kennen muss, um das so zu spielen, wie es Holland gespielt hat. Wie Ajax Amsterdam gespielt hat.
Okay, sehr gut, habe ich verstanden. Mal wieder interessante soziologische Komponente davon. Klaus Tevelet schreibt in seinem Buch Tor zur Welt, dass die Niederländer dieses System deswegen hätte spielen können, weil sie aufgrund der vielen Kanäle, Deiche und Krachten ein anderes Raumverständnis haben, also der Niederländer an sich.
Es gibt noch ein Buch, Oranje Brillant, von David Winner, glaube ich, was auch in diese Kerbe schlägt. Der auch die These ist, dass sie, dass dieses aufrückende Abführen, dieses Raum abschneiden, dass das aus dem Mittelalter stammt, wo man Kanäle unter Wasser gesetzt hat, um den Gegner in den Raum, um den Gegner sage ich schon, um den Feind den Raum zu nehmen. Da kann man auch so ganz wieder interessante Parallelen ziehen, wenn man möchte. Aber manchen ist es natürlich auch weit hergeholt.
Das stimmt, aber das Buch ist trotzdem sehr empfehlenswert. Das packen wir in unsere Literaturliste, die ich auf jeden Fall für diese Show Notes anlegen werde. So, wir haben jetzt den niederländischen Fußball und wir haben schon drüber geredet, dass wir mit Beckenbauer und Netzer zwei wichtige Figuren in der Bundesliga hatten, die diese geprägt haben. Und jetzt gibt es ja den glücklichen Umstand, dass die in der Nationalmannschaft gemeinsam antreten können. Und tatsächlich ist die Phase gerade ein 3 zu 1 in Wembley 1972. Wir haben vorhin davon gesprochen, wie bedeutsam es damals noch war, gegen England in Wembley zu gewinnen, gilt immer noch als eines der besten Spiele der deutschen Nationalmannschaften. Kannst du vielleicht mal kurz erklären, wo waren denn jetzt dann die Unterschiede, wenn wir auf die Nationalmannschaften gucken zwischen Niederlande und Deutschland?
Also, man muss zunächst einmal sagen, dass dieser Fußball-Total, der in Holland um die 70er Jahre aufkam, der wurde in Deutschland relativ schnell in Einzelteilen aufgenommen. Also nicht jetzt als komplettes System, also nicht mit dieser Wucht und mit dieser ideologischen Wucht, die da hinter dem holländischen Fußball steckte, aber halt in einzelnen Dingen. Das waren dann nicht, dass alle Spieler die Position getauscht haben, sondern einzelne. Und damit wären wir jetzt bei 72. Da gibt es ja dieses berühmte Zusammenspiel zwischen Netzer und Beckenbauer. Wir hatten es schon gesagt, Netzer fällt zurück, Beckenbauer geht nach vorne. Bei dieser EM 72 war halt genau dieses Zusammenspiel auf der Höhe der Zeit. Also das war besser, haben Netzer und Beckenbauer nie mehr harmoniert als bei dieser EM 72. Und in dem Sinne dadurch, dass sie halt ständig die Position getauscht haben und auch andere Spieler da mitgemacht haben und sich eingefügt haben, zum Beispiel Paul Breitner, der auch Außenverteidiger gespielt hat, aber auch immer wieder in die Mitte gegangen ist, hatte Deutschland halt so einen Hauch dieses totalen Fußballs. Aber es war nie so ganz so total wie der niederländische Fußball, weil nie so mit VMNs die Position getauscht wurden und weil man auch dieses Pressing-Element nicht wirklich übernommen hat.
Okay, das waren also dann die Unterschiede. Jetzt treffen genau diese Mannschaften 1974 im WM-Finale aufeinander und wir Deutschen kennen ja die Geschichtsschreibung dazu. Die Deutschen waren Außenseiter und die Niederländer, dadurch dass sie da verloren haben, reihen sich in die, können einen Schulterschluss mit den Ungarn machen, die auch eine wahnsinnig dominierende Taktik und Mannschaft und Spielergeneration hatten, die sich keinen Weltmeistertitel erspiegen konnte und beide sind an Deutschland gescheitert. War es denn tatsächlich so krass der Unterschied zwischen beiden oder konstruieren wir das vielleicht auch einfach aus dem Turnierverlauf heraus?
Ich finde, es ist immer eine sehr konstruierte Sache. Ich habe mir das Spiel angesehen, mehrfach natürlich für das Buch, war natürlich ein wichtiger Pfeiler dieses Spiels, 1974. Und es gilt bis heute noch so, beim ersten Mal war es ein Wunder, beim zweiten Mal war es Glück, beim dritten Mal der verdiente Lohn und so weiter. Es war kein Glück. Also es war vielleicht im Turnierverlauf Glück, aber das Finale war Deutschland die bessere Mannschaft. Man muss es auch so sagen. Mittlerweile gibt es auch Niederländer, die das eingestehen. Ich habe jetzt den Namen und den Autor nicht beratet, aber es gibt ein ganz berühmtes niederländisches Buch, das ein Bestseller wurde, das sich nur mit dem Mythos-Finale 1974 beschäftigt und halt nur sagt, dass die Niederländer besser waren, war ein Mythos, den sie halt ganz gerne hochhalten. Deutschland war in diesem Finale besser, eben weil sie dieses Fußball total dreifach gespielt haben. Sie haben natürlich nicht diese Positionswechsel gehabt, natürlich nicht dieses Pressing gehabt, aber auch in Ansätzen natürlich mit Beckenbohrsein Vorstößen, mit Breitners Läufen und so weiter, aber haben das dann stärker mit einem defensiv soliden Spiel kombiniert bekommen. Wohingegen die Holländer in diesem Finale war nichts von ihrem Football total zu sehen. Waren keine Positionswechsel, war nur Johann Kreuf, der immer ganz weit nach hinten gefallen ist, um überhaupt einen Ball zu bekommen, war kein Pressing zu sehen, also war nichts von dem all dem. Und in dem Sinne war das auch mal wieder so, das ist einer dieser zahlreichen Momente im deutschen Fußball, wo man halt gesehen hat, okay, die haben diesen totalen Fußball der Niederländer verstanden, aber haben ihn auf eine sehr deutsche Weise, wenig extrem, mit Hang zum Mitte, mit Hang zum Kampf umgesetzt und haben damit dann den WM-Titel gewonnen.
Das ist einfach kreuft den Terrier auf den Hals gehetzt und das hat zwar irgendwie nach 40 Sekunden schon zu einem Elfmeter geführt, aber ansonsten ganz gut funktioniert in dem Finale. Das heißt, im Grunde kann man schon sagen, da sind die beiden innovativsten Mannschaften des damaligen Weltfußballs aufeinander getroffen im Finale auch?
Ja, würde ich jetzt sogar so sagen. Wenn wir jetzt in Fußball-Hipster-Abgründe gehen wollen, könnte man noch Polen nennen, die sehr modern gespielt haben. Aber dann sind wir jetzt wirklich in den Abgründen des Fußball-Hipstertums.
Ne, da wollen wir nicht hin. Da riecht es noch lange immer Chiatto aus Sojamilch.
Ja, da kratzt der Bart so doll. Das ist aber tatsächlich so gewesen. Also Deutschland war da nicht innovativ, aber hat da natürlich auch mit modernen Taktiken gespielt. Es ist nicht so, dass Deutschland nie ein Land der Taktik war. Also so ist das nicht. Man hat immer viel mehr darüber nachgedacht. Und auch Weißweiler und Herberger waren immer Leute, die sich genau Gedanken gemacht haben, wie sie aufstellen. Nur hat man halt nie diesen Hang zur Revolution gehabt, wie jetzt zum Beispiel die Holländer das hatten mit ihrem Football total.
Wo man ja am Beispiel der Holländer auch wieder die Unterlegenheitsthese spielen kann. Vielleicht muss ich jetzt dann doch mal den O-Ton von Thomas Tuchel einspielen, von dem wir später noch hören werden. Ist ein bisschen ein längeres Stück, aber es zahlt für mich genau auf diesen Punkt ein, woher eigentlich Innovation in taktischer Sicht oft kommt, nämlich aus dem Gefühl der Unterlegenheit daraus. Hör mal mal kurz rein.
Wir hatten, wir im Trainerteam hatten das Gefühl, wir sind aktuell überhaupt nicht konkurrenzfähig. Weder im Mannschaftsgeist, noch in der körperlichen Fitness, noch in der in der mentalen Ausprägung, noch in der taktischen Finesse und schon gar nicht in der individuellen Qualität. Also was machen? Gegner schauen, Gegner schauen, Gegner schauen. Was machen die? Wie spielen die? Jede Woche, jede Woche und jede Woche den Gegner analysieren, analysieren, vor dem DVD, Vorspulen, Rückspulen, Vorspulen, Rückspulen, schneiden, schneiden, schneiden und dann haben wir den Gegner gespiegelt. Also die geometrische Figur des Gegners versucht zu antizipieren, denn die haben alle im alten Denkmuster gespielt. Einmal 4-4-2, immer 4-4-2. Das war nicht schwer rauszukriegen und zu beobachten und wir haben es, ja, wir haben es gespiegelt. Das heißt, da wird dann gegen, gegen ein 4-2-3-1, passt am besten in 4-1-4-1 und wieso?
Damit wir unsere defensiven Abläufe, wenn der Gegner den Ball hat, gespiegelt, jeder seinen Ablauf hat, weil auf jedem Raum steht schon ein Gegenspieler, den wir attackieren können und wir können handeln. Wir wollten unseren Spielern ein Gerüst mitgeben, eine Hilfe, eine Hilfe, wie wir ohne nachzudenken, ohne darüber grübeln zu müssen, intuitiv handeln können und defensiv Zugriff bekommen, um Zweikämpfe zu führen, denn das wollten wir tun, um unbequem zu sein und so auch ins Spiel zu finden. Das heißt, wir haben dieses Muster entwickelt, diese unterschiedlichen Spielsysteme entwickelt, um der Mannschaft zu helfen, um ihr zu helfen, im Tun zu bleiben, im Handeln zu bleiben, um Flow herzustellen, aufzugehen in der zehntel Sekunde und nicht drüber nachzudenken, wer muss jetzt hier noch mal attackieren, bin ich das oder bin ich das schon zu spät? Auf diesem Niveau Bundesliga schon zu spät. Und das hat sich dann weiterentwickelt über auch Spielglück, über Ergebnisse, über Erfolgserlebnisse, über das jeder Trainer braucht, glaube ich auch einfach das Quäntchen Glück, der Innenpfosten und der Außenpfosten über Ergebnisse. Haben wir das weiterentwickelt und die Systemumstellungen, die Offenheit meiner Spieler gepaart mit der noch Sturheit oder mit der noch Eingefrorenheit der Denkmuster der Gegner, hatten wir einen Wettbewerbsvorteil und haben das ausgebaut zu einem gewissen etwas. Es war unser Wettbewerbsvorteil über zwei Saison.
Ein etwas längeres Zitat, da spielen jetzt auch noch viele Dinge mit rein, über die wir später noch reden werden, aber wir haben schon so oft darüber gesprochen, dass aus einer Unterlegenheit heraus Innovationen kamen und das alte Denkmuster aufgebrochen werden und man dadurch ein Wettbewerbsvorteil hat. Jetzt muss ich einfach diesen Tuchel-O-Tun einspielen.
Ich hasse es immer so, Werbesprüche zu nutzen, wenn man dann den Werbemachern immer ein Recht gibt, aber Vorsprung durch Innovation ist ein toller Spruch, der hier einfach passt. Weil natürlich, wenn man die Innovation hat, hat man einen Vorsprung über den Gegner. Das ist ja ganz klar, wenn man etwas so wie den Football Total über Jahre weiterentwickelt, etwas so Neues macht und Gegner vor Probleme stellt, die er nicht kennt, gerade im Europapokal. Dann kommen Gegner von, was weiß ich, aus Bukarest oder aus Madrid oder Mailand und müssen dann plötzlich mit einem Spielstil gegenhalten, den sie nicht kennen. Das ist natürlich was, das stellt man den Gegner vor, ein Problem, das er nicht kennt und das er wahrscheinlich auch, dass er mit höherer Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht lösen wird, als ein Problem, das er kennt. Wobei wir jetzt mit dem 74er – sorry, ich bin jetzt gerade zum Flow – weil wir mit dem 74er jetzt natürlich auch noch einen interessanten Aspekt zu dem Zitat von Tuchel hinzufügen können. Und zwar, dass dein Wettbewerbsvorteil irgendwann keiner mehr ist.
Genau.
Weil nämlich der Gegner, weil der wird, wenn du einen Vorteil hast, dann werden andere Leute den aufnehmen und dann werden sie irgendwann dich damit übertrumpfen. Siehe WM-Final 1974, wo Deutschland mit einer sehr, sehr modifizierten Form, aber auch mit einer Form, die anleihen am Footboot total genommen hat, die in den Länder geschlagen hat.
Ach, Tobi, das hast du jetzt einfach, als hätte ich das in ein Sendungsdokument reingeschrieben. Bitte rede so weiter nach diesen Fotonen. Ja, genau das fand ich interessant und noch einige andere Aspekte. Aber aus diesem Tuchelvortrag, den ich da gefunden habe, bei YouTube kommt auch in die Show notes, werde ich später noch ein paar O-Tonne vorspielen. Sehr interessant, sehr kluge Gedanken an vielen Stellen. So, aber wir halten fest, WM 74 ist ein Mythos, das Deutschland die klaren Außenseitern war. Es ist vermutlich entstanden aus dem Turnierverlauf, aber nur gesehen auf die Mannschaft und auf die Taktik war das kein unverdienter WM-Titel. Und da kommen natürlich noch andere Themen rein, aber wir reden ja hier vor allem Fußball-Taktisch. So, das war jetzt quasi die große Innovation der Niederländer in den 70er Jahren unter Johann Kreuf und die Deutschen mit ihrer Hochzeit mit Netzer und Beckenbauer. Und jetzt machen wir einen kleinen Cut und kommen zu einem Mann, der für ganz viele Trainer der Moderne die Inspirationsquelle war. Also es ist eigentlich schwierig, ein Zitat von jemandem nicht zu finden, der sagt Lobanowski, Valeri Lobanowski bei Dynamo Kief und dann später Nationaltrainer der UD SSR hätte ihn nicht beeinflusst. Ich habe ein Zitat zu ihm gefunden in einem Artikel, da hieß es sein Vermächtnis war dieser wunderbare Schachbrettfußball und das hört sich auf der einen Seite nach einer Überhöhung an, die inhaltslär ist. Vielleicht trifft es aber auf ihn tatsächlich zu. Was hat denn Lobanowski gemacht, dass er so viele andere Trainer beeinflusst hat?
Ich muss wieder einen kleinen Schritt zurückgreifen, weil wir natürlich wieder die Ausgangslage etwas brauchen. Und zwar haben wir jetzt 1974, wir waren jetzt gerade bei Football total und wir waren jetzt sehr viel bei offensiven Mitteln, die nach dem Catenaciu kamen. Das gilt auch von den Fußballern der 70er Jahre, aber dann am Ende der 70er Jahre wurde diese offensiven Mittel immer weniger. Es wurde immer mehr mit Mannendeckung gespielt, es wurde immer mehr Kraftfußball gespielt. Die Fußballer wurden immer kräftiger, athletische Möglichkeiten waren wichtiger. Und vor allem diese Mannendeckung war sehr präsent. Für die 80er Jahre war das das taktische Mittel. Mannendeckung war das, was wir mit allen gespielt haben. Ein Libero hinter der Abwehr und dann wurde davor Mann gedeckt. Und jetzt kommen wir zu Lobanowski. Lobanowski war ein Trainer, der eben keine Mannendeckung spielen ließ, sondern der das wiederentdeckt hat, was Brasilien schon zig Jahre zuvor gemacht hat. Und zwar hat er seine Spieler mit einer Raumdeckung spielen lassen. Das war keine Mischform der Mannendeckung, wie man sie damals doch relativ häufig angetroffen hat, sondern es war eine reine Raumdeckung, meist im 4-4-2, wo dann tatsächlich die vier Abwehrspieler von rechts nach links verschoben haben und immer die gleichen Abstände zueinander. Also der rechte Abwehrspieler zehn Meter oder fünf Meter neben dem rechten Verteidiger.
Wie an der Tisch-Fußballstange quasi.
Genau, wie an der Tisch-Fußballstange, perfekt erklärt. Und dann sind die mit diesem Konstrukt, mit diesem 4-4-2, mit möglichst geringen Abständen, möglichst kompakt wieder, also möglichst geringer Abstand zwischen dem letzten und dem ersten, also dem vorletzten und dem hintersten Spieler, von Seite zu Seite verschoben und haben dadurch, dass sie die Räume perfekt besetzt haben, haben sie dem Gegner keinen Platz gelassen zum Angreifen, haben alle Passwege verschlossen, haben alle Möglichkeiten, die Spitze zu spielen, verschlossen und haben sich dadurch wieder einen Wettbewerbsvorteil erarbeitet.
Das war quasi die defensive Gegenbewegung und wie haben sie ihre Tore geschossen?
Das ist, da bin ich jetzt auch gar kein so ein Riesenexperte, muss ich zugeben. Ich habe ein paar Spiele von Lubanowski gesehen bei Kiew, die halt einen sehr großen Fokus auf Defensive hatten. Sie haben aber auch Pressing gespielt, das ich selber leider selten sehen konnte, weil sie es eher in der Liga gespielt haben als in Europa. In Europa haben sie sich weit zurückgezogen. Sie haben angeblich Pressing gespielt, mit einem sehr hohen 4-4-2. Sie haben sehr schnell gespielt, nach Ballgewinn schnell umgeschaltet, schnell einen Konterfußball gespielt. Sie haben auch hier wieder diese Extreme gesucht. Sie waren die erste Verbindung zu dem, was man heute moderner Fußball nennt. Natürlich noch nicht ganz so ausgereift, wie man es heute sieht, aber durch diese sehr kompakte Raumdeckung, durch diese schnellen Konter, das ist das, was man ja auch heute meistens sieht, wenn man Fußball sieht.
Dazu gibt es auch eine sehr gute Retro-Analyse, nennt ihr das, glaube ich, aus Spielverlagung.de, zu einem Spiel von Lobanowskis Kief, ich glaube gegen die Bayern. Das werde ich auch verlinken. Das hat mir bei der Vorbereitung sehr geholfen. Weil man durchaus tatsächlich nicht bei allen Themen gleich viele Quellen findet und gleich gute Quellen auch. Und hier kommt vielleicht noch ein Aspekt mit rein. Ich habe gefragt, wie haben sie die Tore geschossen? Da kommt hinzu, dass es mit Oleg Blochin einen richtigen Torjäger gab, der da vorne einen nach dem anderen reingeknipst hat. Aber wir haben hier auch nochmal eine Umentwicklung, die sicherlich auch politisch und soziologisch motiviert war. Wir befinden uns mitten im Kalten Krieg und wir reden hier über jemanden, der bei Kiew und in der UDSSR, also in sozialistischen, kommunistischen Staaten tätig war. Wir reden hier über eine Rückbesinnung zum System. Lobanowski hat den Satz geprägt, das System ist immer größer als der Einzelspieler. Und das muss man sich, glaube ich, deswegen auch nochmal extra vor Augen rufen, denn wenn wir gerade eben in langen Elogen die Niederländer und die Deutschen gelobt haben, dann gab es da immer Leuchttürme. Wir haben über Kreuf gesprochen, an dem sich quasi der Football total orientiert hat, und wir haben über Beckenbauer und auch Netzer gesprochen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch noch eine wichtige Entwicklung im Fußball, die eben in diesem Zitat, das System ist immer größer als der Einzelspieler, zusammengefasst ist. Ich habe da etwas, ein fast gleichlautendes Zitat gefunden, eines Trainers, den wir alle kennen. Das möchte ich mal kurz einspielen.
Weil ich weiß, dass Robert, wenn er mit Bavarians in einer Linie spielt, und wenn er hinter ihm spielt, ich denke, das ist ein Problem für ihn.
Ich habe es an der Stelle schon abgeschnitten, denn Jürgen Klopp hatte sehr, sehr schlechte Laune bei dieser Pressekonferenz. Bei YouTube war nach einem Spiel gegen Leverkusen, als noch Jupp Reinkes der Leverkusener Trainer war. Aber das fand ich recht interessant, denn ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich eine der großen Linien. Wir hatten so eine Zeit der absoluten leuchtenden Stars mit Kräufe, mit Beckenbauer, mit Pelé auch. Kann man da auch noch mit reinrechnen. Es wird immer noch tolle Einzelkünstler geben, aber sogar, wenn wir später über einen Leo Messi reden, den vielleicht besten Fußballer aller Zeiten, dann ist er auch eher klar in ein System eingebunden. Das fand ich ganz interessant.
Ja, ist auch dann in diesem Moment bei Lobanovsky interessant, weil er natürlich an diesem Konstrukt gerüttelt hat. Ich würde sagen, da sind wir jetzt wieder in den Hipster-Abgründen, aber das gab es in aus der Europa schon vorher oft. Das ist oft schiefgegangen, aber Anfang der 70er-Jahre gab es ja diese Hochzeit auch des DDR-Fußballs, auch des polnischen Fußballs, wo sie halt auch ganz stark dieses System größer als Einzelspieler gemacht haben und da schon so einen Vorgriff drauf gemacht haben. Lobanovsky dann auch nochmal so einer, der dann diesen Vorgriff gemacht hat, das System ist größer als die Einzelspieler. Man muss aber sagen, wir sind jetzt Anfang der 80er-Jahre angekommen und da war das aber nicht normal. Also das war jetzt so ein Leuchtturm innerhalb von Systemen, wo der Einzelspieler wohl sehr wichtig war. Ich muss glaube ich nur den Namen Maradona nennen, der die argentinische Nationalmannschaft war. Also Punkt. Da gab es niemand anderes. Wir kennen noch irgendeinen anderen Spieler aus der Argentinischen Nationalmannschaft von damals. Ich habe ein Buch geschrieben und da sind zwei Grafiken drin und zwei Kapitel, wo es sich um Argentinien gegen Deutschland dreht. Mir fällt jetzt spontan kein Name mehr ein, außer Maradona. Also in dem Sinne der Fußball. Jetzt kommt so diese Zeit, wo diese Grafsvollste Bewegung losgeht mit Labanovski und die dann auch noch weiter kommt.
Genau, deswegen habe ich auch dieses Unterlegenheitszital von Tuchel schon vor diesem ganzen Block bringen wollen. Das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Wir reden jetzt immer über Innovationen und auch tatsächlich über erfolgreiche Mannschaften. Aber im Großen und Ganzen bewegen wir uns hier in einem Zeitraum, in dem eben Deutschland zweimal nacheinander gegen Argentinen im Finale stand, in der Maradona ein Wahnsinnssolo gegen England gemacht hat, die Hand Gottes ein Tor geschossen hat, in der Guido Buchwald zum Rastelli – das ist ein wörtliches Zitat von Gerd Rubenbauer – im WM-Finale 90 hochstilisiert wird. Das finde ich genau richtig, dass du es nochmal betont hast. Das war quasi die Minderheit, die so gespielt hat und die aber quasi dadurch, durch einen neuen Ansatz aus einer eigentlichen faktischen Unterlegenheit, immer wieder Wettbewerbsvorteile ziehen konnte.
Man muss jetzt quasi zwei Zeitlinien ziehen. Die eine Zeitlinie ist halt dieser große Fußball in den 80ern und 90ern, der halt doch sehr geprägt war von diesem Star-Denken, gerade in den 80er Jahren. Und der halt taktisch dann eher, wo dann taktische Fragen nicht mehr so wichtig wurden. Also dann ging es meistens um die Frage, wie kriegen wir den gegnerischen Starspieler aus dem Spiel und wie kriegen wir unseren Starspieler ins Spiel? Das ist diese eine Zeitlinie, die dann die angetinische Nationalmannschaft kann man dann nennen. Man kann Platini nennen, man kann aber auch die deutsche Nationalmannschaft der Zeit nennen. Und die andere Zeitlinie ist jetzt so, diese Grafsportusbewegung aus der Hand mit Lubanowski, der wiederum andere Trainer beeinflusst hat und die dann halt dieses Systemding groß geschrieben haben. Und diese Linie fügt sich dann irgendwann mit der anderen Linie zusammen, sodass man sagen kann, ok, dieses Systemding hat dann dieses Star-Ding abgelöst als Standard-Ding.
Die Stars wurden quasi in starke Systeme integriert, ja. Genau, ich habe schon gesagt, Lubanowski hat große Auswirkungen oder großen Einfluss auf Trainer gehabt, die später dann die Fußballtaktik bestimmen sollten, unter anderem auch ein gewisser Reihe. Er hat mal 1984 mit Viktoria Backnang gegen Dynamo Kief in einem Trainingslager gespielt. Er hat irgendwann in einem Interview gesagt, er war danach vollkomperplex und hat erstmal die Spieler durchgezählt, weil er nicht glauben konnte, dass die auch zur Elft spielen, weil die einfach den Platz so gut genutzt haben, die Dynamo Kief-Spieler, und ein so starkes Pressing gespielt hätten. Das war für ihn ein Erweckungserlebnis, hat er im Nachhinein gesagt, und auch Ariko Saki, über den ich jetzt gerne sprechen wollen würde, hat sich immer mal wieder auf Lobanovski bezogen. Ariko Saki unter AC Milan. Auch hier treffen wieder tolle Spieler auf taktische Innovationen. Was müssen wir denn dazu wissen, Tobi?
Ja, jetzt haben wir genau diese Entwicklung gehabt, dass dieses Lobanovski-Ding weiterentwickelt wurde von Saki, nämlich das ist jetzt wieder diese zweite Zeitlinie, die wir haben. Und Saki war ein Schuhverkäufer aus der italienischen Provinz, so muss man das ganz klar sagen, er war kein Profi-Spieler selber, sondern jemand, der aber unbedingt in den Fußballbereich rein wollte. Das zu einer Zeit, wo Trainer immer Ex-Spieler waren, das war kein leichtes Unterfangen. Und er musste halt arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten. Saki reiste durch ganz Europa und schaute sich alle möglichen Sachen an, unter anderem auch mit Lubanowski und entwickelte daraus sein eigenes Spiel. Das eigene Spiel, das er hatte, das baute ähnlich wie das Lubanowski-Spiel auf eine Raumdeckung. Es war auch ein 4-4-2-System, also dass die Mannschaft in 4-4-2 verschob. Aber es setzte noch sehr viel stärker auf Pressing, auf Pressing und auf Raumverknappung. Also den Raum möglichst eng machen, möglichst kompakt spielen und dann möglichst den Gegnern weit vorne attackieren. Das bedeutete, dass auch die Stürmer gegen den Ball mitarbeiten mussten. Also dass die Stürmer waren die ersten, die die gegnerischen Verteidiger anliefen. Dann liefen die Außenstürmer hinterher und dann lief das Mittelfeld hinterher und dann macht man immer so weiter, jagt den Gegner immer so weiter, bis man den Ball gewann. Und die Spieler mussten halt dafür die Abstände perfekt zueinander halten und mussten genau wissen, wann sie attackieren und wann sie den Raum decken.
Ich habe da ein sehr interessantes Zitat von ihm gelesen in einem Artikel über ihn. Du hast es schon angesprochen, die waren perfekt organisiert und er musste seine Spieler davon natürlich auch erstmal überzeugen. Das hat er gemacht, indem er ihnen gesagt hat, dass fünf Spieler mit guter Organisation zehn Spieler ohne Organisation schlagen könnten. Und das hat er ihnen dann demonstriert. Er hat seinen Torhüter und vier Verteidiger aufgestellt, unter anderem ein gewisser Maldini darunter. Und dagegen hat er mit die Crème de la Crème der Stürmer gestellt, mit Gulli, Van Basten, Rijkaard und eben zehn Gegenspieler. Die zehn Akteure bekamen 15 Minuten Zeit, um gegen die fünf Verteidiger ein Tor zu erziehen. Die einzige Regel war, wenn sie den Ball verlieren, müssen sie wieder in der eigenen Hälfte beginnen. Und es ist tatsächlich in diesen 15 Minuten trotz fünf Mann Überlegenheit kein Tor gefallen.
Das ist auch krass, das funktioniert auch tatsächlich. Ich habe tatsächlich neulich mal eine Jugendgruppe trainiert und habe dann auch so etwas gemacht. Und da ist auch kein Tor gefallen. Weil wenn du die vier Mann hinten, die Viererkette gut organisierst, ist das für die immer ein leichtes, einfach von einer Seite zu der anderen zu verschieben und kein Tor zuzulassen. Weil hinter die Spieler passen kannst du nicht, wenn sie am eigenen 16er stehen in dem Fall. Du kannst nicht, du musst dich halt sehr gut organisieren, um das zu schlagen. Das ist schon, das ist wahr, das funktioniert. Und damit hat er ja auch die Mannschaft dann rumbekommen mit solchen Übungen.
Und auch hier wieder tolle Spieler, ich habe ja schon ein paar genannt. Gulli van Basten, Rijkaard Maldini, Angelotti, ein gewisser zukünftiger Bayern-Trainer. Da kam auch wieder alles zusammen, war sehr, sehr anstrengend für die Spieler, weil sie sehr konzentriert sein mussten. Ich habe ein Zitat gelesen, das ich zweimal lesen musste, bis ich verstanden hatte. Und so deutlich ist es dann auch, wie konzentriert die Spieler sein mussten. Unsere Spieler hatten vier Referenzpunkte, hat Saki gesagt, den Ball, den Raum, den Gegner und seine Mitspieler. Jede Bewegung musste in Beziehung zu diesen Referenzpunkten passieren. Jeder Spieler musste entscheiden, welcher dieser Referenzpunkte seine Bewegung bestimmen sollte. Ist natürlich auch sehr verkopft ausgedrückt, aber zeigt schon, war jetzt nicht die zugänglichste Fußballphilosophie. Ja, definitiv. Im 4-0 im Finale gegen Stoa Bucares gewonnen in der damals noch nicht gegründeten Champions League, also Landesmeistercup. Und vor allem das Rückspiel gegen Real Madrid. Ein 5-0 war damals so, ja, also diese taktischen Innovationen, über die wir sprechen, die haben wir meistens so Erweckungsspiele, in denen dann halb Europa mal darauf aufmerksam wurde, ey, da passiert was. Und dieses 5-0 gegen Real war wohl eines davon.
Ja, sein Milan-Mannschaft hat dann tatsächlich dafür gesorgt, dass diese Zeitlinie, die wir hatten mit dem Focus auf Stars, abgelöst wurde von Systemfußball. Weil natürlich die Leute gesehen haben dann als Milan den europäischen Pokal gewonnen hat, dass das überlegen ist. Dass diese Art des Fußballspielens, natürlich wenn ich mich mit all meinen Spielern organisiere und die Stärken und Schwächen dieser Spiele alle sehr gut in ein System einbinde, bin ich natürlich mehr überlegen gegen eine Mannschaft, die davon abhängig ist, dass der Starspieler einen guten Tag erwischt. Es gibt auch das – ich habe tatsächlich mal mit Lothar Matthäus drüber gesprochen. Der hat nämlich damals bei Inter gespielt in jeder Zeit. Und der hat gesagt, er hat die Spiele gegen Milan gehasst. Weil alles, was passiert ist, ist, dass er im Mittelfeld gespielt hat und der Ball nur über seinen Kopf flog. Weil die Abwehr halt den Ball nur lang nach vorne bolzen konnte, weil sie ansonsten den Ball gegen das Pressing verloren hätten. Und hier reden wir auch wieder über den Vorteil durch Innovation. Weil natürlich die Abwehrspieler damals nicht gewohnt waren, ein Spiel aufzubauen. Die waren zum Abwehrspielen da und haben dann den Ball ins Mittelfeld gepasst. Das war es auch schon. Und genau diese Spieler hat Milan unter Druck gesetzt und hat sich dadurch einen extremen Vorteil verschafft.
Wie extrem der Vorteil war, kann ich an einer kleinen Statistik noch zeigen. In den 450 Spielminuten von Viertel- Halbfinale und Finale 1989, als Milan gewonnen hat, verliert Milan nur einmal im Spielaufbau den Ball, erpresst sich 90 Mal den Ball vom Gegner und hat insgesamt nur 16 Flanken der Gegner zugelassen. Das zeigt tatsächlich, wie weit vorne die waren mit dieser sehr guten Organisation. Ja, Wahnsinn, ich fand's auch… Deswegen wollte ich es nochmal vorlesen. Wir befinden uns jetzt Ende der 80er, Anfang der 90er und kommen nun zu einem alten Bekannten, Johann Kreuf, der nicht nur als Spieler, Innovator war und Dreh- und Angelpunkt einer fußballerischen Weiterentwicklung, sondern auch als Trainer. Und zwar wieder bei Barcelona. Er ist 88ter Trainer geworden, bis 96. Vor Kreuf hatte Barca einen Ligatitel in 14 Jahren gewonnen. Ich betone nochmal, einen Ligatitel in 14 Jahren. Das kann man sich heute nicht mehr vorstellen. Acht Jahre später, als er wieder gegangen ist, waren es elf Ligatitel. Was hat er da alles gemacht, Tobi?
Kreuf hat da weiter gemacht, wo er als Spieler aufgehört hat. Als Spieler war Football total ein Spielstil, der natürlich auch sehr auf das technische Können bedacht war. Was er gemacht hat, ist, er hat erst einmal alle diese Gewissheiten über Bord geworfen, die es damals im Fußball gab. Er hat halt gesagt, wir spielen jetzt keinen Star-Fußball, wir spielen jetzt System-Fußball, wir konzentrieren uns nicht auf Mann, Deckung, Defensive, wir wollen den Ball haben, wir wollen den Ball laufen lassen, wir wollen das Spiel gestalten. Und er entwickelte dann das, was man heutzutage unter Chorego de Posicionen kennt, das Positionsspiel. Positionsspiel bedeutet, dass die Spieler bei Ballbesitz bestimmte Räume besetzen sollen und so zueinander stehen müssen, dass sie den Ball möglichst gut laufen lassen können. Der Spieler am Ball soll immer möglich zwei, am besten sogar drei Anspielstationen haben.
Also Ball laufen lassen bedeutet, ich kann ihn mit wenigen Kontakten direkt weiter zu einem Gegenspieler passen.
Ich kann möglichst viele Pässe aneinander rein, ohne dass ich zwischendurch dribblings oder so etwas machen muss. Und das trainiert er mit seinen Spielern. Er hat mit seinen Spielern sehr stark darauf getrimmt, dass sie den Ball laufen lassen sollen, dass sie sich anbieten sollen ständig, dass sie Verbindungen schaffen sollen zueinander. Dass es halt nicht so ist, dass man den Ball zum Maradona spielt, der Maradona dribbelt dann fünf Leute aus, sondern dass man über Teambewegung, über Teamattacken zum Ziel kommt.
Er hat dafür auch so ein bisschen auf dem Spielfeld herumgeschoben. Ich habe ein Zitat gefunden von Eusebio, also nicht dem Portugiesen, der 1958, glaube ich, seine große Zeit hatte, sondern dem anderen Eusebio. Eben dem von Greuf, der hat geschrieben, also drei Verteidiger, vier Mittelfeldspieler, zwei Außenstürmer und einen Stürmer. Das hört sich jetzt noch unspektakulär an, aber das Zitat geht sinngemäß weiter, dass sich die Spieler angeguckt hätten und gesagt haben, was zur Hölle soll das denn sein? Wie sollen wir denn nur mit Dreien dahinten spielen? Und wie geil ist es eigentlich, dass da vorne so viele stehen, die Tore schießen dürfen?
Es gibt da viele Geschichten, ja. Die andere berühmte Geschichte ist, wie er Guardiola entdeckt hat.
Ja, erzähl die doch mal.
Das tatsächlich kam nach Barcelona und das hieß, ja, wir haben in unserem Jugendbereich einen Spieler, der kann alles mit dem Ball. Der kann Pässe spielen, der kann dribbeln, der hat eine perfekte Ballkontrolle. Und dann ist er halt mal zum Jugendspiel gegangen und hat dann sich ihn angucken wollen. Aber Guardiola hat nicht gespielt. Weder in der ersten Mannschaft noch in der zweiten Mannschaft, sondern in der dritten Mannschaft. Hat dann den Trainer gefragt, ja, warum spielt denn der nicht? Ja, der ist so klein und schmächtig, den kann ich ja nicht spielen lassen. Ich muss ja Spiele gewinnen. Dann hat Kreuf gesagt, ja, bist verrückt. Wenn der Spieler gut ist, dann lässt du ihn spielen. Dadurch hat er dann Kreuf spielen, hat er dann Guardiola spielen lassen. Und Guardiola hat dann zu der Spielzeit gekommen. In einer Zeit, wo man halt eher diese großen, starken Leute bevorzugt hat, hat er halt gesagt, aber es ist wichtiger dieses technische Können. Und wir müssen diese jungen Spieler, die technisch das können, spielen lassen, auch wenn sie nicht den Körper haben.
Okay, und um quasi runterzubrechen, was er gemacht hat, ist also, du hast gesagt, er hat das fortgeführt, was er als Spieler gemacht hat. Ballbesitz, Dominanz, Ball laufen lassen, gut verteilt sein. Er hat allein durch die Ausstellung das Mittelfeld gestärkt. Das kennen wir auch irgendwo her. Und wenn wir wissen, dass Pep Guardiola sein Schlüsselspieler war, dann dämmert es vielleicht auch dem einen oder anderen, wo man so ein mittelfelddominierte Spielweise noch kennt. Das waren so die Schlüsselmomente. Und dadurch hat es geschafft, die Defensivstrukturen der Gegner zu überraschen.
Genau. Auch hier wieder ein Weiterentwickler natürlich, dadurch, dass er dieses sehr klare System geschaffen hat. Auch, dass er den sehr großen Wert auf flache Pässe gelegt hat und sehr viel auf Genauigkeit. Hat er da ein Stück weit den Fußball weiterentwickelt. Wobei ich seinen Barca gar nicht als die große Revolution ansehe. Es gibt da Leute, die tun das. Aber es ist, glaube ich, eher wichtig gewesen, dass er viele Menschen beeinflusst hat. Um jetzt nur mal Guardiola als einen Namen zu nennen.
Ja, genau. Das wollte ich jetzt gerade noch ansprechen. Denn zum einen wird es jetzt immer schwieriger, die großen Innovationen zu benennen. Was vielleicht auch daran liegt, dass wir uns jetzt in die 90er-Reihen begeben und dann die 2000er. Das liegt natürlich alles zeitlich so nah zu uns. Und so ein bisschen so große Linien kommen ja auch immer aus einer zeitlichen Distanz zum Berichteten. Und zum anderen wäre das auch genau mein Punkt gewesen, dass ich auch den Eindruck hatte, Kreuf wird auch deshalb so vererbt, nicht nur wegen der Ligatitel, die er gewonnen hat. Das ist natürlich der Grundstein, aber er hat in diesem Club wahnsinnig viel verändert von der Spielphilosophie und die Grundsteine, die er gelegt hat, auch indem er zum Beispiel so eine Entscheidung getroffen hat wie Guardiola, der unter 1, 80 war. Das war damals die Grenze für Jugendspieler, bei der sie quasi noch nicht mehr spielen durften. Als er gesagt hat, der muss immer spielen, weil der kann was am Ball. Das ist ja quasi der Grundstein einer Philosophie, die dann später, wenn wir nochmal über Barca reden, wo dann auf einmal so kleine Wusler wie Xavi Iniesta und ein gewisser Leo Messi rumwuseln, das war ja auch nur so möglich.
Das ist das Interessante meiner Meinung nach, weil das, was Kreuf gemacht hat, das kam eigentlich erst 20 Jahre später so richtig zur Anfaltung. Auch dieses Positionsspiel, dieses fröge Position, wurde erst wirklich als taktischer Punkt sehr wichtig später. Deswegen werden wir da auch später darüber reden. In dem Sinne war, ich würde sogar behaupten, Milan Saci war natürlich für die Zeit wichtiger, weil das war ein System, das man relativ schnell aufnehmen konnte, wo man jetzt nicht groß seine Jugendspiele auf Pass treppen musste, sondern dieses Pressing konnte, kann jeder Spieler spielen. Und das hat auch dann natürlich sau viele Trainer zu der Zeit beeinflusst. Deshalb würde ich sagen, dass Cruyffs Barca eher langfristig wichtig für den Fußball war, aber die Revolution zu der Zeit, also um die 19er Jahre herum, das war Milan Saci – Saci ist Milan, Milan Saci.
Okay, sehr schön zusammengefasst. Ich habe es gerade schon angedeutet. Wir kommen jetzt in einem Bereich, wo wir, wir zwei, wahrscheinlich immer granularer über Mannschaften reden, es ist schwieriger, große Linien auszumachen, während wir so schön von irgendwelchen Österreich, Österreich- ungarischen Wunderteams hin zum Football Total gekommen sind, wird es jetzt immer mehr so eine Verknüpfung aus dieser Trainer war dann bei dieser Mannschaft und hat mit denen das hier gemacht. Und meinem Eindruck nach, wir werden dem jetzt dann auf die Schliche gehen, werden die Veränderungen immer granularer und deswegen ist es auch schwieriger zu sagen, das war jetzt die wahnsinnige Innovation, die alles verändert hat, bis wir dann eigentlich zu Barstar dann später nochmal kommen. Das war dann nochmal ein großes Ding, würde ich sagen. Deswegen würde ich es auch ehrlich gesagt, deiner Einschätzung überlassen, wie wir das gewichten. Ich habe jetzt weiter herausgesucht, wen ich in den 90ern und dann auch später interessant fand und bemerkenswert. Und du sagst mir dann einfach, ob ich da mit meiner Einschätzung, dass die taktisch gesehen wichtig waren, richtig liege oder nicht. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Jetzt wird es wirklich interessant, Leute. Und um den ganzen noch die Krone aufzusetzen, können wir wieder ganz kurz eine Regeländerung fallen lassen, die Anfang der 90er eingeführt wurde, die wiederum große Auswirkungen auf den Fußball hatte. Wir erinnern uns, die Abseitsregel wurde 1925 geändert. Das hat zu 1.700 Toren mehr in einer Fußballsaison geführt. Das war eine krasse Änderung. Und jetzt wird sie noch einmal verändert. Das haben wir bisher verschwiegen, aber ich glaube, wir beide sind vorhin schon genug ins Schwitzen gekommen beim erklärenden Abseitsregel. Die Abseitsregel bis zum Jahr, ich glaube, 1992 war so gestaltet, dass man schon dann als Angreifer im Abseits stand, wenn man auf einer Höhe mit dem Verteidiger war. Und das wurde jetzt verändert dahingehend, dass jetzt kein Abseits mehr gegeben wurde, wenn man auf einer Höhe ist, sondern nur wenn ein Körperteil, mit dem man ein Tor erzielen kann, in dieser verbotenen Zone, die ich vorhin beschrieben habe, war, also quasi hinter dem letzten Verteidiger oder dem zweitletzten Spieler. Und das heißt, letztlich, das hört sich wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig kompliziert an, aber letztlich wird es den Angreifern einfacher gemacht. Man war früher leichter, ins Abseits zu stellen als jetzt. Jetzt zählt es quasi erst, wenn man mit einer Fußspitze hinter dem Verteidiger ist, aber man kann quasi auf gleicher Höhe mit ihm sein, was einem logischerweise einen Vorteil gibt, einen Pass zu erlaufen, der hinter den Verteidiger gespielt wird. Das ist die eine Änderung. Und die zweite Änderung, die glaube ich auch sehr wichtig ist, ist, die Rückpassregel wurde aufgehoben erst 1992. Das vergisst man, finde ich, immer ganz gerne. Auch erst relativ kurz vor Gründung der Champions League. Und das wiederum hat Pressing wesentlich effektiver gemacht. Denn Pressing hat vorher auch schon, haben wir ja schon darüber gesprochen, zu Erfolgen geführt. Aber es gab immer dieses Schlupfloch für die Mannschaft. Ich passe den Ball einfach zu meinem Torhüter und dann nimmt ihn in die Hand. Und dann ist jedes Pressing erst mal gestorben.
Was halt auch – ich hatte ganz am Anfang, Leute werden sich dunkel dran erinnern, mal gesagt, dass die 1925 Abseits-Regel die zweitbeste Regeländerung der Geschichte des Fußballs war. Die Rückpassregeländerung, die beste. Also die hat den Fußball komplett einmal auf links gedreht, meiner Meinung nach. Und die kann gar nicht hoch genug angesiedelt werden. Weil sie eben genau dieses, was du gerade gesagt hast, dieses Pressing – man konnte es viel stärker forcieren jetzt. Also es gab dieses Schlupfloch nicht mehr, dass man den Ball zum Torwart zurückgespielt hat. Es sind auch ganze taktische Rollen einfach weggefallen. Wenn ich daran denke, wenn man sich den Fußball der 80er-Jahre anguckt, dann gibt es bei pressenden Teams immer einen Stürmer, der hat nichts anderes gemacht als den Rückpassweg zum Torwart blockiert. Der hat sich immer so positioniert, dass man nicht zum Torwart zurück spielen kann. Das gab es dann natürlich danach nicht mehr. Den konnte man danach natürlich sinnvoller einsetzen im Pressing als für sowas. Deswegen meiner Meinung nach die wichtigste Regeländerung, die es gab.
Hat auch die ganze Spielgeschwindigkeit verändert. Also wenn man Spiele mit Rückpassregeln anguckt, man hält es nicht aus, man wird wahnsinnig. Also geht mir persönlich so. Ständig wird er zurückgepasst und dann nimmt er ihn wieder. Dann hält er in zehn Sekunden in der Hand und dann passt er am besten wieder kurz zum Verteidiger.
Am besten war immer, als es noch nicht diese 7-Sekunden-Regel mit dem Tor, dass der Torwart den Ball nur 7 Sekunden in der Hand halten darf, gab, dann gab es immer eine kurze Phase, wo es erlaubt war, dass der Torwart sich den Ball so zurollt, 5 Meter weit, und dann wieder in die Hand nimmt. Das gab es ja auch noch. Das sieht man dann alles. Aber man muss es halt nochmal sagen, diese Rückpassregel war so wichtig, weil sie dann diesen Pressing-Weg und diesen Systemfußballweg, den wir ja gerade mit Satchi beschrieben haben, dass die quasi die Tür und Tor geöffnet haben.
Genau, der wurde unterstützt. Und dann kommt später dann noch eine verbanstheoretische Änderung oder eine vertragsrechtliche dazu mit dem Bossmann-Urteil in den 90ern. Und zack, hast du einen komplett anderen Fußball.
Und die Drei-Punkte-Regel nicht zu vergessen?
Und die Drei-Punkte-Regel. Ja, wobei ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mir da immer noch nicht so sicher, wie viel die wirklich verändert hat. Also es gibt ja auch verschiedene Statistiken, die das mal hin und her rechnen. Der Unterschied zwischen Zwei-Punkte- und Drei-Punkte-Regel. Also, liebe Hörer, wir reden davon, dass irgendwann geändert wurde. Früher hat man für einen Sieg zwei Punkte bekommen. Und für einen unentschieden einen Punkt. Womit natürlich beim Stand von 1 zu 1 in der 85. Minute der Anreiz, noch ein Tor zu erzielen, nicht so hoch war, weil man konnte nur einen Punkt dazu gewinnen oder aber einen Punkt verlieren. Darauf hat die UEFA reagiert und hat die 3-Punkte-Regel eingeführt. Die kamen dann auch irgendwann in die Bundesliga. Was eben bedeutet, bei einem Sieg gibt es 3 Punkte. Damit wird es attraktiver, noch auf den Punkt gewinnen zu gehen, weil man zwei Punkte gewinnen, aber einen Punkt verlieren kann. Reden wir doch mal über Ajax Amsterdam. Wir haben vorhin schon kurz drüber geredet, beim Teil von Johan Kreuf. Und jetzt möchte ich mit dir über Ajax der frühen 90er reden, unter einem gewissen Louis van Gaal. Ajax kurz zu den sportlichen Ergebnissen, den UEFA Cup 1992 gewonnen und Champions League und Liga 1994-95 gewonnen, mit so namenlosen Spielern wie Litmannen, van der Sar, Danny Blind, Frank de Boer, Ronald de Boer, Edgar Davids, Reikard, Clarence Seedorf, Patrick Kloywert. Sie hatten nicht nur tolle Spieler, sondern auch ein interessantes System. Kannst du uns da ein bisschen aufklären?
Ja, wir haben auch eine Mischung gespielt aus 4-3-3 und 3-1-3-3. Wobei wir ja mittlerweile wissen, dass diese Zahlen wenig wert sind. Was viel wichtiger ist, sie haben ein Ballbesitzspiel gespielt. Das kennt man ja von Louis van Gaal, dafür ist er ja bekannt. Ihm war sehr wichtig, dass die Spieler sich im Ballbesitz richtig positionieren, dass sie Dreiecke aufbauen, dass sie jederzeit dort stehen, wo sie zu stehen haben. Wenn das jetzt ein bisschen an Barca und der Kreufe erinnert, das ist keine Überraschung. Das waren so zwei Entwicklungen, die parallel liefen. Man darf es nur Louis van Gaal nicht sagen in dem Vergleich, weil Louis van Gaal und Kreufe haben sich immer gehasst. Was ich nicht ganz verstehe, aber gut, weil der Fußball doch sehr ähnlich ist. Wahrscheinlich wegen der Teilfragen. Die Teilfragen sind auch die Unterschiede. Was Van Gaal noch viel stärker will als Kreufe, hat den Spielern mehr Freiheiten gegeben. Hat gesagt, wenn jemand einen Raum sieht, wo er starten möchte, kann er das tun. Wohingegen bei Van Gaal doch ganz klar im Fokus war, dass die Spieler ihre Position halten müssen und so stehen müssen, wie sie stehen. Ich glaube, das kann jeder, der deutsche Fußballfans nachvollziehen, der Gaals Bayern mal gesehen hat. Es war im Endeffekt von den Prinzipien her kein riesen Unterschied zu dem, was Ajax damals gespielt hat. Wobei es natürlich noch ein anderer Fußball damals war, aber auch damals waren diese Prinzipien mit den Dreiecken, mit den Positionen halten schon sehr stark vorhanden.
Dreiecke, Kurzballspiel, Dominanz, Ballsicherheit, das speichern wir ab. Und nur um kurz herauszustellen, wie überragend in dieser Van Gaalfase Ajax war. Die Mannschaft hat im Verlauf der Saison 94, 95 kein einziges Pflichtspiel nach regulärer Spielzeit verloren. Und in der Champions League vor dem Finale auch nur 7 Siege und 4 Remis gehabt. In der Meisterschaft 27 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und eine Tordeferenz von 106 zu 28. Und nur im Cup-Viertelfinale gab es einen Aus gegen Feyenoord Rotterdam nach Verlängerung. Also, ist durchaus berechtigt zu sagen, das war eine goldene Zeit unter Louis. Und Schuld waren die Dreiecke. Die nächste Mannschaft, die so ein bisschen sich in Europa in den Vordergrund gespielt hat, war Juventus Turin unter Marcelo Lippi. Da geht ab 94 los. Er hat ein 4-3-3 gespielt, das sich aber meiner Meinung nach eben seiner Amtszeit krass verändert hat. Und das würde ich tatsächlich an eine Personale festmachen, nämlich an der Ankunft von Zinedine Zidane.
Jetzt muss ich zugeben, dass du mir ein bisschen voraus bist. Weil ich diese Veränderung natürlich da war. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, worauf du dich mit 4-3-3 beziehst. Ich kenne die ersten Jahre von Juventus und Lippi tatsächlich nicht so gut. Ich weiß, dass sie später mit Zidane eine Art Raute gespielt haben. Also Zidane ist ja einer der großen Stars der 90er, der von der 10 aus die Fäden seiner Mannschaft gezogen hat, der dann hinter zwei Stürmern gespielt hat bei Juventus. So einem 4-3-1-2 würde man das bezeichnen. Jetzt musst du den ganzen Landzug einspringen und uns ein bisschen was über Juventus und Lippi erzählen.
Ja, sehr gut. Jetzt muss ich alle meine Links, die ich gestern Abend auf dem Internet noch mal öffnen. Zidane hat tatsächlich gespielt hinter der Pierre und ins Agi. Also auch hier haben wir wieder eine tolle Spielergeneration. Ich glaube, ein wichtiger Spieler, der auch noch ein bisschen unterschätzt wird, in der Mannschaft war der Jean, der so ein bisschen hinten den Laden dicht gehalten hat im Mittelfeld. Ich musste tatsächlich gerade noch mal raussuchen, wie sie vor Zidane gespielt haben. Meine Erinnerung nach, wobei das können keine wirklichen Erinnerungen gewesen sein, denn da war ich noch recht jung, war es aber so, dass der eigentliche Unterschied tatsächlich war, dass er von einem klassischen 4-3-3, das heißt, wir sprechen von vier Verteidigern, von drei Mittelfeldspielern, die halbwegs auf einer Linie stehen, einer so ein bisschen zurückgefallen, der so ein bisschen versucht, Angriffe abzufangen, und drei Stürmern so eben dieser Raute gewechselt hat. Das war eigentlich das, was ich damit gemeint hatte.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Was man vielleicht dann noch sagen könnte, weil du gerade schon die Schaum angesprochen hast, der steht natürlich auch für so eine neue taktische Rolle, die dann in den 90er Jahren auch aufgekommen ist. Das, was wir heute als Sechser kennen. Ich finde die Bezeichnung Sechser sehr interessant, weil wir hatten ja diese Namen, diese Positionen anhand von Nummern hatten wir ja vor zig Stunden mal gehabt in diesem Podcast. Und im echten Fußball stammt das aus den 20er- 30er- 40er- 50er-Jahren. Aber beim Sechser hat sich das halt bis heute durchgezogen. Und der Begriff wurde halt auch erst wieder in den 90er-Jahren so richtig verwindet für einen Spieler, der eben vor der Abwehr spielt, der die Position im zentralen Mittelfeld spielt und von dort aus einerseits das Spiel gestaltet, andererseits aber auch dafür zuständig ist, abzusichern hinter den Stürmern. Und der im modernen Fußball eine ganz zentrale Rolle spielt.
Das heißt, wenn wir mal zurückblicken aufs WM-System, dann wären die Sechser die beiden Spitzen des Ms, die beiden zurückgezogenen Mittelfeldspieler. Genau, das wird wichtig. Jetzt ist natürlich interessant, wir haben jetzt wieder viel über taktische Innovationen geredet, aber schon ganz lange nicht mehr über Deutschland. Und gerade in der Phase hat das sehr gute Gründe. Ich habe das folgende Kapitel überschrieben in unserem Sendungsdokument mit, denke ich an Deutschland in der Nacht. Das berühmte Heinrich Heine, Zitat, warte ich um den Schlaf gebracht. Was lief denn da alles schief in Deutschland, Tobi?
Groß Erfolge haben wir gefeiert bis in die 90er Jahre hinein. 1990 der dritte WM-Titel, der hohe Hochzeit des Mannendeckungfußballs, des Individualistenfußballs, wie wir ihn ja vorhin genannt hatten. In Deutschland wurde aber verpasst, dass wir das jetzt in den 90er Jahren hatten. Da kam es ja einige weiterentwickeln. Da gab es ja Barca mit dem neuen Stil, Milan mit dem neuen Stil, aber auch Juventus, die was Neues probiert haben. Neue Formation 4-3-3, das haben wir bis jetzt noch gar nicht gehabt. Rauhte 4-3-1-2, auch neu. Diese neuen Dinge kamen einem deutschen Fußball nicht so wirklich an. Die wurden nicht aufgenommen. Deutschland wurde weiterhin nicht raumgedeckt, sondern manngedeckt. Es wurde weiter mit Libero gespielt, statt mit Viererkette. Es wurde weiterhin mit Spielmacher auf der Zehn gespielt, anstatt dass man so eine Sechs oder eine Doppel-Sechs später dann einführt. Man hat da die Entwicklung, muss man ganz klar so sagen, verschlafen.
Ja, und das muss man sich wirklich nochmal vor Augen führen. Es wird immer noch mit Libero gespielt. Den hat Franz Beckenbauer Ende der 60er Jahre erfunden. Das ist wirklich krass, finde ich. Also vor allem, wenn man sich jetzt guckt. Ich meine natürlich, wir haben jetzt gerade eine verknapte Sicht auf den Fußball. Wir konzentrieren uns gerade nur auf taktische Innovationen. Aber trotzdem, da ist so viel passiert. Und in Deutschland hat sich einfach nichts verändert. Ich glaube, an dem Punkt müssen wir aber dann schon, glaube ich, nochmal kurz mit im Betracht ziehen. Das liegt halt auch daran, wie sich der Fußball und die Fußballberichterstattung vor allem in der Zeit geändert haben.
Ja, muss man schon sagen. Der Fußball wurde noch stärker zur Massenware, war er vorher auch schon. Aber dadurch, dass diese Privatsender den Fußball für sich entdeckt haben, mit RAN als große Sendung damals, die den Fußball dann aber auch als Glamour-Produkt vermarktet haben, muss man fast sagen. Die Geschichten wurden dann immer persönlicher. Wenn man sich die Sportpresse anguckt bis in die 70er, 80er Jahre hinein, da ging es immer um Teams und da ging es immer um Entwicklung. Dann ging es sehr viel um Trainer, die nicht erfolgreich waren. Aber jetzt kamen dann so Sachen wie der FC Hollywood bei Bayern, wo dann sehr viel darum ging, was machen die Spieler, wenn sie nicht gerade Fußball spielen. Ein magisches Dreieck, da ging es dann sehr viel um Individualisten. Und da ging es halt sehr wenig um Systemen. In der Zeit galt das auch als so angestaubt. Wenn man dann so über Taktik reden wollte, dann ja, das hatte so einen miefigen Geruch, so einen miefigen Geruch nach Kicker der 60er Jahre. Und dieses Nachdenken und dieses Reden über Taktik ist da in dieser Zeit sehr verloren gegangen.
Ich finde, simpeltlich für den deutschen Fußball steht in der Zeit tatsächlich die Nationalmannschaft. Berti Vogts hatte die große Ehre nach dem berühmten Beckenbauer Zitat, wir werden auf Jahre hin unschlagbar sein, wenn jetzt noch die Spiele aus der DDR dazu kommen. Er hatte ja die große Ehre, eine taktisch überhaupt nicht moderne Nationalmannschaft übernehmen zu müssen. 1992 dann noch ins Finale gekommen und gegen Dänemark verloren. Da aber zum Beispiel auch schon gegen eine Abseitsfalle der Belgier gar nicht so gut zurechtgekommen, wenn ich das richtig rekapituliere.
Das war das Stärkere Spiel gegen Welt. Dänemark hätten sie eigentlich gewinnen müssen, aber vorher sahen sie nicht immer gut aus. Ich glaube auch Niederlande, aber kann es sein, dass ich falsch liege, haben sie auch nicht gut ausgesehen.
Und dann die WM in den USA 1994 als Titelverteidiger, als Weltmeister muss man sich überlegen. Vogts versucht, eine Viererkette zu etablieren und stellt dann ernüchtert fest, seine Spieler sind entweder zu eingeschränkt in ihren Möglichkeiten, mentaler und fußballerischer Art, oder sie wollen nicht. Auf jeden Fall stellt er etwas resigniert wieder um. Und Deutschland scheidet dann im Viertelfinale gegen Bulgarien aus. Und dann passiert etwas Seltsames. Deutschland wird Europameister.
Das letzte große Hurra des deutschen Fußballs. Erst mal war es nicht so, dass Deutschland plötzlich keinen Fußballer mehr hatte. Da waren ja schon ein paar Leute dabei, die wussten, wie man kicken kann. Und sie hatten gerade mit Matthias Sammer endlich mal wieder einen richtig guten Libero. Das war das Problem seit Beckenbauer eigentlich aufgehört hat, dass es keinen richtig guten Libero mehr gab. Aber mit Matthias Sammer dann tatsächlich ein, der sowohl defensiv als auch offensiv Akzente setzen konnte. Der diese Mannschaft auch in diesem Turnier getragen hat. Hat dann mit der Nationalmannschaft für einen Hurra gesorgt, hat dann 1997 mit dem BVB noch für einen Hurra gesorgt, als sie die Champions League gewinnen konnten. Aber das waren dann so die letzten Zuckungen eines Fußballs, der nicht mehr zeitgemäß war.
Ja, und da würde ich aber gerne noch kurz mit dir verharren. Nämlich bei dieser 97er-Saison. Denn es ist ja schon erstaunlich, dass wir beide uns darin einig sind und ehrlich gesagt auf die Fußballgeschichtsschreibung, dass die 90er ein düsteres Jahrzehnt waren für den deutschen Fußball aus taktischer Sicht. Und dennoch haben wir das erfolgreichste Jahr. 1997 gewinnt Dortmund gegen Juventus Turin mit einem 3 zu 1 die Champions League und zeitgleich, eine Woche später, Schalke 04 gegen Inter Mailand im Elfmeterschießen den UEFA-Pokal. Waren die Siege dann Zufall oder haben sich da nochmal gewisse Tugenden durchgesetzt? Wie passt das zusammen?
Es ist interessant, wie diese Siege zustande gekommen sind. In beiden Finals waren BVB und Schalke die klaren Außenseiter. Also Schalke gegen Inter Mailand und BVB gegen Juventus Turin. Da ging es bei beiden eigentlich nur um die Höhen der Niederlage. In beiden haben sie sich mit Kampffußball dagegen gestellt und nicht mit Systemfußball. Beiden war der Wille da. Das war halt so klassisch deutsch. 1954 hatte es so einen Touch. 1974 vielleicht sogar. Der Außenseiter kämpft sich so durch. Damit hat man dann die taktischen Schwächen teilweise doch ausgeglichen. Also Fußball ist natürlich nicht nur Taktik. Aber wenn man die Entwicklung der 90er guckt, auch die Entwicklung der Nationalmannschaft, dann sieht man doch, dass diese Ideen, die international im Fußball aufkamen, nicht aufgenommen wurden. Das wurde ja dann nachher vor allem zu Problemen in den 2000er Jahren, wo man dann nichts mehr gewinnen konnte. Auch international nicht. Bayern München 2001, Champions-League-Triumph war der letzte Triumph, bis sie dann 12 Jahre später noch mal die Champions-League gewinnen konnten.
12 Jahre später hat das Champions-League-Finale nicht stattgefunden, meiner Erinnerung nach.
Ist rausgefallen.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was da los war. Also könnte man quasi sagen, die Tugenden, die der deutsche Fußball auch in dieser Zeit hatte, gerade repräsentiert durch so Typen wie Sammer oder vielleicht auch Cola, die haben 97 und 96 noch gereicht, den Mangel an Innovationskraft zu überdecken. Aber das ist dann in sich zusammengefallen.
Ja, das wäre meine These an der Vd-Geschichte.
Genau.
Es waren jetzt nicht so, dass der deutsche Fußball im April erfolgreich war, sondern diese BVB und Schalke-Erfolge und auch das Finale der Bayern zwei Jahre später, 99, das waren ja eher Ausnahmen. 96, 97 kamen dann noch mal so hoch. Aber die fünf Jahre davor und die fünf Jahre danach war nicht viel los.
In der Nationalmannschaft kommt es dann quasi zum großen Crash. 98 gegen Kroatien raus, 0 zu 3. Dann wird Erich Ribbeck installiert. Es gibt einen wunderbaren Ausschnitt, wo Oliver Neville, der damals quasi am Beginn seiner Karriere stand, gefragt wird, sagt ihm der Name Erich Ribbeck. Und er guckt vollkommen verständnislos in die Kamera und sagt Nein. Und dann sagt der Reporter, das ist der neue Bundestrainer. Ein zeitlos schöner Ausschnitt. Wird nur noch getoppt von dem Ausschnitt, wo Erich Ribbeck versucht einen Ball, der am Boden liegt, mit einem Trick hochzuschießen und grandios daran scheitert. 2000 dann Vorrunden aus, unter anderem gegen Portugal, 3-0 verloren. Das ist so der Tiefpunkt des deutschen Fußballs auf Nationalmannschaftsebene. Und danach kämpelt sich der deutsche Fußball um. Bevor wir das dann noch so ein bisschen erörtern können, es wird jetzt immer granularer, wie angekündigt, müssen wir aber schon erwähnen, es gab allerdings auch im deutschen Fußball Innovation nur im sehr, sehr kleinen.
Ja, genau. Da hatten wir eine kleine Revolution von unten, muss man sagen. Dass nämlich diese Ideen von Saki wurden aufgenommen in Deutschland tatsächlich, aber nicht von den großen Trainern, sondern der hat einen sehr starken Einfluss gehabt auf Ralf Rangnick, aber auch auf Volker Finke, der beim SC Freiburg in den 90er-Jahren gearbeitet hat und die nach oben geführt hat, hatte auch Einfluss auf einen gewissen Wolfgang Frank, der bei Mainz damals gearbeitet hat, der Mentor von Jürgen Klopp, muss man so sagen, die dann halt in ihren kleineren Clubs diese Ideen des Pressings, der Raumdeckung, des Verschiebens, des Konterspiels umgesetzt haben.
Ja, und nirgends fasst es sich besser zusammen, wie diese Entwicklung aufgenommen wurde, als in der Person von Ralf Rangnick, finde ich, der im aktuellen Sportstudio die Viererkette erklären sollte und dafür nicht bewundertes Kopfnicken geerntet hat, sondern den spöttisch gemeinten Spitzennamen der Fußballprofessor und einige beleidigte Aussagen unter anderem von Erich Riebeck. Er hat dann allerdings auch zurückgeschossen. Ich habe ein Zitat gelesen. Ja, vielleicht hat Erich Riebeck meinen Vortrag auch deshalb nicht gut gefunden, weil seine Frau ihn danach gefragt hat, warum spielen wir eigentlich nicht so. Das fand ich auf mehreren Ebenen dann auch recht frech, sage ich mal. Und ich würde aber ganz gerne mit dir kurz in diesen Sportstudioauftritt reinhören und dann auch in die Zusammenfassung, die der Moderator Michael Steinbrecher gemacht hat, weil es zum einen nochmal erklärt, worum geht es eigentlich, was waren quasi die Punkte, an denen diese von dir genannten Personen innovativer waren als der Rest Fußball Deutschlands. Und gleichzeitig ist es halt schon ein Zeitdokument, weil wir alle wissen, was danach mit der Person von Ralf Rangnick passiert ist. Hören wir mal rein.
Ralf Rangnick, seit Jahren reden wir nun schon über Viererketten und Raumdeckung. Man hat so das Gefühl, es ist fast ehrfurchtbar, wenn man über dieses System redet. Jetzt haben wir hier mal eine Taktik-Tafel. Es gibt viele Leute bei uns zu Hause, die uns zuschauen, die sagen, wir verstehen immer noch gar nicht genau, worum es geht. Können Sie es mal kurz beschreiben?
Zunächst mal zum Thema Viererkette. Die Viererkette ist für uns eigentlich nur ein Mittel zum Zweck. Denn das, was wir eigentlich spielen wollen, ist extrem ausgeprägtes Pressing. Wir wollen versuchen eigentlich immer, den gegnerischen Ballbesitzer mit mindestens einem an Überzahl zu attackieren. Und da ist es einfach wichtig, dass die Spieler auch eine Grundordnung haben, wo sie wissen, dass jeder Spieler auch wirklich rückengedeckt ist. Also so viel einfach mal zu dem Thema Viererkette. Vielleicht noch ein weiterer Mythos, der ja in Deutschland immer noch existiert. Eine Viererkette spielt ohne Libero. Wir spielen nicht ohne Libero, nur ist es eben bei uns so, und wir werden das nachher vielleicht gleich mal sehen, an der Situation, dass unsere beiden Innenverteidiger diesen Libero je nach Situation erzeugen. Je nachdem, über welche Seite der gegnerische Angriff kommt, ist mal der eine und mal der andere Innenverteidiger eben unser Mann, der den anderen sichert.
Das muss man sich mal geben, er muss im Jahr 1998 sich noch rechtfertigen und ein Libero-Argument bringen. Hören wir noch kurz in die Zusammenfassung von Michael Steinbrecher, nachdem sie ein paar Minuten lang Magnete an der Tafel entlang geschoben haben.
Aufmerksam. Ich fasse das jetzt nochmal in meinen Worten zusammen. Das heißt, man orientiert sich am Ball. Man versucht in Ballnähe Überzahl zu schaffen. Man versucht dem Gegner am Ball Zeit und Raum zu nehmen. Und man deckt nicht gegner- oder zuordnungsorientiert, sondern gefahrenorientiert. Das heißt, der Spieler ist nicht so interessant, sondern man deckt immer ballorientiert. Richtig?
Korrekt.
Ist richtig zusammengefasst.
Haben Sie noch Kapazitäten frei?
Ja, er fällt einem ein bisschen. Und er war damals taktisch im Denken innovativer als der amtierende Nationaltrainer. Das muss man tatsächlich so sagen. Aber es sollten ja auch noch andere Zeiten kommen. Lass uns mal noch kurz über ein paar Sonderfälle des Fußballs reden, die dann so mit den 2000ern kamen, bis wir dann, glaube ich, bei der nächsten großen Entwicklung landen, dem FC Barcelona unter Reikart und dann Pep Guardiola. Ich habe da jetzt einfach ein paar Namen rausgesucht. Eine Mannschaft, an der kommt man nicht vorbei, da weiß ich aber wirklich gar nicht, ob das aus taktischer Sicht wirklich relevant ist. Da hilf mir bitte. Die Galaktischen, Real Madrid mit Figo, Zidane, Ronaldo, Beckham, Owen, Raúl, aber auch Defensivspielern wie Jero, Markelele, Solari. War das tatsächlich nur dieses Ensemble aus Einzelspielern, aus sehr, sehr guten Einzelspielern, wie es damals dargestellt wurde, oder war diese Mannschaft auch taktisch interessant?
Die war auch taktisch interessant, würde ich behaupten. Weil nämlich die hatten ja eigentlich nur eine Hochzeit, die, würde ich sagen, eigentlich nur sehr kurz war. Die haben ja 2000 und 2002 die Champions League gewonnen. 1998 okay auch, aber damals noch mit die Heinkiss, und damals waren das noch nicht die Galaktischen, da waren noch nicht die ganzen Star-Star. Und diese Hochzeit hat es nämlich Vincente de Bosque geschafft, dass dieses extrem offensive Gerüst mit diesen Stars einfach sehr gut funktioniert hat. Einfach so funktioniert hat, dass man die defensiven Absicherungen trotz dieser ganzen Star-Power vorne hatte. Weil man auch hinten mit Macelele zum Beispiel einen Sechser hatte, der das ausbalancieren konnte. Und der hat halt so ein extrem offensives System gespielt, aber hatte trotzdem defensive Stabilität da reinbekommen. Und das fand ich sehr faszinierend. Finde ich auch heute noch, wenn man das Team ansieht, faszinierend. Und sie waren halt, solange Dil Boske da war, sie waren 2000. Sie waren eigentlich auch 2001. Das wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht gerne hören. Aber sie waren eigentlich auch 2001 das beste Champions-League-Team. Und 2002 auch. Da haben wir wieder diesen Mix.
Ich kann mit der Aussage, dass sie das beste Team waren. Damit kann ich leben. Viel zu zwei. Dann hätte ich noch zwei, drei Mannschaften, die interessante Gegenkonzepte dargestellt haben. Aber immer nur singulär. Wo ich aber noch weiß, dass damals viel drüber diskutiert wurde. Vielleicht aber auch in Deutschland gerade deshalb, weil da dann der deutsche Fußball so langsam in Umbruch kam. Das können wir dann später nochmal kurz rekapitulieren. Das eine ist bei der WM 2002, Südkorea unter Ruis Hitting. Die einen krassen Fußball gespielt haben. Ich weiß noch, der hat zum Teil mit fünf Stürmern gespielt. Und getragen von einer unglaublichen Euphorie in den Stadien, hat Südkorea ja bis ins Halbfinale gebracht. Und gegen Deutschland dann jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so wahnsinnig verdient ausgeschieden. Das war nur ein Tor. War das ein wildes Einmal-Phänomen? Oder war da auch taktisch irgendwas, was man quasi mitnehmen kann?
Schwierig. Hedin ist natürlich ein Trainer, der auch die Ballons immer hat, aber auch gerne offensiv spielen lässt. Auch in sehr schnellen Konterfußball spielt. Der mit Südkorea damit derzeit ein bisschen voraus war, weil dieses wirklich sauschnelles Spiel, das kam dann erst ein paar Jahre später. Das, was wir heute gewohnt sind, halt Ball gewinnen und ab geht die Luzi. Das kam dann eigentlich erst ein paar Jahre später und der war derzeit ein bisschen voraus. Wobei man natürlich bei Südkorea 2002 auch gucken muss, die hatten sehr viel Glück, dass sie da ins Halbfinale vorgestoßen sind und sind dann auch verdient gegen eine gar nicht so starke deutsche Mannschaft ausgeschieden. Also von daher würde ich jetzt da die nicht so hochhängen wollen.
Was machen wir mit vielleicht einer der größten Sensationen der Fußballgeschichte, nämlich Griechenlands Europameistermannschaft von 2004 unter Otto Rehagel?
Eine der interessantesten Dinge, die ich festgestellt habe, als ich das Buch gemacht habe, und das habe ich erst festgestellt, als es fertig war, dass der Name Otto Rehagel in meinem Buch über die Geschichte der Fußballtaktik in Deutschland kein einziges Mal auftaucht. Weil nämlich Otto Rehagel als Trainer nie irgendwas gemacht hat, was in irgendeiner Weise innovativ war. Sondern er hat immer so spielen lassen, wie man eigentlich zehn Jahre zuvor hat spielen lassen. Und hat dann damit so die Gegner überrumpelt. Und das hast du bei 2004 ganz stark gehabt. Dass sie einfach mit einem 5-4-1 gespielt haben, teilweise mit Libere und Mannendeckung. Und dass dann die Gegner, die alle Raumdeckung gewohnt waren, die alle gewohnt waren, dass der Gegner zumindest versucht zu konnten, nicht nur einen langen Ball zu spielen. Die waren das alle nicht mehr gewohnt. Die waren damit wirklich sichtbar überfordert, dass sie verfolgt wurden vom Gegner. Und damit hat dann im Endeffekt er den großen Erfolg gefeiert. Es war auch gar nicht so groß anders, wie seine Lautermannschaft 1998 gespielt hat. Das war ein sehr ähnlicher Fußball, auch vom System her. Und das ist sehr interessant, dass man mit dieser rückschrittlichen Taktik einen Fortschritt wieder hatte, weil man einfach den Gegner so doll überrascht hat.
Da sind wir wieder beim Wettbewerbsvorteil durch Innovationskraft. Der ist mal größer, mal kleiner, beziehungsweise mal nachhaltiger, mal kurzfristiger. Ich glaube, bei Griechenland ist es keine steile These zu sagen. Es war ein kurzfristiger Wettbewerbsvorteil. In diesem einen Turnier hat das den Titel gebracht. Und danach ging es aber dann langsam bergab. Und bei anderen Innovationen ist es halt größer.
Da spielt natürlich wieder der Faktor Glück mit rein. Es ist ja immer natürlich wie immer. Es ist natürlich nicht nur Taktik.
Genau.
Frankreich über dem Zenit hinweg, dann Nedd wird im Halbfinale verletzt, dann im Finale Portugal mit Pech.
Und ja, vollkommen irre war es, weil die EM im eigenen Land war und sie das Auftaktspiel gegen Griechenland schon eins zu null verloren hatten, weil die Pointe, dass das erste und das letzte Spiel dieser EM sein sollte. Ich hab mir noch aufgeschrieben, in meiner Erinnerung war das zum ersten Mal, dass ein Team einen wirklich nachhaltigen Vorteil hatte durch gut ausgeführte Standardsituationen. Ist das einfach nur Verklärung in meinem Hirn?
Nein, nein, das ist auch so. Das ist auch etwas, wofür Rehagel steht und wo man auch das Gefühl hat, ok, da steckt Systematik hinter. Wir reden natürlich immer, wenn wir über Fußball reden, über Systeme, wir reden über das Spiel mit Ball, wir reden über das Spiel, wenn der Ball im Spiel ist und nicht, wenn der Standard ist. Weil natürlich die Geschichte des Standards auch sehr interessant wäre, da mal zu gucken, weil auch da natürlich eine Systematisierung stattfand und für die natürlich auch der gute Herr Rehagel mit seinen Gerichten steht.
Ok, dann hätten wir 2004. 2005 gab es eins der krassesten Champions-League- Finale aller Zeiten. Liverpool gegen den AC Mailand 3 zu 0 zur Halbzeit für Mailand 3 zu 3 nach regulärer Spielzeit und dann ein Sieg im Elfmeterschießen. Nur dieses eine Spiel wäre es mir jetzt nicht wert gewesen, über Liverpool unter Benitez zu reden. Allerdings hatte ich den Eindruck, dass er auch taktisch damals viel gemacht hat. Also er war zum Beispiel der erste Trainer, von dem ich gelesen habe, dass er die Mannschaft in der taktischen Formation aufgestellt hat beim Warm-Machen und sich dann bewegt hat. Er war der Ball und dann einfach nur die ganze Mannschaft hat verschieben lassen, was ich mir ultra langweilig vorstelle als Spieler.
Das hat aber doch Saki auch schon gemacht, oder?
Stimmt, da gibt es dieses Zitat, dass er sogar ihnen nur gesagt hat, wo der Ball ist und sie dann quasi ein Geisterspiel gespielt haben.
Stimmt. Ich will jetzt hier immer nicht so Teams abtun und ich bin natürlich auch nie niemand, der alle Fußballspieler der Geschichte gesehen hat und wenn ich natürlich dann bestimmte Einschätzungen habe, dann nach dem, was ich gesehen habe, nach dem, was ich gelesen habe, nach dem, was ich so denke. Und ich würde jetzt livertural unter Benitez keinen großen Innovations- oder auch Wert für die Fußballgeschichte zuschreiben. Einfach, weil sie dieses Verschieben natürlich sehr gut gemacht haben und auch sehr gut mit einem Konterspiel angereichert haben. Aber es war halt nichts, was in irgendeiner Form was Neues war. Es gab auch nichts, was in seiner Form so extrem ausgeprägigt war, wie zum Beispiel dieses Raumverschieben und dieses Kontern später unter Mourinho sein sollte.
Und da muss ich noch kurz einschieben, was ist dann mit den Invincibles von Arsenal, diesem Team von Arsene Wenger, was ungeschlagen durch eine Premier League Saison kam?
Die sind wieder ein interessanterer Fall meiner Meinung nach, weil die halt tatsächlich diesen Begriffe One-Touch-Fußball, den ich oder One-Touch-Football auf Englisch, den ich vorher schon benutzt habe, geprägt haben mit ihrem Einkontaktspiel. Die natürlich dann damit wieder, dass sie technischen Perfektionen im Ball gepasst haben, dadurch einen Vorteil sich erarbeitet haben. Aber die natürlich auch wieder Anleihen hatten, einmal seit bei Saki und andererseits aber auch so ein bisschen bei Fanral Barca, was das Positionsspiel angeht.
Es verwebt sich alles ineinander und du hast jetzt gerade schon einen Namen genannt, der prägt den Fußball der 2000er Jahre definitiv und ich stelle die These auf, er ist vielleicht der pragmatischste Trainer der Neuzeit, nämlich Rosé Mourinho, du hast es schon genannt. Nochmal kurz zu seinen Stationen. Porto, sensationell Champions League gewonnen, Chelsea, Inter, Real. Ich muss seine Titel nicht aufzählen, vermutlich muss ich auch nicht erwähnen, was für ein Typ Mensch ist, zumindest in seiner Außendarstellung. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass wegen seines Pragmatismus und wegen der vielleicht nicht gerade immer schönen Spielweise Mourinho so ein bisschen unter Taktik-Kennern – ich weiß nicht, da wird die Nase ein bisschen gerümpft. Also ein Taktik-Liebhaber sagt natürlich, er findet Barca unter Reikert und Guardiola geil, als dass er sagt, er feiert es jetzt, wie Mourinho einfach unter anderem die Bayern 2010 auscoacht im Champions League- Finale. Aber damit tut mir eben doch eigentlich Unrecht.
Ja, tut man eigentlich auch. Das liegt auch natürlich daran, dass wenn du viel Fußball guckst und viel Taktik guckst, dass dann irgendwann so defensive Sachen normal werden und du halt hoffst, dass jemand diese defensiven Sachen ausspielen kann und du dann den Fokus darauf legst. Ich bin ein großer Freund lange gewesen von Mourinho, weil er eben, wie ich gerade gesagt habe, das ins Extreme eigentlich gemacht hat, dieses Saki-Spiel, dieses Verschieben im Raum, dieses, aber auch mit Pressing-Elementen, aber auch gerade dieses Konter-Element, dass man, dass er da halt sehr extrem gearbeitet hat und auch da gewissermaßen auf Standards gefiffen hat, sage ich mal. Zum Beispiel, das bekannte Beispiel war ja das Champions-League-Halbfinale 2010 gegen Barcelona, gegen gerade Jules Barcelona, wo Mourinho nach dem Spiel ganz klar gesagt hat, wir wollten den Ball nicht haben, was soll man mit dem Ball? Wenn wir den Ball haben, dann stehen wir defensiv nicht solide und dann kann Basar räumen, die diese ausnutzen können. Deswegen haben wir dafür gesorgt, dass der Ball so schnell wie möglich nach vorne geht und dass wir möglichst dauerhaft in der Defensivformation stehen. Das mag ich halt, dieses extreme Denken von Mourinho, der aber nicht nur in der defensive extreme denkt, sondern auch was offensive angeht, gerade was Konter angeht. Wenn man sich sein großes Jahr bei Chelsea anguckt, wo sie alle Rekorde eingestellt haben, Meister, geschossene Tore und so weiter, da war das schon ein verdammt feilschneller Offensivfußball seiner Zeit in dem Sinne voraus war.
Würdest du sagen, dieser Pragmatismus, dass man eben sagt, das gängige ist Ballbesitzfußball oder Konterfußball. Mourinho hat sich ja schon wirklich sehr genau auch auf den Gegner konzentriert. Also dieses Halbfinale gegen Barcelona ist dann ein super Beispiel für auch das Finale gegen Bayern, wo er gesagt hat, ich habe die Schwachstelle bei Bayern schon ausgemacht, alles easy, entspannt euch alle mal. Und dann haben die deutschen Journalisten alle gelacht, weil Bayern 2010 unter Van Raal in der zweiten Saisonhälfte echt gut war. Und im Endeffekt war es aber so, er hat erkannt, Van Beuthen ist jetzt nicht der Schnellste, dem stelle ich den Milito auf die Beine, zwei Konter, zack, 2-0. Dann noch ein bisschen Glück gehabt hinten drin. Müller macht eine Chance nach der Halbzeit nicht, ja, fertig ist die Laube. Glaubst du, dass das eine Auswirkung hatte, dieser Erfolg von Mourinho, wie er mit unterlegenden Mannschaften, also jetzt vor allem dann auch mit Porto zum Beispiel Erfolg hatte, dieses, was man heute modernen Trainern unterstellt, dass sie so immer für jedes Spiel einen eigenen Matchplan haben, dass das auch mit Mourinho Einzug in den Fußball gehalten hat?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also Mourinho war da auf jeden Fall ein Vorreiter, auch einer, der diese Saki-Philosophie, dieses Defensive halt noch in dem Sinne weiterentwickelt hat, dass er gesagt hat, dass er sich die Frage immer gestellt hat, wie kriege ich mit einer unterlegenden Mannschaft einen Vorteil her. Das, was wir vorher schon hatten, aber das ist, das ist, was nämlich auch Tuchel gesagt hat, das wäre so, das hätte man auch Mourinho sagen hören können, aber schon zehn Jahre vorher. In dem Sinne natürlich auch. Es hat trotzdem eine interessante Figur. Ich habe Jonathan Wilson, der die Inverting the Pyramid mal geschrieben hat, mal geschrieben hat, der das geschrieben hat, die Geschichte der Fußballtaktik. Der hat sich auch mal dann dazu geäußert, hat natürlich auch gesagt, dass mit der Art Fußball, wie er spielte, mit dem, mit der reaktiven Art, dass man halt immer auf den Gegner reagiert, dass das natürlich Erfolge bringt, aber das bringt ja natürlich keinen Platz ein in so einer Geschichte der Fußballtaktik. Und das stimmt natürlich auch, weil er hat nichts erfunden, er hat kein, nicht ideologisch irgendwie, er ist kein Ideologe, der jetzt wie zum Beispiel Kreu für eine bestimmte Art des Fußballs steht, sondern er war halt immer ein Wandler zwischen den Welten, der sehr parmantisch ist. Und damit hast du natürlich, wenn es nachher eine Geschichtsschreibung gibt, ist natürlich schwierig, die ihn dann irgendwie unterzubringen und ihn dann so angemessen zu würdigen. Weil er ist halt niemand, der irgendwas erfunden hat, muss man auch ganz klar so sagen.
Ja, das ist vielleicht wirklich der wesentliche Punkt. Deswegen reden wir jetzt zwar auch an dieser Stelle über ihn, aber wahrscheinlich nicht so lange, wie wir jetzt über den nächsten großen Schritt im Weltfußball reden werden. Nämlich, ich hab schon mehrmals angekündigt, Barca unter Reikart und dann unter Guardiola. Also wir sprechen jetzt über den Zeitraum von 2003 bis 2008. Das ist ein langer Zeitraum, da hat sich auch noch mal was verändert. Was macht denn das Spiel von Barca aus? Das lebt sich ja eigentlich bis ins Jahr 2016, dem wir das hier aufzeichnen, Jahr noch fort.
Das Spiel von Barca zeichnet aus, dass Guardiola die Mannschaft übernommen hat, als sie am Boden war, muss man so sagen. Die aus tollen Einzelspielern bestand, Ronaldinho, Eto, Deco, Puyol, Messi vielleicht auch noch dazu zählen, aber die halt zu sehr auf diese Einzelspieler fixiert, war aber zu wenig aufs System. Und was er dann gemacht hat, ist, dass er alles dem System untergeordnet hat. Das, was wir vorhin schon gesagt hatten mal. Das System steht über den Einzelspielern. Und dass er aber ein System entwickelt hat, das nicht nur defensiv war, sondern das gerade auch offensiv bei Ballbesitz funktionieren sollte. Guardiola denkt, anders als wir, nicht in Spielphasen, sondern er sieht das Spiel als eine Einheit. Also für ihn ist jederzeit defensiv und jederzeit offensiv. Das heißt, man muss jederzeit in der Lage sein, in Ballbesitz überzugehen und Pässe zu spielen zu können. Man muss jederzeit in der Lage sein, aber auch den Ball erobern zu können. Das war halt das Revolutionäre, was er gemacht hat. Stichwort Gegenpressing.
Wir haben es einfach schon zu lange nicht mehr gehört.
Gegenpressing ist ein Begriff, den Jürgen Klopp sich ausgedacht hat. Wir haben über das normale Pressing vorhin geredet, das Kollektiv erobern des Balles, wenn der Gegner am Ball ist. Das Gegenpressing bezieht sich ausdrücklich auf die Phase, wenn ich den Ball verloren habe. Das heißt, der Gegner steht noch an seiner Defensive-Formation, ich stehe noch Offensiv-Formation und ich versuche jetzt aus dieser Offensiv-Formation heraus, direkt den Ball zurück zu erobern.
War es gut? Ja, da fällt mir nichts mehr ein, wo ich da noch nachfragen sollte. Unter Guardiola gab es ja die Erweckung des Lionel Messi und so ein bisschen als eins der Schlüsselspiele wird da immer ein Klassikos gegen Real Madrid genannt. Der Mythos rankt sich, also das ist jetzt Aussage Guardiola, ob das so stimmt, weiß man natürlich nicht. Er habe am Vorabend des Klassikos Videomaterial von Real Madrid studiert und dabei gesehen, dass die Innenverteidiger-Spieler nicht ans defensive Mittelfeld übergeben. Das heißt, jetzt erinnern wir uns mal kurz mal, da gab es doch mal sowas mit einer falschen neuen Hidekuti, Sindela und so weiter, die sich zurückfallen lässt, wo genau dieses Problem ja letztlich ausgenutzt wurde. Dass es eben die Frage ist, wie decken wir jemand, der sich so zwischen den Linien, wenn wir jetzt mal die einzelnen Mannschaftsteile wieder so als Tischfuchsball uns vorstellen, dann gibt es zwischen den Linien ja einen umbesetzten Raum. Das hat der Messi gesagt und hat die noch irgendwie um 10 Uhr abends zu sich ins Büro ins Stadion kommen lassen angeblich. Und hat am nächsten Tag es auch in einer Mannschaftsbesprechung nicht angesprochen. Er hat nur kurz vor dem Spiel Xavi und Iniesta gesagt, ihr werdet Lionel zwischen den Linien sehen. Wundert euch nicht, gebt ihm einfach den Ball. Und Barca hat 5 zu 1, glaube ich, gewonnen. Das heißt, er hat einen Klassiker der Fußballtaktik wieder ausgepackt, die falsche Neun.
Genau, das ist ja das, was Guardiola sowieso ist. Guardiola sind diese Zahlenspieler, die sind 4-3-3, 4-2-3-1, völlig unwichtig. Für ihn geht es um die Besetzung der Zone. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass Guardiola das Spielfeld in verschiedene Bereiche einteilt. Wenn man das Spielfeld jetzt nehmen würde, würde er quasi Linienzeichen über das Spielfeld, auf der Horizontalen, auf der Vertikalen, und dann würde, wie so bei so einem Schachtbrett, dann würden da, was weiß ich, 30 verschiedene Felder entstehen. Und er würde von seinen Spielern verlangen, dass sie die Felder auf diesem Spielbrett besetzen, dass nicht zwei Leute in einem Feld stehen, dass immer, wenn ein Spieler in einem Feld den Ball hat, dass dann die Felder drumherum besetzt sind und so weiter und so fort. Da gibt es dann viele verschiedene Regeln, die es zu beachten gilt, weswegen Guardiolas Fußball auch relativ komplex ist und relativ schwierig und viel von den Spielern verlangt. Und er stellt sich immer die Frage, in welchen dieser Zonen habe ich jetzt einen Vorteil? Und gegen Real Madrid war das so, dass in der Zone vor der Abwehr hat er gesehen, da habe ich jetzt einen Vorteil und dann muss ich da einen Spieler reinstellen. Und dann war das für ihn mit Messi der perfekte Spieler, den man da reinstellen kann. Und so geht halt Guardiola vor. Und wie gesagt, er denkt bei dieser Besetzung dieser Zonen immer sowohl an das Defensive als auch an das Offensive Element. Also er denkt sowohl daran, dass man im Ballbesitz möglichst gut kombinieren kann. Aber er denkt auch daran, okay, wie kriegen wir dann nach dem Ballverlust eine Ordnung hin, in der wir gut nachsetzen können, in der wir gut wieder den Ball zurückerobern können. Und dieser letzte Punkt, der war aus meiner Sicht das wirklich Neuartige am Barcelona-System. Dass sie halt genau geguckt haben, okay, wie können wir den Ball möglichst schnell zurückerobern, sodass der Gegner gar nicht erst in diesen Konter reinkommen kann.
Also das war quasi die defensive Stabilität, so wie Deutschland damals am Hindukusch verteidigt wurde. So hat Barca sein Tor schon in der gegnerischen Hälfte verteidigt, da schon den Ball gewonnen. Vielleicht nehmen wir auch schon ein bisschen zu lange auf.
Ja, ich habe dich lieb, aber ich glaube, das könnte man als Preis für den schrägsten Vergleich nominieren.
Ok, das nächste Mal packe ich wieder die Käsetheke aus.
Es ist notiert.
Jetzt ist aber ja noch die Frage, also das erklärt defensive Stabilität. Dazu kommen noch wirklich wieder hervorragende Einzelspieler, du hast ja vorhin schon ein paar genannt. Das muss man sehen. Und jetzt ist aber die Frage, nur dadurch, dass ich auf dem Schachbrett Zonen besetze und mir gucke, wo habe ich Stärken, aus welchen Zonen kann ich ein Vorteil für mich erschießen. Nur daraus erziele ich ja noch keine Tore. Was macht man denn offensiv?
Genau. Es gibt auch noch ein Zitat von Guardiola, der gesagt hat, meine Arbeit bei Barca ist letztlich einfach. Ich muss einfach nur gucken, dass ich Xavi, Iniesta oder Messi frei bekomme. Und dann, boom, machen die ein Tor. Irgendeiner von denen wird die Idee haben. Das war ja auch so in der großen Zeit von Barca. Und das ist letztlich dann das, was Guardiola dann vor jedem Spiel guckt, individuell für den Gegner. Wo sind die Räume frei und welchen meiner Spieler bekomme ich da möglichst gut hin? Kriege ich es hin, dass Messi vor der Abwehr frei steht? Kriege ich es hin, dass Iniesta irgendwo auf dem linken Flügel seinen Freiraum bekommt? Und dann wird halt der Ball so lange gepasst, bis man den entscheidenden Spieler in diesem entscheidenden Freiraum bekommt. Und der dann durch eine geniale Aktion, durch ein Tripling, durch ein Pass ein Tor einleiten kann.
Also reduziert sich es auf individuelle Klasse?
Nein, weil ja, ja.
Also das System ist quasi, das System wird verwendet, um die individuelle Klasse zur Geltung kommen zu lassen.
Genau, ja. So ist es korrekt. Aber es reduziert sich nicht auf individuelle Klasse, weil natürlich das System ganz klar auf die Stärken und Schwächen der Spieler ausgelegt ist. Und das ist jetzt wieder ein neuer Punkt, aber der natürlich Gas. Was viele in Deutschland nicht verstehen, dass Guardiolas Bayern ein ganz anderes Team sind als Guardiolas Barca. Und dass, wenn Guardiola diesen Sommer City übernimmt, dann wird Guardiola City wieder ein ganz anderes Team sein. Und dann, weil man natürlich immer noch viele von diesen Vorurteilen, die aus der Barca-Zeit stammen, wie zum Beispiel, dass Pep nur Mittelfeldspieler haben will, die treffen nicht zu auf das Bayern von Guardiola. Weil er natürlich genau sich anguckt, was habe ich für Spieler und wie kriege ich die in Situationen, dass sie erfolgreich sein können.
Ja, da hören wir mal uns dazu an, wie er das in seinen Worten sagt.
Die Leute spielen, diese Mannschaft spielt 4-3-3, das ist gar nichts. Welche Qualität hat diese Spieler, diese drei spielen nach vorne. Wenn du spielst mit Robben, Ribery und Douglas Costa, ist es komplett anders, wenn du spielst mit Lewandowski, Müller und, ich weiß nicht, Thiago. Die Qualität ist komplett anders. Unsere Teilen um zu angreifen, unsere Teilen um zu verteidigen, ist komplett anders.
Also er hat quasi nochmal genau bestätigt, was du gerade gesagt hast. Bevor wir über die Bayern unter Guardiola reden, hätte ich aber noch eine Frage zu Barca unter Guardiola. Ich habe mich immer schon gefragt, ist Messi denn wirklich eine falsche Neun? Denn ich habe falsche Neun jetzt so gelernt, dass das der Mittelstürmer ist, der sich zurückfallen lässt. Für mich ist Messi aber ein Flügelstürmer, der so schräg diagonal in den Rückraum zieht.
Das ist er die meiste Zeit tatsächlich gewesen. Im ersten Guardiola-Jahr und auch später als Guardiola gegangen ist, hat er diese Rolle gefüllt. Aber tatsächlich in der Hochzeit des Guardiola-Fußballs gab es keinen Mittelstürmer bei Barca. Da wurde ja auch Eto nach einem Jahr verkauft, mit Ibrahimovic hat es nicht so ganz funktioniert. Und dann hatte man tatsächlich zwei Außenstürmer, meist Iniesta und Petro oder Iniesta und Sanchez. Und in der Mitte hatte man Messi. Und der hat dann tatsächlich falsche Neun, zurückfallenden Stürmer, wie man auch mal das nennen möchte, gespielt, der von der Mittelstürmer-Position aus agiert hat.
Er hat tatsächlich eine klassische falsche Neun gespielt.
Ja, wobei klassisch sehr schwierig ist zu sagen. Weil so viele falsche Neun gibt es jetzt auch nicht. Und das ist natürlich ein ganz anderer Fußball gewesen, den man 50 Jahre später als heute. Messi ist ja auch oft mit Flüge ausgewichen. Wahrscheinlich deswegen der Eindruck auch von dir, der auch nicht komplett falsch ist. Das hat Hidikute zum Beispiel nie gemacht. Hidikute ist nicht über die Flüge gekommen. Da gibt es natürlich dann Unterschiede im Detail, klar.
Mit dieser Barca-Mannschaft unter Guardiola setzt auch die Zeit an, in der die spanische Nationalmannschaft den Weltfußball dominiert. Und das ist durchaus bemerkenswert, denn das vergisst man glaube ich immer viel zu schnell, wie lange die kein Titel mehr gewonnen hatten, vor der Europameisterschaft 2008. Und wie dominant sie dann tatsächlich waren bis zur WM 2014, da ging es dann raus mal. Aber selbst da hatte man irgendwie das Gefühl, hätten sie es irgendwie auf die Kette gekriegt, was sie eigentlich können, dann wäre das noch viel weiter gegangen im Turnier. Gibt es denn wesentliche Unterschiede zwischen der spanischen Nationalmannschaft dieser Zeit und dem Barcelona? Oder kann man sagen, das war quasi die Fortführung des Barcelona-Spiels mit den wichtigsten Spielern plus noch so ein bisschen aufgefüllt?
Da gibt es schon wesentliche Unterschiede, weil die spanische Nationalmannschaft das Ballbesitzspiel sehr viel defensiver ausgeführt hat. Es wird ja immer gerne diesen Ballbesitz-Teams vorgeworfen, dass es langweilig sei, weil sie halt einfach nur den Ball von Abwehrspieler zu Abwehrspieler laufen lassen und halt vorne nichts passiert. Also die nutzen halt Ballbesitz, um selber keine Tore einzufangen, weil wenn ich den Ball habe, kann der Gegner kein Tor schießen. Und dieses Klischee trifft meiner Meinung nach nicht zu auf gerade Jolas Barcelona, die sehr viel tororientierter gespielt haben. Weil wir sie halt durch ihr Gegenpressing sehr viel abfangen konnten dann wiederum. Deswegen hatten sie halt dauernd den Ball und hatten gefühlt immer 80 Prozent Ballbesitz. Wohingegen Spanien doch sehr viel langsamer und sehr viel tiefer den Ball hat zirclären lassen. Eine Anlehnung an dieses Wort Tikitaka, das man ja für den spanischen Ballbesitzfußball verwendet, sprechen auch manche Spanier bei der spanischen Nationalmannschaft von Tikinaccio. Das ist so ein Kunstwort aus Tikitaka und Katanaccio, weil das eben so ein defensives, orientiertes Ballbesitzspiel ist.
Vielleicht auch dem geschuldet, dass das Gegenpressing, was Guardiola unter Barca hat spielen lassen, oder jetzt ja auch bei den Bayerns, da muss man auch perfekt aufeinander eingespielt sein. Das ist vielleicht mit einer Nationalmannschaft gar nicht so leicht herzustellen, wo man sich ja nur alle paar Wochen mal sieht für ein paar Trainingseinheiten.
Ja, das auch, aber es war natürlich auch so ein Kompromiss-Ding von Del Bosco, weil er natürlich gesehen hat, dass die Spanier, dass Barcelona das Nürnberg-Uta war und dass da auch seine meisten Spieler und seine wichtigsten Spieler waren. Und er dann natürlich das Spiel so gewissermaßen auch an diese Spieler anpassen musste, weil er selber war eigentlich auch immer ein Trainer, der für ein sehr viel schnelleres Spiel stand, gerade bei seiner Zeit bei Real Madrid. Und er hat dann aber auch das angenommen, was ihm die Spieler geboten haben. Da sind wir dann wieder beim Einfluss von Spielern und Taktik.
Und jetzt wissen wir ja alle, Guardiola ist zumindest standaufnahme dieses Podcasts noch Trainer beim FC Bayern. Du hast schon gesagt, dass die Vorurteile, die aus seiner Barcelona-Zeit mit ihm nach Deutschland kamen, auf Bayern nicht zutreffen. Was hat er denn verändert im Spiel jetzt im Vergleich zwischen diesen beiden Mannschaften?
Er hat bei den Bayern ist das Spiel sehr viel stärker auf die Flügel ausgerichtet. Da haben wir wieder die Frage, wie kriege ich meine besten Spieler in Positionen, dass sie Erfolg haben können. Bei Barcelona waren die besten Spieler im Zentrum. Xavi, Iniesta, Messi als falsche Neuen. Und da war das diese Achse, die zentrale Achse. Bei den Bayern sind die besten Spieler Robben, Ribery, mittlerweile auch Costa, mittlerweile auch Coman, die man in Eins-gegen-eins-Situation bringen muss. Dementsprechend ist das Mittelfeld auch gerade mit den Jahren unter Guardiola immer stärker geschwächt worden. Und der Fokus liegt immer mehr auf den Außen. Den kann man auch allein durch die Transfers sehen. Ich kann immer nicht sagen, wie weit Guardiola da drin steckt. Aber natürlich, wenn man Schweinschläger verkauft, wenn man groß verkauft, wenn man da von Vidal holt, dann verschiebt sich die Arithmetik des Spiels. Die Arithmetik des Bayernspiels ist so, dass sie den Ball in der Abwehr zirkulieren lassen und von da aus die Außen suchen. Und gar nicht so sehr dieses Mittelfeld-Ding, was ja immer für Guardiola steht. Aber da hat nichts damit zu tun bei den Bayern. Weil die dieses Mittelfeld kaum mehr bespielen. Die spielen über die Außen viel stärker, weil sie halt da ihre Stärken sehen.
Und wie hat sich die Rolle der Abwehr unter Guardiola dann im Aufbauspiel verändert?
Bei Bayern sind natürlich die zentralen Figuren des Aufbauspiels mittlerweile in der Abwehr. Das muss man ganz klar so sagen. Alonso, der zwar ein Mittelfeldspieler ist nominell, aber der sich immer zurückfallen lässt eigentlich. Also der immer aus der Abwehr eigentlich aufbaut. Damit natürlich auch im Spielaufbau und Abwehrspieler praktisch. Boateng, der eine ganz zentrale Figur ist. Die halten natürlich auch diese weiten Bälle auf die Flügel spielen. Wobei bei Barca die Abwehrspieler eher dazu da waren, den Ball zu Busquets oder auch vor allen Dingen zu Xavi zu tragen. Und der sollte dann den Ball verteilen. Wobei wir jetzt natürlich auch wieder unterschiedliche Zeiten haben. Wobei wir unterschiedliche Ligen haben. Das ist das Widerumfeld. Weil bei Barca in der spanischen Liga als Barcelona groß war, haben sich die meisten Gegner hinten reingestellt. Und es war relativ einfach, den Ball zu Xavi zu bekommen. Wohingegen selbst in der Bundesliga, selbst gegen die Bayern, die meisten Teams, sich zumindest am Mittelkreis aufstellen. Und zumindest mal den Weg ins Mittelfeld blockieren. Wenn nicht sogar ein hohes Pressing spielen. Was einfach in Deutschland mittlerweile zum Standard geworden ist. Und da sieht man dann auch wieder die Unterschiede, die sich in Guardiola Spielweise da entwickeln. Weil natürlich die Abwehrspieler dann die freien Leute eher sind. Jetzt und auch eher die Spieler sind, die das Spiel tragen müssen.
Da habe ich den perfekten O-Ton zu. Hör mal genau hin.
Jerome Boateng hat im Mittelfeld gespielt. Kannst du mir deine Gedanken dazu erklären? Oder warum hast du Jerome im Mittelfeld aufgestellt?
Nach zehn Minuten hab ich gedacht, warum ich auch ein WM-Spiel in der Mitte?
Da hat er einen guten Tag.
Aber er wird sich schon was bei gedacht haben und nicht gesagt haben, Mensch, ich weiß nicht, dann mach ich jetzt einfach mal.
Er hat das später genau in dem in demselben Video sogar noch erklärt. Das bezog sich auf das Spiel gegen Hertha BSC. Und er wusste, dass sie mit einer Fünferkette tiefstehen werden, dass das Ziel sein muss, Flanken zu schlagen. Und dann sollten Vidal, Müller und Lewandowski mit drei Mann in den Strafraum und im besten Fall kommt noch ein Vierter mit dazu. Und deshalb hat der Spieler gebraucht, die direkt von hinten die Bälle auf die Diagonale, auf die Außenposition verteilen. Und deswegen hat er Boateng vorgezogen. Ich wollte aber zum einen damit sicherstellen, dass wir einmal kurz den Namen Boateng haben fallen lassen, denn das ist, glaube ich, auch einer der Schlüsselspieler bei dem Bayern gerade. Manuel Neuer, der das Torbatspiel – ja, ich glaube, man kann schon sagen, dass er es neu definiert hat in dieser Ausprägung. So viele Ballkontakte, so eine Passgenauigkeit, so ein hohes Stehen. Also sprich, wir sprechen jetzt davon, wie weit entfernt er von seinem eigenen Tor manchmal steht, um den Ball abzufangen. Ein Punkt, den ich ganz interessant finde, und der leitet da nämlich auch ein bisschen über noch zu den nächsten beiden Personen, über die ich gerne reden würde, die aus Fußball-Taktik-Sicht interessant sind. Man hat heutzutage den Eindruck, dass vielmehr noch während des Spiels verändert wird. Also zum Teil wird das dann mit Schachverglichen, das hat Felix Magert mit Wolfsburg damals schon immer so bezeichnet, auch bei diesem denkwürdigen 5 zu 1 gegen die Bayern. Aber noch deutlicher, finde ich, hat man es dann später bei Jürgen Klopp gesehen und auch Thomas Tuchel, über die ich gleich noch sprechen möchte. Und auch bei Guardiola wird gesagt, dass er oft nach zehn Minuten die Formation ändert und dann nach zehn Minuten noch mal und noch mal und noch mal. Ist das der moderne Fußball, dass eine Mannschaft heutzutage in der Lage sein muss, quasi auf Zuruf, den kompletten Stil auch umzuwerfen?
Stil nicht, glaube ich, aber die taktischen Mittel, um diesen Stil zu spielen. Da kommt vielleicht das Zitat, was du ganz, ganz voran mal hattest von Christoph Biermann und Ulrich Fuchs mit rein, die gesagt haben, dass die einzelnen Formationen immer unwichtiger werden, der Stil immer wichtiger. Das ist, glaube ich, das sieht man heute immer mehr, weil natürlich die Spieler heutzutage sehr viel besser ausgebildet sind als vor 20 Jahren. Wenn man sich guckt, wo die meisten deutschen Weltmeister von 1990 herkamen, die wurden meistens direkt mit 18, 19 von irgendeinem Dorfverein gecastet quasi und sind dann zu den Profis gekommen. Da hatten die großen Teams noch keine Jugendarbeit in dem Sinne, sondern haben halt die dann aus dem Amateurbereich übernommen. Und heutzutage kommen die Spieler mit zehn in das Jugendinternat und lernen dann mit zehn schon, wie sie richtig verschieben und mit elf lernen sie dann, wie man sich richtig im Dreieck aufstellt und mit zwölf lernen sie dann, wie man den Pass in zehntausend verschiedenen Formen spielt. Und dass man mit diesen Spielern natürlich eine andere Art Fußball spielen kann, als das vor 22 Jahren der Fall war, ist natürlich klar. Und dass man diesen Spielern dann auch taktisch mehr zutrauen kann, die natürlich taktisch auch besser geschult sind und die nicht einfach nur blind von hinten nach vorne die Außenlinie runterrennen. Das ist meiner Meinung nach auch klar. Und dann diese Unterschiede sieht man jetzt auch im Fußball, dass man auf Zuruf die Formation hat, die die Einstellung ändern kann. Ich war gerade noch ein bisschen so, dass ich möchte darauf mal eingehen, ein bisschen, weil du gerade gesagt hast, dass man den Stil ändern muss auf Zuruf. Ich glaube, das ist eher, das ist eine Sache, die noch schwieriger ist, weil natürlich wir hatten ganz am Anfang diesen Unterschied zwischen Strategie und Taktik. Also, dass Strategie etwas ist, was man über längere Zeit prägt. Ich glaube, das beste Beispiel, was man jetzt aktuell nennen kann, ist gestern dieses, ich weiß nicht, wann das ausstrahlt, aber nach unserer Aufnahme war es gestern, das Spiel Liverpool gegen Dortmund. Dortmund hat nämlich einen ganz anderen Stil gespielt, als sie diese Saison sonst gespielt haben. Sie haben nämlich sich in der Abwehr aufgebaut, mit zwei Viererketten zunächst, später mit einem 5-3-2 und haben einfach nur gegen den Ball gespielt, hatten nur 40 Prozent Ballbesitz, was einfach ein krasser Stilwandel ist zu dem Ballbesitzfußball, den Tuchel sonst hat spielen lassen. Einfach ein krasser strategischer Wandel und man hat dann auch am Ende gesehen, wie das schiefgegangen ist und wie das nicht funktioniert hat, weil die Spieler natürlich diese sehr krasse Umstellung nicht so gut verkraftet haben, wie man jetzt eine einfache Umstellung hat von einer Formation auf eine andere, weil sie einfach plötzlich einen ganz anderen Stil spielen mussten. Und das ist halt da noch der Unterschied, dass man einerseits die Taktik jederzeit ändern kann heutzutage und jederzeit das wird auch immer mehr werden. Aber ich glaube, Strategie ist etwas, was natürlich doch Trainer über längere Zeit prägt. Ich glaube, wir werden nicht erleben, dass Guardiola plötzlich auf einen totalen Abwehr Konterfußball umstellen wird. Genauso wenig, wie Bell.
Aber im Kleinen hat man das doch vielleicht schon gesehen. Also ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel an ein Auswärtsspiel der Bayern bei Borussia Dortmund noch unter Jürgen Klopp. Da hat Guardiola angefangen mit Manczukic und langen Bellen und nach 60 Minuten wechselt er erst Götze ein und dann Thiago und auf einmal spielen die nur noch im Kurzpass hinten raus und später hat auch Klopp gesagt, es ist halt schwierig, darauf zu reagieren, weil die haben halt auch dann den krasseren Kader. Und das ist doch letztlich genau das, dass der Stil verändert wird.
Ja, ja, hast du schon recht eigentlich, ja, hast du mir gut widersprochen, hast ein gutes Beispiel gewählt. Wobei ich jetzt noch behaupten würde, dass das auch noch, kann man noch einen langen Ball und noch als taktischen Mittel sehen. Was du von den Bayern nicht sehen wirst, ist, dass sie am eigenen 16er mit zwei Viererketten stehen und dann den Ball lang rausholzen, sondern sie werden immer noch weiter gegenpressen, sie werden immer noch weiter gucken, dass sie auf jeden zweiten Ball gehen.
Sie können nicht raus aus ihrer Haut, ja. Da finden sich auch gute Belege. Du müsstest mir jetzt nur die Champions League-Halbfinals gegen Real und gegen Barca nennen, der letzten beiden Jahre. Da hat er genau das gezeigt. Die wollen auch bei 0-2 in Barcelona spielen, die nach vorne. Auch bei Pep, der gesagt hat, du musst unbedingt ein Tor schießen und renn halt dann so ins 0-3 rein. Das stimmt schon. Und das passiert in der Mourinho-Mannschaft nicht.
Das ist dann das andere Beispiel. Mourinho wirst du nie mit so einem kompletten Ballbesitzspiel spielen, weil das einfach Sachen sind, die du über Wochen und Wochen hinwegträgen musst. Und das musst du auch den Spielern immer und immer wieder einbläuen. Und das ist, glaube ich, nichts auch, was du von einem Moment auf den anderen groß ummelden kannst.
Wir werden ja Pep in Erinnerung behalten als dem Berserker der Linie, und zwar in andere Hinsicht als Jürgen Klopp zum Beispiel, der gern mal den vierten Offiziellen verspeist hat. Also nicht mal an der Konsole stellt man so oft an seiner Taktik rum wie er und ruft so viel rein und weist die Spieler zurecht, das ist quasi – das ist mein Professor, nicht Ralf Ranglick im Sportstudio. Was meinst du, kommt das an? Ist das vielleicht nur Kompensation eines Fußballverrückten oder ist das tatsächlich was, was heutzutage von Spielern gefordert ist, dass die in einer eh schon körperlich wahnsinnig anstrengenden Situation auch noch irgendwie mit so mentalen Denkaufgaben umgehen können?
Das ist eine interessante Frage und das habe ich auch noch nicht abschließend beantworten können für mich. Da müsste man mal mit tatsächlich mit Guardiola-Spielern reden darüber, ob das, was er da außen brüllt, ob das tatsächlich ankommt. Andererseits, man sieht ja immer wieder, dass auch im Spiel umgestellt wird. Also, irgendwas muss da ja ankommen, weil der Guardiola wechselt ja ständig die Formation oder tauschen plötzlich die Verteidiger die Plätze oder was weiß ich nicht. So ganz kleine Sachen, wo du halt siehst, okay, die sind geplant. Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie aus Versehen passiert. Hups, bin gestolpert und bin jetzt in einer anderen Formation. Deshalb glaube ich schon, dass das eine Auswirkung hat. Deswegen glaube ich schon, dass das natürlich auch Guardiolas große Stärke ist, dass er bei der Strategie zwar sehr rigide ist und sehr fest ist und sehr an sein Ballbesitzspiel glaubt, aber dass er jemand ist, der das taktisch von einer Minute auf die andere komplett umwerfen kann.
Ich glaube, in der Spielvorbereitung, in der Gegnerbeobachtung, in der taktischen Ausrichtung und vielleicht auch in der Trainingsmethode sind sich Trainer eines bestimmten Levels, glaube ich, sehr ähnlich und vielleicht aber in dem Reagieren während des Spiels unterscheidet sich dann noch die die Spreu vom Weizen. Also es ist schon interessant zu sehen, wie zum Beispiel ein ein Thomas Tuchel auf Umstellungen von Guardiola reagiert im Vergleich zu einem Victus Kripnik, Armin Fee und so weiter. Vielleicht ist das tatsächlich der Unterschied. Soll ich dir mal vorspielen, was er selbst dazu sagt? Ich weiß allerdings nicht ganz, ob man ihn dafür vollnehmen kann.
Schieß los! Wenn du unterm Spiel was siehst, was dir nicht gefällt und du willst die Taktik ändern während des Spiels und du gibst Anweisungen draußen an der Seitenlinie, wie viel kommt dabei den Spielern an oder können die das während des Spiels auch umsetzen?
Normalerweise, wenn sie auf der Seitenlinie sprechen, verstehen sie mich nicht.
Aber Bibiana Steinhaus versteht dich?
Nein, ich bin nicht in der Lage, zu sitzen auf der Bank. Ich bin nicht wo, ich muss schauen, ich kritisiere meine Spieler und das ist mein Beruf in diesem Moment. Ich denke, sie verstehen mich, aber sie verstehen mich nicht. Es ist nur in der Hauptzeit.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich diesen Eindruck oft auch. Aber gut, er stellt definitiv während des Spiels um. Genug über Guardiola geredet. Ich denke, wir alle haben gesehen, was er schon fußballtaktisch verändert hat, auch auf einer größeren Metaebene betrachtet. Und da wird ja vielleicht auch noch einiges kommen.
Ich würde vielleicht noch mal kurz zusammenfassen einmal, weil wir jetzt sehr auf dieser Bayern-Basa-Ebene waren, um diese historische Dimension reinzubekommen. Natürlich diese Detailversessenheit, diese Umstellung und auch dieses Gegenpressing, das waren halt die Sachen, die Guardiola auf jeden Fall seinen Platz in den Fußballgeschichtsbüchern bringen wird und auch schon gebracht hat. Also da kann noch kommen, was will, aber das ist halt das, was Guardiola geprägt hat.
Und dann müsste er jetzt eigentlich dann – ist die Frage, wir hatten ja bisher immer so Wechselbewegungen zwischen Defensive verbessert sich, dann findet die Offensive eine Antwort darauf, es pendet wieder zurück, vor und zurück und das ist ja so ein komischer – das ist ja ein Zwitter aus Offensive und Defensive, denn klar ist es eine Defensive Verbesserung, weil du hältst den Gegner vom eigenen Tor weg und gleichzeitig ist es aber auch ein offensives Element, weil du in einer wahnsinnig gefährlichen Zone den Ball wieder gewonnen hast.
Ja, sehr richtig. Es ist vielleicht auch in dem Sinne revolutionär, weil es was Komplettes ist, was alle Spielphasen betrifft, also wo man nicht mehr einzeln guckt, was passiert in dieser Spielphase, was passiert in jener Spielphase, was passiert, wenn ich den Ball habe, was passiert, wenn der Gegner den Ball hat, sondern es wird als ein kohärentes Ganzes gedacht. Und das ist, glaube ich, dann auch das, was das Revolutionäre daran ist, gar nicht so sehr diese Details, weil das sind halt Detailfragen letztlich, ob ich mit falscher neuen spiele oder mit echte Mittelstämme. Aber dieses komplett, ein Fußballspiel als ganzheitliche Einheit zu betrachten, das ist das, was man Guardiola zuschreiben muss, egal ob man jetzt diesen Ballbesitzstil schätzt oder nicht.
Okay, und das ist, ich glaube, damit haben wir genug Guardiola gewürdigt. Ich würde gerne mit dir noch über, ich würde mal sagen, drei Persönlichkeiten sprechen, die fußballtaktisch interessant sind und die jetzt mal ausnahmsweise alle drei aus Deutschland kommen. Und das zeigt dann vielleicht auch eine Entwicklung. Als letztes würde ich mit dir gerne über die Nationalmannschaft und Joachim Löw reden. Und dann können wir vielleicht auch diese Entwicklung, wie die Nationalmannschaft aus ihrem 2000er-Loch wieder rauskam, kurz beschreiben. Und dann gibt es aber noch zwei Trainer-Namen, die sind jetzt auch schon öfter gefallen. Beide haben bei Mainz und beim BVB gewirkt oder wirken noch. Das eine ist Jürgen Klopp, das andere ist Thomas Tuchel. Lass mal mit Jürgen Klopp anfangen, der seinen Start hatte, indem er dich zum Taktikexperten gemacht hat. Das würde ich als sein größtes Verdienst bezeichnen. Was war denn sein zweites größtes?
Ich glaube, da bist du alleine mit dieser Meinung, gerade unter BVB-Fans. Was Jürgen Klopp geschaffen hat, ist, dass er dieses Gegenpressing, was wir gerade mit Guardiola verbunden haben, dass er das nach Deutschen gebracht hat. Und dass er auch diese Formeln, wie Guardiola sie angewandt hat, weiterentwickelt hat. Jürgen Klopp hat dieses Gegenpressing sehr schnell kombiniert mit einem sehr vertikalen Spiel. Das vertikale Spiel, das hat er schon immer geliebt. Das hat er unter Wolfgang Frank, das hatten wir vorhin in dem Segment über die 90er genannt, als einen der Revoluzzer. Dieses vertikale Spiel hatte Klopp unter Frank bereits kennengelernt, hat er in Main spielen lassen und dann auch in seinen ersten Dortmunderjahren. Aber diesen kleinen Schritt von Dortmund als wirklich gute Mannschaft zu Dortmund als wirklich überragende Mannschaft mit 2 Meistertiteln, ein Pokalsieg, Champions League-Finale, das war halt, dass er dieses Gegenpressing, dieses systematische Nachsatz nach Ballverlust in seinen Spielstil eingefügt hat. In dem Sinne halt eine Weiterentwicklung, weil Klops Dortmunder in ihren besten Zeiten haben beide Umschaltmomente genutzt. Sowohl den Umschaltmoment nach Ballgewinn als auch den Umschaltmoment nach Ballverlust. Und das war halt was ganz Neues und ganz Spannendes in den ersten Dortmunder Jahren.
Kombiniert noch mit einer Fähigkeit zu Motivation und Rhetorischheit sehr, sehr beschlagen. Ich musste jetzt gerade bei deiner Schilderung des Gegenpressings daran denken, was er mal gesagt hat. Es gab das Spiel, wo Dortmund 3 zu 1 in München gewonnen hat durch Tore von Schahin, Hummels und den Dritten habe ich vergessen 3 zu 1. Das war die Meistersaison, die erste Meistersaison. Da hat er den Spielern vor dem Spiel gesagt, ihr müsst draufgehen wie Piranhas. Und vielleicht fasst das sogar diese beiden Komponenten gut zusammen. Das eine ist das Taktische, dass er ihnen sagt, ihr müsst im Gegenpressing schnell sein. Und das andere ist aber auch diese Fähigkeit zu motivieren und Bilder zu erschaffen, die für jeden greifbar sind.
Ich nenne es in meinem Buch so, er hat seine rhetorischen Fähigkeiten und seine Motivation in taktische Konzepte genutzt. Er ist ja nicht nur ein Motivator, er ist auch ein Taktiker. Er ist auch einer, der genau weiß, wie er mit einer Mannschaft vor allem gegen den Ball zu spielen hat. Aber er hat es immer geschafft, das mit einer Motivation zu kombinieren. Best of both worlds sozusagen.
Wenn wir diese Phase mit Jürgen Klopp in der Bundesliga betrachten, und wir haben jetzt auch schon vorgegriffen und auf die Cardiola Bayern geguckt, dann findet da ja so eine Entwicklung statt. Bei den Bayern, da will ich jetzt gar nicht im Detail drüber sprechen, aber im Schnelldurchlauf kleans man vollkommen nach Rheinfall, Heinkes rettet die Bude halt noch so ein paar Spieltage lang. Van Gaal bringt ihnen bei, dass man Positionen zu halten hat, wie man sich in eine Situation bringt, um Chancen zu kreieren. Und dann nimmt das so eine Entwicklung, die sich immer weiter fortführt. Und 2013 haben wir im Champions League-Finale Bayern gegen Dortmund, und die haben jeweils vorher Barcelona und Real aus den Halbfinals genommen. Das könnte man nur vom sportlichen Ergebnis her als Höhepunkt des deutschen Fußballs in den letzten 20 Jahren bezeichnen. Jetzt stellt sich für mich aber die Frage, jetzt gerade mit Blick auch auf Dortmund und der Klopp, waren das dann jetzt Innovationen oder war das wieder das Muster, das wir kennen und ja auch in deinem Buch oft nachlesen können, das einfach nur erfolgreiches aus dem Ausland adaptiert wird?
Es ist eine schwierige Frage, weil einerseits war es natürlich etwas, was nicht originär deutsch ist, wieder mal also Jürgen Klopp hat keine neue Formation genutzt, hat halt so 4-2-3-1, was aber zu der Zeit schon Standard wurde, hat halt Pressing spielen lassen, kompakt gestanden, Kontern, hat auch das Gegenpressing, was bei Barca kam, es war alles nichts Neues. Was natürlich neu war ein bisschen, war diese Kombination aus Gegenpressing und Konter, das kann man vielleicht Klopp sagen, ok, da war er seiner Zeit voraus, das war wirklich was brandneues, spannendes. Aber grundsätzlich auch hier wieder, dass man sich inspirieren hat lassen durch ausländische Trends.
Und dann würde ich eigentlich ganz gern mit dir, außer du sagst, du hast zu Jürgen Klopp noch was wichtiges zu sagen, würde ich gern mit dir über Thomas Tuchel reden. Ich habe, von ihm habe ich einen Vortrag gefunden bei YouTube, den werde ich in den Linken, da erzählt er eine halbe Stunde, ich glaube vor einem Think Tank, die Rule Breakers, nannte sich anscheinend diese Konferenz oder keine Ahnung, was er so gemacht hat bei Mainz, als er Trainer wurde. Und ich finde diese halbe Stunde wahnsinnig interessant, ich werde auch noch viele O-Töne daraus spielen, ich hoffe, du findest es ähnlich interessant wie ich. Und da kam ich aber dann langsam auf so einen Gedanken, vielleicht ist das Innovative, was auch Jürgen Klopp und Thomas Tuchel jetzt auch und vor ihnen vielleicht noch Joachim Löw und in kleinen Teilen auch Jürgen Klinsmann noch geleistet haben, vielleicht ist das eine Sache, die man gar nicht mehr so sehr auf dem Platz beobachten kann, sondern tatsächlich im Training. Ich habe den Eindruck, in Sachen Trainingsmethodik, Motivation, Ernährung, Psychologie, all diese weichen Faktoren, sage ich jetzt mal, erreichen diese Trainer tatsächlich die Maßstäbe, die viele andere nicht erreichen. Vielleicht ist das eigentlich das eigentliche Feld der Innovation, wo sie vielleicht auch ihre größten Berieten haben. Man kann es halt nur am schwierigsten beobachten.
Ja, wir kommen jetzt auch in ein Zeitalter, wo Fußballtrainer anders arbeiten und arbeiten müssen auch. Wir kommen weg von diesem Erfahrungsbasierten, dass ein Trainer sagt, ich weiß, wie das geht und ich habe das seit 20 Jahren so gemacht und es hat immer funktioniert. Sondern dahin, wo man es in der Wissenschaft so gerne evidenzbasiert, dass genau geguckt wird, was sind jetzt die neuesten wissenschaftlichen Ergebnisse, wie kriegen wir die unter an unser System, wie können wir damit umgehen. Und dass halt auch als Trainer sich immer weiter weiterentwickelt wird. Genau, die Laptop-Trainer, die dann halt genau gucken, was sind die Trends, wo können wir uns noch weiterentwickeln. Das ist natürlich auch etwas, wofür Tuchel steht und auch, wo natürlich Guardiola für steht, wo Löw auch gewissen Maße für steht. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen weg vom Taktischen, aber ich glaube, das ist auch ein anderer Aspekt.
Genau, also wie das Training geleitet wird. Ich würde dir dazu gerne mal zwei O-Tone vorspielen. Hören wir mal direkt rein.
Wir haben die Denkmuster meiner Spieler bezüglich der Spielsysteme aufgebrochen, aber wir haben sie total aufgebrochen bezüglich ihren Verhaltensweisen. Ich gebe Ihnen auch da ein Beispiel. Die Mannschaft hat in den ersten Spielen, die wir gemacht haben, Trainingsspielen, extrem häufig – Sie kennen sich das Fußballfeld, haben Sie vor Augen – dieses Rechteck und die Mitte ist extrem verdichtet, auch in der ersten Bundesliga. Also versuchen viele Mannschaften sehr früh über den Flügel den Durchbruch zu schaffen und nach vorne zu spielen. Jetzt hat meine Mannschaft extrem früh nach außen gespielt, quer, und hat dann versucht, an der Linie entlang Longline-flach unsere Angriffe auszulösen. Das war für uns ein absolutes No-Go. Wir wollten im Umkehrschluss den Gegner dazu zwingen, bis heute Longline-flach zu spielen, weil es unserer Meinung nach der ideale Passe ist, um selber eine Balleroberung aktiv zu erzwingen. Also meine Mannschaft hat den Denkmuster, wir spielen nach außen und wir spielen Longline-flach, das ist sicher, das ist bequem und soll der vorne gucken, was er macht, ich habe damit nichts zu tun. So, was haben wir gemacht? Wir wollten das nicht haben, wir wollten diagonal flach haben und zwar diagonal von hinten nach vorne und von vorne weiter nach vorne ins letzte Drittel. Wir haben einfach die Ecken unserer Felder abgeschnitten. Also das heißt, wir haben trainiert auf zwei Tore und das Feld müssen Sie sich vorstellen, da war das Tor und dann waren vielleicht noch seitlich vom Tor die normale Seitenlinie und dann gab es keine Ecke, sondern es ging diagonal weg, die Außenlinie. Wir haben in einer Raute gespielt, in einem diamantförmigen Spielfeld haben alle unsere Spiele stattgefunden und wieso? Weil das unser Prinzip war, diagonal flach ist bis heute ein Spielprinzip von Mainz 05 oder von mir, meinem Trainerteam und der Mannschaft und wir zwingen dadurch unsere Spieler in dieses Prinzip, aber wir erhalten in den Leitplanken, die das Feld vorgibt, ihre maximale Kreativität. Also es gibt keine Vorgabe, wie er in diesem diamantförmigen Spielfeld klarkommt und das wollen wir auch gar nicht, denn das verändert natürlich meine Coaching-Rolle extrem. Bis heute möchte ich das nicht, ich möchte nicht derjenige sein, der bei jedem Longline-Pass nach vorne in die Trillerpfeife pfeift und sagt, nein, wie oft habe ich dir gesagt, du sollst diagonal – das will ich überhaupt nicht sein, das nutzt sich ab. Nein, dann schneide ich einfach das Feld ein, dann brauche ich diesen Zuruf, diese Unterbrechung brauche ich nie mehr machen. Ich kann ihn beobachten, wie er in diesem Raum klarkommt und ich kann ihm helfen, besser klarzukommen, dann bin ich sein Unterstützer, im anderen Fall bin ich sein Kritiker und der, in dem er es nie recht machen kann und so weiter. Das verändert meine Coaching-Rolle in einer Art und Weise, wie ich sie unbedingt haben wollte und bis heute haben möchte.
Interessant, oder? Auch ganz interessant, wie alt ist das? Das war die dritte Saison bei Mainz. Ja, aber es ist auch schon wieder drei Jahre her. Ja, stimmt, das ist tatsächlich verrückt.
Weil nämlich tatsächlich dieses Diagonal und dieses Longline, das Longline-Spiel machen nur noch wenige. Es gibt immer noch genug Teams, die das machen, aber es machen immer weniger Teams und mehr Diagonal, wo halt auch dieser Vorteil weg ist einfach. Schon noch drei Jahre ist dieser Vorteil wieder weg.
Das ist echt Wahnsinn. Ja, das sagt er auch. In dem ersten O-Ton, den wir ganz vor mehreren Stunden von ihm gehört haben, sagt er ja auch, wir hatten einen Wettbewerbsvorteil für zwei Saisons und dann war er weg. Ich finde es interessant, also aus dem Aspekt, den ich gerade schon gesagt habe, dass ich den Eindruck habe, vielleicht kann man viel der innovativen Kraft, liegt jetzt tatsächlich in der Trainingsmethodik, die schwieriger zu beobachten ist. Da hat er auch noch was weiteres gesagt, das hat mich sogar fast sprachlos zurückgelassen. Ich kann es kaum glauben, da höre ich mal kurz rein, das ist nicht ganz so lang.
Diese Trainingsmuster, diese Verhaltensweisen sind bis heute geblieben, die haben wir erweitert, aktualisiert über neueste Erkenntnis der Gehirnforschung, die damit einfließen. Das bedeutet, wir trainieren unendlich viele Wiederholungen, aber wir trainieren niemals einschleifend. Es gibt keine einschleifende Passmuster von A nach B, von B nach C, von C nach D und dann zur Flanke, zum Tor, es gibt aber Wiederholungen. Es wird immer alles trainiert. Wir sind völlig weg aus dem Denkmuster, drei Monate X, drei Monate Y, drei Monate Z und im letzten Quartal das. Wir trainieren immer alles, vom ersten Training bis zum letzten Training der Saison. Wir trainieren in extrem verengten und veränderten Räumen, diamantfarbenes Spielfeld, wir trainieren im Kreis, wir trainieren auf 18 Meter Spielfeldbreite, mal 75 Meter Länge auf zwei Tore, wir trainieren auf 30 Meter Länge, aber 70 Meter Breite auf zwei Tore. Wir haben bis heute kein einziges Training auf dem ganzen Trainingsfeld 11 gegen 11 gespielt. Wir versuchen erst gar nicht, das Spiel vom Samstag zu kopieren, denn es wird uns nicht gelingen.
Um jetzt wieder einen Werbeblock hier reinzubringen. Wer tatsächlich sich für das interessiert, diese Philosophie und die Frage, wie trainiere ich das? Mein Kollege René Maritsch hat mit Marco Henseling zusammen ein Trainingsbuch geschrieben, Fußball durch Fußball heißt das. Das hat halt genau diese Philosophie zur Grundlage. Ganzheitliches Training, man trainiert immer alle Aspekte des Spiels, man trainiert nie einzelne Aspekte, man trainiert immer alle Aspekte. Man packt alle Aspekte, die ein Fußballspiel ausmachen, in eine Übung, das heißt Zeitdruck, Gegner, Ball und so weiter und so fort und das ist halt das, was Tuchel weiterentwickelt hat.
Ich fand's wirklich faszinierend, also vor allem auch diese Aussage, wir haben noch nie 11 gegen 11 auf großem Feld gespielt. Mein Gott, das war bei mir früher im Jugendtraining immer das Größte, wenn wir endlich 11 gegen 11 gegen durften, wobei so viel waren nie beim Training. Okay, 8 gegen 8. Fand ich wirklich interessant. Ein Aspekt, der viel schwieriger für uns Außenstehende zu beobachten ist, der aber glaube ich, vielleicht liegen da die kleinen Innovationen.
Auf jeden Fall, das ist das, womit man arbeiten kann, wenn man heutzutage sich einen Vorteil erschaffen will.
Und an der Stelle würde ich jetzt ganz gerne dann einmal noch kurz über die Nationalmannschaft reden. Denn als wir zuletzt über die deutsche Nationalmannschaft geredet haben, da lag Deutschland da nieder nach der EM 2000 ausgeschieden in der Vorrunde und ersetzte eine bemerkenswerte Entwicklung ein. Man kann viel dazu in deinem Buch nachlesen. Es gibt auch ein Buch von Raphael Honigstein. Im Englischen hieß es das Reboot und im Deutschen heißt es, glaube ich, der vierte Stern, wie sich der deutsche Fußball neu erfand oder irgendwie so. Sehr empfehlenswert.
Wieso sind die deutschen Titel immer so gräßlich? Wir hatten es vorher schon bei Revolution auf dem Rasen.
Ja, überhaupt diese Wortspiele mit Rasen finde ich furchtbar. Zurück zum Rasenfunk und zur deutschen Nationalmannschaft nach dem Jahr 2000. Du hast da auch, das gehört auch mit zu den tollsten Kapiteln in deinem Buch, wo du auch beschreibst, wie sich der deutsche Fußball weiterentwickelt hat. Was ist denn da passiert von 2000 bis 2014 bis zum Weltmeistertitel?
2000 hat man den Unterbau des deutschen Fußballs revolutioniert. Man hat gesagt, wir brauchen bessere Talente, wir brauchen mehr Talente, wir müssen die Talente besser schulen. Hat sehr viele Jugend-Schulen gemacht, hat die Trainer-Ausbildung revolutioniert, hat dafür gesorgt, dass moderne taktische Prinzipien von der ersten Trainer-Ausbildung teil sind, also Pressing, Verschieben, dass solche Dinge auch jeder, der einen C-Trainer-Schein hat, muss solche Dinge wissen heutzutage, das war damals auch anders. Man hat dann die Nationalmannschaft ab 2004 unter Jürgen Klinsmann komplett neu ausgerichtet, einerseits natürlich von der Professionalität her, andererseits auch taktisch, weil man natürlich gesagt hat, okay, wir sehen, dass dieser Weg, Verschieben, Schneller-Umschaltspiel, Verteidigungsraum, dass das der Weg der Zukunft ist. Und hat dann diesen Weg der Zukunft mitgegangen, mit Joachim Löw vor allen Dingen, der als, man weiß es ja heute, der 2006 das Gehirn der Mannschaft war eigentlich, der sich die Taktiken ausgedacht hat.
Über den Jürgen Klinsmann ja gesagt hat, er war der Erste, der mir innerhalb von drei Sätzen die Viererkette erklären konnte, wo ich mir gedacht habe, an diesem Zitat merkt man, dass Klinsmann noch aus dieser Generation von Spielern kommt, die zu dumm waren, 1994 die Viererkette zu spielen.
Ja, interessant dabei ist ja, die das auch gar nicht wissen. Das sind ja heute dann die Experten, die uns das zu erklären versuchen. Interessant den Punkt, den du ansprichst, weil ich komme schon wieder vom Thema ab, aber wenn es interessant ist, kann man es immer machen. Ist natürlich auch interessant, wenn du guckst, wer heute die großen Trainer sind und wie sich die 90er-Jahrespieler, wie die auf dem Trainermarkt so dastehen.
Ja, absolut. Wie gesagt, vorhin das eingeworfene Laptoptrainer war ja ein spöttisches Zitat von Mehmet Scholl, der gesagt hat, die Laptoptrainer, und damit meint er eben diese Generation, die Fußball quasi nicht auf die harte Art und Weise in den 90ern auf dem Fußballplatz gelernt hat, sondern eben in Nachwuchsleistungszentren und am Laptop. Aber die scheinen die Zukunft zu haben. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht mehr, was der Gegenbegriff von ihm dazu war. Laptoptrainer versus?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob er einen hat.
Wahrscheinlich hat er gar keinen.
Ich versuche, Mehmet Scholl so gut es geht zu ignorieren.
Jetzt hast du aber noch fünf Stunden hier was rausgehauen, was einigen Bühnen bereitet.
Ja, ich habe mir einen rausgehauen.
Kauft bitte trotzdem sein Buch, er ist ein netter.
Wir waren stehen geblieben bei der Nationalmannschaft, die natürlich auch nach der WM 2006 diese Entwicklung weitergegangen ist. Modernes Verschieben, vor allen Dingen Umschaltfußball. Das war das, was auch Jogi Löw bis 2010 eigentlich immer gepredigt hat. Man müsste sich der Premier League anpassen, man müsste schnell spielen, man müsse Geschwindigkeit reinbringen. 2010 kam dann dieses Erweckungserlebnis für Joachim Löw. Das war das Halbfinale gegen Spanien.
Ich dachte die Verletzung von Michael Ballack.
Das war das Erweckungserlebnis für Michael Ballack leider. 2010 kam dann das Halbfinale, wo man gegen Spanien mit dem Ballbesitzspiel verloren hat. Das habe ich jetzt auch relativ ausführlich in meinem Buch. Das war der Moment, wo Deutschland sich dann zum Ballbesitzspiel hingewandt hat. Weil auch Louis van Rall bei den Bayern kam, weil auch später gerade Jula kam bei den Bayern. Damit hat man dann einen neuen Weg gesucht, der dann letztlich 2014 auch erfolgreich zu einem WM-Titel geführt hat.
Jetzt würde man aber ja auch, wenn man auf diesen 2014er Weltmeister guckt, nicht behaupten, dass da taktische Innovationen Grundlage für den Erfolg waren, oder?
Nee, es war natürlich wieder eine Mixtur. Also es war eigentlich wieder so ein ganz typischer deutscher Erfolg, weil man wieder taktische Mittel genommen hat gegen Pressing, dieses Ballbesitzspiel aber auch angereichert mit teilweise sehr schnellem Umschaltverhalten. Dass man diese taktischen Mittel, die in den letzten 20 Jahren im Fußball berühmt geworden ist, die hat man auf deutsche Art und Weise zusammen gemixt und dann mit so ein bisschen deutscher Kampfkraft und mit einem bisschen deutschem Wir geben niemals auf, auch nicht in der Verlängerung des Finals. Das finden wir immer noch unsere Chance. Das hat man damit so kombiniert, hat damit wieder was deutsches, originär deutsches geschaffen, das aber in sich selbst nicht wirklich innovativ war. Das kann man so, wenn man die Metapher wählen möchte, das deutsche Ingenieurs-Kunst, das, was andere schon erfunden haben und gucken, wo wir es leichter machen können, wo wir es perfektionieren können. Das hat Jorahm Löw letztendlich gemacht und hat damit Deutschland zum vierten WM-Titel geführt.
So Tobi, und jetzt kannst du glänzen, indem du jetzt die Trends voraussagst. Was meinst du denn, in welche Richtung wird sich der Fußball weiterentwickeln? Ist da für dich etwas absehbar?
Für Leute, die den Ballbesitz Fußball nicht mögen, muss ich eine traurige Mitteilung machen. Ich glaube, diese Tendenz wird noch stärker werden, weil wir jetzt mittlerweile meiner Meinung nach die Defensive ziemlich ausgereizt haben. Es gibt natürlich immer noch Details, die man optimieren kann, aber jegliche Form des Pressings ist erfunden, jegliche Form der Balleroberung, jegliche Form des Kompaktverteidigungs im Raum, auf Mann – ich sehe da momentan nichts, was wirklich eine noch eine weitere Revolution sein kann. Ich sehe nur, dass der Weg momentan ist und auch Zukunft sein wird, die Frage zu beantworten, wie können wir Teams, die sehr gut verteidigen können, auseinanderspielen. Das sieht man gerade in Deutschland, aber auch in Spanien, dass Teams wie Barcelona, Bayern München und Dortmund im Moment den leichten Vorsprung haben. Diesen leichten Punkt Vorsprung, weil sie eben etwas mit dem Ball anzufangen müssen. Ich hatte auch in den letzten Monaten viel Einblick in die Jugendabteilung von großen Klubs, die mittlerweile sehr darauf bedacht sind, den Spielern schon ab dem Alter von zehn die richtige Positionierung bei Ballbesitz beizubringen. Wenn die Spieler das natürlich gelernt haben, wie wir dieses Beispiel mit dem Longline bei Tuchel hatten, dass man sowas nicht spielt, wenn die das von der Pico auf gelernt haben, dann hat es nachher der Trainer, der dann den Profikader übernimmt, hat es dann auch einfacher. In dem Sinne sehe ich da den nächsten Schritt der Weiterentwicklung.
Grundsätzlich hat ja die angreifende Mannschaft immer einen Vorteil gegenüber der verteidigenden Mannschaft, einfach vom Bewegungsablauf her. Es ist einfacher. Was glaubst du, welche Auswirkungen wird Technologie und letztlich vielleicht auch das Internet auf die Taktik haben? Wir haben diesen Bereich ein bisschen ausgespart, aber der war ja auch wichtig. Allein die Möglichkeiten, den Gegner zu beobachten, haben ja innerhalb der 90er Jahre rasant zugenommen und inzwischen kann jedes Training getrackt werden und so weiter. Also es wird immer verwissenschaftlicher. Glaubst du, das wird man auch tatsächlich irgendwann mal an irgendetwas auf dem Spielfeld erkennen können oder ist es auch so ein weicher Faktor, der es halt insgesamt ein bisschen besser macht, vielleicht im Bezug auf Belastungsdosierung von Spielern und so weiter?
Im taktischen Bereich ist es natürlich ein wichtiger Faktor, dieses Internet. Wenn wir natürlich das alte Beispiel wieder nehmen mit der falschen neuen Hede Kuti, die 1953 beim 6 zu 3 gegen England geglänzt hat und dann hat es ein ganzes Jahr, inklusive ich glaube über 10 Spiele, gedauert, bis dann mit Sepp Helberger jemand kam, der eine Idee hatte, dagegen vorzugehen. Das ist ja heute völlig undenkbar. Wenn ein Mannschaft einen taktischen Kniff hat, dann hat er spätestens zwei Wochen später eine andere taktische Mannschaft einen Gegenkniff, weil sie es einfach dann 30 mal auf Video angeguckt haben zwischenzeitlich und weil sie es 30 mal im 20 Mann großen Trainerteam dann fünf Mal durchgesprochen haben. In dem Sinne verändert Technologie natürlich auch die Taktik, weil sie das Spiel gläserner macht, weil jeder Spieler überall auf der Welt mittlerweile beobachtet werden kann. Weil wenn man einen Spieler für das System sucht, der perfekt passt, dann ist man nicht davon abhängig, dass gerade in der Nähe irgendein junges Talent auftaucht, sondern man kann gucken, okay, in Japan, zweite Liga, da spielt dieser Kagawa, der passt doch ganz gut in unseren Fußball rein, lass uns den mal kaufen. Das bringt natürlich dann auch eine Veränderung, weil Mannschaften einfach zusammengekauft werden können, auch nach Philosophie. Nicht die Philosophie nach den Spielern kommt, wie wir es in den 70ern und 80ern hatten.
Das betrifft quasi den Bereich Scouting. Was glaubst du, was wird sich beim Ingame-Coaching, also quasi dem Einwirken des Trainers auf die Mannschaft während des Spiels verändern durch Technologie? Warum erlaubt die DFL keine iPads am Spielfeldrand?
Das ist ein großes Rätsel, aber ich glaube, das liegt auch an der FIFA. Ich glaube, ich habe es mal gehört, die DFL würde es gerne erlauben, aber die FIFA erlaubt es nicht. Ich habe von einem Trainer mittlerweile auch gehört, dass sie keine iPads erlauben, aber Smartphones und dass sich jetzt die sämtliche Trainerteams Sonderbestellungen von Smartphones mit extra großem Bildschirm geholt haben, damit sie auch am Spielfeldrand diese Bildschirme haben. Das wird kommen. Auch jetzt schon gibt es einen Videoanalysten, der während dem Spiel mitschneidet und der dann in der Halbzeit die wichtigsten Szenen den Spielern zur Verfügung stellt. Das ist heute Usus bei allen Mannschaften. Bei der WM-Deutschland 2014, beim WM-Sieg, haben die deutschen Spieler ein Zimmer gefunden. Da waren dann zehn iPads aufgestellt und da konnten sie dann ihre eigenen Szenen aus dem Spiel gestern nochmal nachgucken. Die waren dann auch perfekt geschnitten und perfekt auf das, was der Trainer ihnen sagen wollte, zurechtgelegt. Also das sind Sachen, die den Fußball jetzt schon verändern. Ich glaube nicht, dass das zukunftsmöglich ist. Das gibt es jetzt schon.
Ich bin ja gespannt, was Augmented Reality mit Training verändern wird. Vielleicht musst du dann irgendwann nicht mehr die Spielkanten abschneiden, sondern du kannst es deinem Spieler im Display anzeigen, wo der Trainer jetzt gerne hätte, dass er hinläuft. Aber auch das werden wir im Spiel wahrscheinlich so direkt gar nicht sehen. Ich habe eine These, Tobi. Die würde ich an dir gerne testen. Ich habe den Eindruck, von der Technik her sind wir auf einem sehr hohen Level angekommen. Wir sind auch von der Ausbildung der Spieler her, vom spieltaktischen Verständnis auf einem hohen Level angekommen und bezüglich sportwissenschaftlicher Erkenntnisse, Ernährung, Psychologie und so weiter auch. Also ich glaube, in allen Bereichen hat eine wesentliche Innovation in den letzten zehn Jahren stattgefunden. Deshalb glaube ich, dass es immer schwieriger wird, mit einer vorbereiteten Taktik vor dem Spiel einen Gegner in Bedrängnis zu bringen, weil einfach zu viele Optionen vorher durchgeplant werden und die Spieler auch einfach auf Zuruf zu schnell darauf reagieren können. Deswegen habe ich manchmal so den Eindruck, vielleicht wird in Zukunft noch bedeutender werden, eine gegnerische Mannschaft mental zu schlagen. Es ist ein bisschen ein weiches Argument, es ist schwierig, ein Wort zu fassen. Aber als Beispiel, ich nehme mir als Juventus Turin zum Beispiel im Rückspiel gegen die Bayern vor, ich stelle mich jetzt nicht hinten rein, sondern ich gehe den richtig auf die Füße die ersten 15 Minuten, dann ziehe ich mich aber zurück und dann reagiere ich darauf, was der Gegner macht. Denn ich habe den Eindruck, das ist immer noch das, wo auch große Mannschaften Schwachstellen haben, wenn sich innerhalb des Spiels diese Dynamiken, die sind glaube ich nicht immer zufällig, dass mal ein Team eine starke Phase hat und mal das andere. Das hat manchmal mit konditionellen Aspekten zu tun, manchmal auch nur mit Zufällen, aber ich glaube manchmal ist das tatsächlich auch Anweisung und könnte es nicht da vielleicht hingehen, dass ich meinen Spieler, so wie ich im Tennis meinen Gegenspieler mental breche, grüße an John McEnroe, so kann ich das ja auch im Fußball mit einer Mannschaft vielleicht machen.
Ja, das sind auch Sachen, die zum Beispiel ein Klopp immer sehr auch schon mit einbezogen hat. Dortmund in der Zeit hatten immer die ersten 15 Minuten richtig hohes Pressing, dann zehn Minuten Pause und dann wieder zehn Minuten richtig hohes Pressing. Was ich den wichtigsten Begriff in dem Zusammenhang finde, ist der Begriff Selbstwirksamkeitserwartung.
Warte, warte, warte.
Selbstwirksamkeitserwartung bezeichnet in der Psychologie die eigene Erwartung an sich selbst. Ob ich daran glaube, dass das, was ich tue, wirksam wird. Ein ganz profales Beispiel, wenn ich denke, ich bin schlecht in Mathe, dann habe ich eine Selbstwirksamkeitserwartung auf den nächsten Mathe-Test, das ist schlecht. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch mein Ergebnis beeinflussen. Und im Fußball muss es gerade in der Jugendarbeit darum gehen, die Selbstwirksamkeitserwartung der Spieler möglichst hochzuschrauben. Also, dass sie in jede Aktion reingehen mit dem Gedanken, ich werde diese Aktion gelingen, weil ich das kann. Das funktioniert einerseits bei Motivation, aber auch bei Training. Wenn man ein perfekt ausgebildeter Spieler ist, der wird da weniger Berührungsängste haben mit sowas. Wenn ich einen dominanten Spielstil haben will, muss ich meinen Spielern auch da das mitgeben, dass sie von sich selbst erwarten, Erfolg zu haben und dass sie mit dieser Selbstwirksamkeitserwartung auch den Gegner natürlich einschüchtern können. Wenn Bayern München 50 Pässe am Stück spielt, dann gibt es keinen Gegner, der nicht innerlich denkt, auch scheiße, kommen wir jemals wieder an den Ball, was machen die mit uns? Das hat dann natürlich auch immer wieder psychologische Auswirkungen.
Ja, zahlt ja ein bisschen auf das ein, was ich gesagt habe. Weißt du was, ich habe noch einen längeren Ausschnitt von Thomas Tuchel, der ist für dich ideal, um mal kurz seine Stimme wieder aufzufrischen. Für mich übrigens auch. Aber ich finde, der zahlt ein bisschen darauf ein. Ich fand es, das ist eher eine Anekdote, aber ich fand es einfach interessant, weil letztlich hat das genau mit dem Punkt zu tun, über den wir beide gerade gesprochen haben. Wie muss ein Trainer heutzutage mental auf seine Spieler einwirken und wie wichtig ist eben diese Selbstwirksamkeitswahrnehmung? Hören wir mal rein und nehmen einen Schluck Getränk zu uns.
Wir spielen in Mediasch das Rückspiel. Wir haben am Ende des Tages 46 zu 4 Torschüsse und verlieren im Elfmeterschießen in Mediasch. Noch bevor die Euro League beginnt, sind wir ausgeschieden. Ich sitze am Flughafen, ich werde das nie vergessen. Wir warten auf unsere Maschine, um übrigens nach Frankfurt-Hahn zu fliegen. Wir warten, wir sitzen und ich habe noch nie eine Mannschaft so leer und so enttäuscht gesehen wie meine Mannschaft. Ich habe mich umgeschaut, ich habe selber auch kein Wort gesagt, ich werde diese Gesichter nie vergessen, es war alles leer. Das Problem an der Sache war, es war Donnerstag um 23 Uhr, wir sitzen in Mediasch, in the middle of nowhere am Flughafen, wir sind leer, k.o. es ist Donnerstag um 23 Uhr, am Samstag um 15.30 Uhr geht die Saison los vor ausverkauften neuen Stadion gegen den Vizemeister Bayerliberkusen. Ganzer Flug, ganze Fahrt von Hahn nach Mainz, ganze Nacht wach gewesen und überlegt, was können wir tun, in dieser Verfassung brauchen wir nicht antreten, es ist nicht möglich. Wir haben die Regel gebrochen, eine Gewohnheit gebrochen, die Mannschaft hat die Videoanalyse erwartet am nächsten Morgen, weil das der Normalfall ist, dass wir Videoanalyse vom Spiel machen, inhaltlich, was haben wir gut gemacht, was haben wir schlecht gemacht. Wir haben sie zusammengeholt in unserem Videoraum und ich lese ihnen jetzt das Zitat vor, das haben wir dann an die Wand geworfen. Ich habe in meiner Karriere 900 Würfe daneben geworfen. Ich habe fast 300 Spiele verloren, 26 Mal wurde mir der alles entscheidende Wurf anvertraut und ich habe ihn verfehlt. Ich habe immer und immer wieder versagt in meinem Leben und daher wurde ich so erfolgreich. Kennt ihr jemand, das Zitat? Nein, das ist Michael Jordan, also der erfolgreichste Mannschaftssportler, der glaube ich als Einziger alleine für Mannschaftserfolg gesorgt hat, hat diesen Satz gesagt, ich habe immer und immer wieder versagt und wurde deshalb so erfolgreich. Das haben wir ihm hingeworfen, wir haben danach fünf Minuten lang Bilder von Michael Jordan gezeigt, von seinen Trophäen, von seinen… wir haben ihnen damit gezeigt und vermittelt, dass es dazu gehört, so beschissen es sich für uns anfühlt und so bitter es ist, es gehört zu diesem Spiel, dass wir versagen, dass wir als Versager abgestempelt werden, dass wir Spiele verlieren, dass wir bitterste Momente haben, um uns weiterzuentwickeln. Wir haben auch dadurch, glaube ich, wirklich unbescheiden sagen zu können, auch durch diese Herangehensweise die Mannschaft in eine mentale Verfassung gebracht, um zwei Tage, einen Tag später, es war Freitagmittag, wir haben erstmal ausgeschlafen, alle zum Schlafen geschickt, um Freitagmittag, um am Samstag Leverkusen zu Hause im neuen Stadion 2-0 zu schlagen.
Man, was mir jetzt auffällt da gerade, man muss aber auch nicht alle Veränderungen immer so hochhängen. Weil, natürlich kann man jetzt Selbstwirksamkeitserwartungen groß reden und wie er da die Selbstwirksamkeitserwartungen seiner Spieler hochgesteckt hat und sowas, aber solche Motivationstricks gab's natürlich auch schon vor 50, 100 Jahren.
Da hast du recht. Ich dachte, das hat nur so gut zu deinem Punkt gepasst.
Ja, hat da sehr gut gepasst, aber es ist auch interessant, dass man dann halt immer bei sowas dann immer schnell kommt, Mensch, ist das cool, ist das neu. Wir reden jetzt viel über die Teiländerung im Fußball. Natürlich hat sich der Fußball verändert, aber man darf bitte, bitte, bitte nicht den Fehler machen und den Fußball von früher weniger komplex machen, als er war. Auch da gab es Trainer, die hauptamtlich bezahlt wurden, über Fußball nachzudenken. Und die haben das getan, haben auf ihre Weise damals das Beste gegeben und haben auch auf ihre Weise taktische Ideen gehabt. Natürlich andere als heute, weil natürlich heute auch die athletischen Fähigkeiten anders sind, die technischen Fähigkeiten der Spieler, da kann ich viel mehr mit anfangen. Aber Taktik ist etwas, was es in der Geschichte des Fußballs immer gab und was auch immer die Trainer beschäftigt hatten, was auch immer schon wichtig war. Vielleicht ist es heute noch wichtiger, aber es war immer wichtig und die großen Teams hatten immer auf irgendeine Weise sich einen taktischen Vorsprung gearbeitet. Und sei es nur, dass sie wussten, wie sie ihren Starspieler richtig einsetzen.
Und wie ist es mit der Wahrnehmung von Fußballtaktik jetzt bezogen auf Deutschland?
Ganz interessant, weil natürlich würde man jetzt behaupten, was jetzt klassisch ich sagen müsste, heutzutage ist Fußballtaktik wichtiger und es gibt Angebote wie Spielverlagerung und es wird viel mehr taktisch gemacht. Ist aber nichts Neues. Ich habe in meiner Recherche für mein Buch habe ich den Kicker durchgelesen und ich habe sämtliche Ausgaben zumindest überblättert von 1920 bis 1990. Da brauchte man den Kicker nicht mehr, da konnte man viel selber und auch Internetrecherche machen. Aber gerade die Ausgaben in den 30er bis in die 60er Jahre hinein waren extrem taktisch geprägt. Ich hatte ja vorhin schon erwähnt, dass zum 6 zu 3 Ungarns gegen England gab es eine Sonderausgabe mit zehn Seiten, wo zwei Seiten nur eine Analyse der Falschen Neuen war, wo ich halt auch zum ersten Mal diesen Begriff Falschen Neuen gelesen habe. Das war halt früher ein sehr wichtiges Thema und da wird auch viel drüber geredet. Ich habe auch auf meiner Facebook-Seite mal ein sehr schönes Zitat gepostet aus dem Kicker, wo ein Kickerautor sich im Jahre 1900, irgendwann in den 30er Jahren beschwert darüber, dass Fußball ihm heute viel zu viel Systemmeierei sei und dass die Leute den Fußball analysieren würden wie beim Darmgammiteeröffnung beim Schach. Das gab es schon 1935, da war der Kicker schon genervt von Fußballtaktik. Das ist nicht erst seit heute so. Das ist eine Wellenentwicklung gewesen, würde ich behaupten. Das ist so verloren gegangen in den 70er, 80er und 90er, wo man halt als verstaubt galt, dieses Reden um Systeme, dieses Verkopfen des Fußballs. Das ist dann wieder zurückgekommen, aber jetzt in der jetzigen Zeit natürlich auch mit mehr Möglichkeiten, mit dem Internet, mit der Möglichkeit, sehr viele Spiele. Zu sehen, dass auch Laien zu Experten werden können, was ja früher gar nicht möglich gewesen wäre. Das ist ja auch das, wo ich mein Wissen beziehe und in dem Sinne ist es, ich würde es nämlich nicht sagen, und Taktik ist Neues, sondern es ist ein Revival, das wir jetzt erleben, ein Revival des Nachdenkens über Fußball.
Aber würdest du mir zustimmen, wenn ich sage, Taktik spielt in der aktuellen Berichterstattung wieder eine größere Rolle als noch vor 15, 20 Jahren, auch wenn wir zum Beispiel Live-Kommentatoren uns ansehen und nicht nur die klassische Nachberichterstattung?
Klar, natürlich, natürlich. Also es hat die lange Zeit gar keine Rolle gespielt. Also ich habe es ja auch gerade erwähnt, bis in die 70er-Jahre war das wichtig, aber dann hat man das so vergessen, so hat man so gesagt. Man hat dann über die Startspielerberichte, man hat dann geguckt, wie sie spielen, man hat dann immer erklärt, okay, wenn der einen guten Tag hat, dann gewinnt er. Wenn man einen guten Tag hat, gewinnt Argentinien. Wenn Matthäus einen guten Tag hat, gewinnt Deutschland. So war dann die Berichterstattung etwa. Dadurch, dass Fußball jetzt durch 2006 auch nochmal viel mehr Volkssport ist, als er vorher war und auch die Massen viel mehr beschäftigt, wird auch viel mehr Platz geschaffen für Nischen. Das ist natürlich klar. Der Fußball ernährt jetzt sehr viel mehr Leute, als er noch vor 20 Jahren ernährt hat. Das muss man auch mal ganz klar dazu sagen. Letztlich ernährt der Fußball auch mich. Und dann ist natürlich auch möglich, dass man diese Nischen bedient mit Taktikanalysen, mit Schiedsrichtanalysen, mit Rasenfunk.
Und wie siehst du dieses Problem? Also wir beide sind ja sehr taktikinteressiert. Also bei dir steht es sowieso außerhalb jeder Frage, du hast ein Buch geschrieben über Fußball-Taktik. Aber auch ich musste mich jetzt nicht zwingen zu diesem Tribünengespräch, sondern ich wollte das unbedingt mit dir machen, weil ich Taktik so interessant finde. Und gleichzeitig reden wir aber über ein Spiel, in dem der Faktor Zufall, der Faktor Glück, der Faktor Verfassung, der Faktor Dinge, die ich gar nicht von außen betrachten kann, der Faktor Kopf eine unerlässliche Rolle spielt. Und immer wenn ich mit Aktiven spreche oder ehemaligen Aktiven, unter anderem auch Ralf Gunnisch, dann legen die viel, viel mehr Wert auf das Mentale, als auf Dinge, die ich so aus sachlich analytischer Ebene betrachte. Siehst du da vielleicht eine Gefahr, dass wir die falschen Prioritäten setzen?
Ich schreibe jetzt kurz vom Thema, aber ich komme gleich zurück. Es gab vor dem letzten Jahr eine große Debatte über Medienkrise und über wie man dafür sorgen kann, dass die Medien wieder mehr Geld verdienen und mehr Vertrauen in die Medienkrise. Und dann hat Stefan Negemeyer auf seinem Blog eine Zusammenfassung der Debatte gemacht. Er hat dann halt herausgearbeitet. Der Unternehmensberater empfiehlt, dass mehr Unternehmensberater eingestellt werden. Der Freiheit-Journalisten empfiehlt, dass mehr Freiheit-Journalisten Storys machen und so weiter und so fort. Was ich damit sagen möchte, wenn du mit einem Spieler über Fußball redest, dann wird der Spieler dir sagen, wie wichtig es ist, dass die Spieler, der einzelne Spieler und der einzelne mentale Faktor, wenn du mit einem Trainer redest über Fußball, wird dir der sagen, wie wichtig der Trainer ist und wie wichtig es ist, dass der Trainer sein Job gut macht. Wenn du mit mir über, wenn du mit einem Taktikanalyst über Fußball redest, wird dir der sagen, dass Taktik das Non-Pos-Ultra ist. Und wahrscheinlich nicht die Wahrheit irgendwo dazwischen. Also so, das ist meine Meinung zu dem Thema.
Ja, da hast du recht und man muss dann einfach immer nur finden, die richtige Mitte irgendwie finden und hoffen, dass man nicht zu weit abgedriftet ist. Ich glaube, es hängt auch so ein bisschen damit zusammen, dass alles, was so mit mentalen Dingen zu tun hat oder immer, wenn man externe Einflüsse ins Spiel mit einbezieht, die nicht taktischer Natur sind oder eindeutig irgendwie auf die Verfassung von Spielern zurückkommt, dann begebt man sich immer ein Stück weit ins Reich der Spekulation und vor allem ganz, ganz schnell in eine populistische Ecke. Und ich persönlich kriege da immer Gänsehaut und ich kriege manchmal bei Fragen, die ich in der Schlusskonferenz stelle, unwirkürlich Gänsehaut, weil ich mir denke, war das jetzt nicht ein Schritt zu sehr Doppelpass, um ehrlich zu sein?
Ja, genau, das ist auch deswegen, weswegen ich das mache, also diese Taktik, wie mich das so interessiert, weil natürlich spielt Zufall mit rein, das würde ich niemals bestreiten. Natürlich kann es auch einfach sein, dass der Stürmer an dem Tag was Schlechtes gegessen hat und den halben Tag auf dem Klo saß und deswegen nicht auf die Flügel ausgewichen ist. Aber ich kann es nicht sehen, ich kann es nicht mit frühen Gewissens sagen, es ist so. Natürlich hat man manchmal so Gedanken wie in die Mannschaft, okay, jetzt strengt sich die Mannschaft plötzlich an und die letzten zwei Wochen nicht, hat die gegen den Trainer gespielt, sowas. Aber ich möchte halt tatsächlich fair sein gegenüber auch den Spielern und gegenüber den Trainern und sagen, okay, was kann ich denn beobachten, wenn Team 4-4-2 spielt, das ist klar beobachtbar, das ist kein Hexenwerk, das ist nicht Interpretationssache, das Team spielt 4-4-2. So und deswegen finde ich, dass das eine interessante Art ist, Fußball zu sehen und auch natürlich in einer Zeit, wo sich die Mannschaften immer mehr abschorten, wo man immer weniger rankommt an die Spieler und auch an die Teams, wo immer mehr Trainings hinter verschlossenen Türen stattfinden, wo immer weniger von den Geheimnissen der Bildzeitung am nächsten Tag stehen. In solchen Zeiten ist das natürlich auch ein Ansatzpunkt, überhaupt irgendwie noch mit Fußball in Berührung zu kommen.
Also du konzentrierst dich quasi auf das Beobachtbare, das macht natürlich auch Sinn. Aber wie gehst du dann damit um, dass wir, wir zwei und auch jeder Zuschauer am Spielfeldrand die falsche Perspektive aus Spiel hat? Ich finde, das ist wirklich ein valider Punkt, den man sich immer, immer wieder vor Augen führen muss. So wie wir aufs Spielfeld gucken, selbst wenn wir in Reihe 7 sitzen, so guckt kein Spieler. Diese Enge, diese Entscheidungsschnelligkeit, die du brauchst, die kann keiner von uns, glaube ich, auch nur ansatzweise nachempfinden.
Ja, das ist eine ganz schwierige Sache. Das ist auch das, was dann nachher den Trainer von dem unterscheidet, was ich bin. Ich fühle mich immer geehrt, wenn die Leute so Witze auf Twitter machen. Ja, Tobias Escher übernimmt das Team oder Spielverlager übernimmt das Team. Wo ich mir immer denke, damit wäre niemandem geholfen, weil ich habe so einen ganz, ganz anderen Blick auf das als Trainer. Der Trainer muss tatsächlich dann sagen, okay, der muss dann in Details gehen. Der muss dann gucken, okay, wie hält er den Fuß? Bringt das was, wenn er den Fuß 30 Grad weiter an den Rechts hält? Wohin guckt der Spieler und sowas? Und das ist dann das, was ein Trainer letztlich im Detail regeln muss und das auch, was ein Spieler regeln muss. Aber wenn ich auf die Taktik gucke und wie das Team steht, ich glaube, dann kann man das schon von oben halbwegs gut erkennen, weil der Trainer sich das auch von oben denkt. Wenn die Perspektive, die ich auf den 4-4-2 vom Oberrang Tribüne gucke, ist nicht groß anders, als wenn ich auf die Taktik-Tafel gucke. Und der Trainer wird auch an der Taktik-Tafel seinem Team erklären, okay, heute verteidigen wir 4-4-2, wir stehen so, so und so sind die Abstände. Natürlich trainiert man das alles und die Spieler sehen das eher in eigenen Augen. Aber es ist ja trotzdem in einem gewissen Maße von oben gedacht.
Das stimmt, aber die Lösungen müssen von unten gefunden werden.
Deswegen, wie gesagt, es ist ein ganz anderer Job, den ich mache.
Da sind dann Dreiecke. Das hört sich so wahnsinnig banal an. Wenn du aber mal selber, ey, da musst du nur mit deinen Freunden kicken gehen in der Halle. Wenn immer zwei Leute freistehen, wenn du einen Ball hast, ist das eine riesige Erleichterung.
So sehen, wo ich stehen muss und auch, dass es geht noch, also das geht noch. So ein Dreieck bilden geht noch. Krass, wenn du kleine, junge Kinder hast, kriegst du das schnell hin, dass sie das machen. Aber dann hinzubekommen, dass der Spieler, der angespielt ist, auch wieder ein Dreieck hat. Und dass der Spieler, der den Spieler anspielt, auch wieder ein Dreieck hat. Das ist ja letztlich die hohe Kunst. Das ist ja letztlich das, was Trainer schaffen müssen, was dann die Spieler aus ihrer Perspektive aussehen müssen. Das ist der Unterschied zu dem, was ich mache, der dann einfach sagen kann, hey, da vorne ist kein Dreieck, ihr seid scheiße. Also das war einfach zu sagen.
Ja klar, wir legen den Finger in die Wunde und die Trainer machen die Seibe drauf und müssen das irgendwie verbessern und beheben. Und zwar aus der Sicht, die wir nicht haben, nämlich aus der Sicht auf dem Platz. Ich bin ja gespannt, ob da vielleicht die Technik tatsächlich uns irgendwann ein bisschen näher ranholt. Also wenn ich mir – das ist jetzt ein doofes Beispiel – aber wenn ich mir die Schiedsrichter cam bei Rugby oder bei NHL-Spielen, gibt es das auch manchmal, angucke, dann hast du schon diese andere Perspektive auf dem Platz. Gleichzeitig haben wir immer mehr Live-Daten, die auch ins Fernsehbild eingebettet werden. Und wenn es vielleicht wirklich irgendwann mal durch Kamera und Technologie kein Problem mehr ist, dass wir auch hin und wieder mal Schnittbilder haben, wo ich aus Spielersicht eine Situation sehe und wo ich vielleicht sehe, okay, der ist heute schon 9 Kilometer gelaufen und das war gerade sein 13. Sprint in den letzten 10 Minuten. Vielleicht kommen wir da ein bisschen näher, vielleicht auch wieder ran, auch als Zuschauer. So, Tobi, kaum zu glauben, dass das hier eine Fünf steht bei den Stunden. Ich freue mich auf die Postproduktion. Aber ein Thema noch kurz und dann entlasse ich dich mit allen Lorbeeren, die ich auch nur irgendwie hier in München für dich finden kann, weil ich weiß, dass die Frage kommt. Lass uns noch kurz durchgehen, welche Bücher und Quellen du für interessant hältst. Ich werde dir auch alle in die Show notes packen. Und dann auch noch, welche Quellen für Daten von Statistiken von Spielen du konsultierst. Fangen wir mal mit Büchern und anderen Medien an.
Wenn man sich ein Buch aussuchen müsste, das man über das Thema liest, dann ist es wahrscheinlich Jonathan Wilson und seine Geschichte der Fußballtaktik. Wenn man einfach sagt, ich will das, was er heute noch mal gesagt hat, in eloquent, witzig, aber auch interessant hören.
Dann kauft man Tobias Escher.
Das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber ich meine jetzt einfach nur, wie viel geschehen in der Fußballtaktik. Das ist jetzt auch kein Humble Bragging, aber was Jonathan Wilson gemacht hat, ist natürlich noch fünfmal intensiver als das, was ich gemacht habe. Ich habe es für ein Land gemacht, in der Herz für die ganze Welt gemacht. Deswegen, das ist das Nummer-1-Buch. Dann gibt es halt noch viele gute Bücher, die wir teilweise auch schon genannt haben. Christoph Biermann natürlich eine Anlaufstelle mit der Ball ist runter, damit das Spiel die Richtung ändern kann. Will ich jetzt gar nicht böse sein, schätze Christophs Arbeit sehr, aber das Buch, wenn man Wilson gelesen hat, braucht man es nicht unbedingt. Wenn ich von Biermann jetzt etwas empfehlen würde, dann eher einerseits, wenn wir vom Fußball träumen über das Ruhrgebiet, aber auch die Fußballmatrix.
Ja, absolut.
Weil da nochmal so das, was wir am Ende sehr stark gemacht haben, wie sehen diese modernen Methoden aus, was kann man da rausholen mit Neuro-Wissenschaften und sowas, das ist ja in diesem Buch dann letztlich drin.
Ja, sehr empfehlenswert, das stimmt.
Und wenn ich noch eins empfehlen dürfte, dann wäre das auf jeden Fall noch Raphael Honigstein. Das Reboot, bis zu der vierte Stern auf Deutsch. Ein Buch, das großartig beschreibt diesen Weg, den der deutsche Fußball nach 2000 gegangen ist und wie man dann 2014 zum WM-Sieg kam. Das Buch hat mich tatsächlich ein bisschen geärgert, weil das ist eines dieser Bücher, wo man sich denkt, das hätte ich gerne selber geschrieben.
Das stimmt. Wobei ich ihn auch wahnsinnig beneidet habe um die Zugänge, die er hatte, und gleichzeitig habe ich einen wahnsinnigen Respekt vor dem Rechercheaufwand. Also er saß ja wirklich bei Scouts usw. in der Wohnung.
Ganz tolles Buch. Und dann, let's last but not least, gibt es dann noch mein schönes Buch. Vom Liebherr zur Doppel-Sechs. Er erscheint am 22.04. Im Buchladen Ihres Vertrauens können Sie es bestellen. Sie können es auf Spielverlagerung.de bestellen oder – bei Amazon gibt es das natürlich auch das Buch oder bei allen Internet-Buchhändlern – geht um die Geschichte der Fußball-Taktik in Deutschland von 1870, als der Ball dann nach Deutschland kam, bis in die heutige Zeit 2014. Und hat mich auch viel Zeit meines Lebens gekostet. Also es war kein einfaches Buch zu schreiben, sagen wir es mal so.
Und das Angenehme ist – und das ist wirklich ernst gemeint – man merkt das dem Buch nicht an. Ein letztes Mal noch – ich habe es jetzt zwar schon oft empfohlen, aber es ist wirklich ein gutes Buch. Bitte holt es euch. Ich glaube, für dich persönlich am vorteilhaftesten ist, wenn man es sich auf Spielverlagerung.de bestellt. Also bitte auf Spielverlagerung.de bestellen und es lohnt sich wirklich. Und damit habe ich jetzt aber auch wirklich ein letztes Mal noch vollkommen zur Rechtwerbung dafür gemacht.
Wenn ich noch einmal Werbung machen darf, einen kleinen Punkt kurz herausheben darf. Es ist verständlich. Also das haben mir schon viele gesagt, aber das muss man nochmal vorstreichen, weil natürlich manche Leute haben Angst vor Spielverlagerung. Teilweise auch zu Recht, weil es sprachlich nicht immer einfach ist, weil viele Fachbegriffe, aber dieses Buch ist extra so gedacht, dass jeder das verstehen kann. Meine Frau hat das Buch gelesen und meine Frau fragt, weiß nicht, was eine Flanke ist. Die hat mich erstmal gefragt, was ist eine Flanke. So, und die hat das Buch verstanden. Und dann hoffe ich, dass ich damit ein bisschen die Angst nehmen kann. So, jetzt habe ich auch genug Eigenwerbung gemacht.
Ja, aber das soll ja schon, also wenn man sich fünf Stunden x Zeit nimmt, dann soll das auch mal sein dürfen. Außerdem, du hast vorhin schon darauf hingewiesen, es gibt eine Reihe von Büchern, die einzelne Ligen behandeln, die auch – da sind überdurchschnittlich viele Gute mit dabei. Du hast Oranier Brillant genannt von David Winner. Es gibt auch Harle, Better, Faster, Stronger, glaube ich, von Raphael Honigstein über die Premier League. Das Buch über die Super League ist hervorragend. Das Buch von Birgit Schönau zur Serie A ist sehr gut. Werde ich auch noch alles in die Show Notes packen. Kann ich persönlich noch sehr empfehlen. Da habe ich auch viel Wissen draus gezogen. Was konsultierst du denn für Online-Medien?
Spielverlegerung.de – logischerweise. Sonst noch sehr wichtig für meine Arbeit, whoscored.com. Ich werde immer wieder gefragt, woher kann man gute Statistik beziehen. whoscored.com hat alle Statistiken, die man braucht, bis auf den Laufwert.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen, ob ich die da nicht gefunden habe.
Bis auf den Laufwert, aber ansonsten, wer hat welchen Spieler angepasst? Wer hat welche Zweikamper beschritten? Wer hat Keep-Passes, also Pässe, die zu Torschüssen geführt haben und so weiter und so fort? Und ich bastel mir auch selber meine Statistiken immer aus diesen Statistiken heraus. Das ist ein sehr befriedigendes Gefühl. Das ist eine sehr wichtige Seite für meine Arbeit. Ansonsten, ich überlege gerade, es gibt noch mehrere Seiten über Taktikanalysen, balfourlieb.eu zum Beispiel, das sind die österreichischen Kollegen, Sonal Marking natürlich, den hatten wir ganz am Anfang mal genannt, aber soll natürlich hier auch wieder genannt werden, der Taktikanalysen anbietet, Michael Cox auf Englisch.
Übrigens gibt es auch sowohl von Ball verliebt als auch von euch von Spielverlagungen auch einen Podcast, der auch empfehlenswert ist auf jeden Fall. Ich habe bei mir auf der Liste noch 442 und ich nutze tatsächlich für die Laufstatistiken furchtbarerweise Bundesliga.de.
Das ist ja nicht furchtbarerweise.
Na ja, ansonsten.
Okay.
Ja, okay, wenn du es sagst, dann ist es auch wieder okay.
Fußball, Bundesliga.de war lange Zeit überlegen, finde ich mittlerweile nicht mehr. Leider haben sie ihre Matrix so ein bisschen.
Ja, die hatten das größte Parcreditor bei Opta gekauft. Das ist ja das eigentlich Interessante, dass man immer auf dasselbe Daten-Widget zugreift, nur unterschiedliche Funktionen sind freigeschaltet. Was ich zum Beispiel noch sehr gerne verwende, ist das Opta-Widget auf süddeutsche.de, denn da kann man sich die realtaktischen Positionen ganz gut anzeigen lassen. Dafür nehme ich das immer her. Ja, ja, ja, das sind aber auch dann schon die wichtigsten Sachen. Und transfermarkt.de immer ganz gern für Saisonverlauf und weiteres Restprogramm.
Ja, natürlich, klar. Also das sind natürlich dann die Standard-Dinger, so transfermarkt.de. Kickwelt, glaube ich. Weißen Sie? Die haben ja auch immer viele historische Sachen drin. Vielleicht noch erwähnenswert, YouTube. Tatsächlich gerade für historische Spiele eine Footgrube, weil da sind sie nicht immer so dran mit Sperren. Lustigerweise sind sie bei EM-Spielen sehr schnell dabei zu sperren, bei WM-Spielen sind sie sehr zu großzügig. Die FIFA scheint da nicht so darauf zu achten wie die UEFA. Wer historische Spiele sehen will, der kann da einfach mal gucken.
Ich glaube, ich weiß sogar warum. Es gibt einen Podcast, eine Ausgabe von Online-Marketing-Rockstars-Podcast. Da haben sie einen, ich glaube, er sagt sein Alter nicht, aber ich glaube, der ist 25, 26, der hat eine eigene Agentur gegründet, kam von MediaCraft, diesem YouTube-Netzwerk und der hat sich darauf spezialisiert, lizenzrechtlich geschützte Inhalte aus YouTube rauszunehmen und arbeitet unter anderem für die Bundesliga. Und ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass sie es auch für die UEFA machen und für die FIFA aber eben nicht.
Das verstehe ich dann immer nicht, aber dann sind wir jetzt wieder ganz weit am Schluss. Da wollen wir jetzt mal nicht drüber reden.
Ne, sonst haben wir jetzt wirklich über alles geredet. Ich habe für die Vorbereitung dieser Sendung noch einige Einzelartikel verwendet. Es ist auch gar nicht alles zur Sprache gekommen. Man mag es kaum glauben, dass ich noch Dinge ausgespart habe. Pack ich alles in die Show notes. Also sollte es irgendjemand geben, dem fünf Stunden irgendwas nicht genügend sind. Es gibt noch viele, was ihr weiter lesen könnt, wenn ihr einfach aufrasenfunk.de. Tobi, gibt es noch einen Insidertipp, den du Taktik-Hipstern geben kannst? Ich weiß noch, eine legendäre Schlusskonferenz, in der du mal Bordeaux, glaube ich, hervorgehoben hast, als du erst gesagt hast, in der Bundesliga ist alles schlecht und du guckst jetzt nur noch Bordeaux. Gibt es da aktuell was, was du gerne guckst? Marcel, das stimmt der Stimme.
Wem sollen wir jetzt in die Abgründe des Taktik-Hepsatums gehen?
Aber so ganz kurz.
Moment, den Namen habe ich nicht ganz auf dem Schirm, den muss ich einmal kurz googeln. Es geht um jetzt, wir sind jetzt gelandet im polnischen Fußball. Und zwar ist dort ein spannendes Meisterrennen mit einem Außenseiter, der sich mit offensiven Fußball in das Herz der polnischen Fans gespielt hat. Und zwar handelt es sich um Piaz Gliwice. Klar, kennt man. Die nur zwei Punkte hinter den großen Favoriten aus Warschau sind, das Ligia Marschow, und die auch eine interessante Dreikette spielen und offensiven Fußball.
Das ist jetzt schon ziemlich cool, verstehst du? So Leute wie ich, wir feiern noch Lester und du hast schon irgendwelche polnischen Vereine auf der Matte. Nicht schlecht, Tobi. Genauso was habe ich mir erhofft, das Runde, das alles setzt schön ab. Ja, weißt du was, wir hören jetzt noch einen ganz kurzen Thomas Duchel-O-Ton. Dann haben wir quasi dieses komplette Video-Interview von ihm verbraten. Und dann entlassen wir unsere Höhere in den Feierabend.
Es ist auf dem Niveau, auf dem wir jetzt Fußball spielen, in meiner Überzeugung ein ganz klares Players-Game und kein Coaches-Game. Es ist ein Coaches-Game bei der U15, es ist bei den 16- 17- 18-Jährigen absolut ein Spiel, das vom Coach gewonnen und gesteuert wird und entscheidend beeinflusst wird. Aber auf diesem Niveau, mit der Spielerfahrung und dem Talent, aus meiner Sicht ein klares Players-Game und die Rolle von mir, die Rolle des Trainerteams, ist eine Dienstleisterrolle. Wir sind die Dienstleister, wir unterstützen und helfen.
Thomas Tuchel als Dienstleister. Ich habe es im Intro schon verbraten, weil ich das Zitat sehr interessant fand. Und vielleicht ist der entscheidende Punkt wirklich, dass er so die Nachwuchsarbeit hervorhebt. Ich habe dich tot geredet, ich merke es.
Nee, wenn wir jetzt wieder anfangen, komm.
Nee, nee, wir lassen es. Tobi ist dabei. Also, liebe Leute da draußen, Tobias Escher bei Twitter et tobiasescher beim Rowold Verlag mit Vom Lieber Rot zur Doppel-Sechs startet er seine große Autorenkarriere. Bei Facebook gibt es eine Facebook-Seite Vom Lieber Rot zur Doppel-Sechs, die ihr liken könnt. Bei Bundesliga ist er immer zu Gast. Da bin ich ein bisschen neidisch auf Bundesliga. Das solltet ihr unbedingt gucken. Tobi, vielen, vielen, vielen, vielen Dank. Hat mir großen Spaß gemacht.
Ich habe herzlich zu danken, dass du mir quasi hier mir einen 5-Stunden-Teppich ausgebreitet hast, in dem ich all meine Weisheiten verbraten konnte.
Ja, Wahnsinn. Bei anderen hätte es nicht für eine halbe Stunde gereicht. Ich sage es dir. Ja, schön. Ich danke dir sehr. Ich danke auch allen Hörern, die das hier gehört haben. Hinterlasst uns gerne Feedback. Wir freuen uns über Rezensionen bei iTunes. Wir freuen uns auch über Likes bei Facebook und über neue Follower bei Twitter. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer, Max Jakob Ost. Freue mich auch über Feedback. Unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr auch bei unseren Sendungen mitmachen. Unter anderem sprechen wir ja in der Schlusskonferenz immer über den Bundesligaspieltag, der zurückliegt. Und in diesem Sinne, wir glücklichen euch dazu, dass ihr euch so viel Zeit mit Fußballtaktik auseinandergesetzt habt. Und danke nochmal, Tobi, ganz herzlich. Und dann bis zum nächsten Tribünengespräch. 24 flocke Stunden über, was weiß ich, Trainingsmethodik. Mal gucken, was ich mir bis dahin anfangen lasse. Vielen Dank, Tobi, vielen Dank liebe Hörer und bis bald. Macht's gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäusern.
Ich hab ja gestern für die Vorbereitungen hierauf, hab ich ja gestern das Auf-Slipper-Spiel-Pool-Spiel verzichtet.
Was echt? Nein, das hast du nicht wirklich gemacht.